so these are times angela davis told the
left forum last night for deep thinking
and analysis feminist analysis she said
in fact of the interlinkages of our
issues
among those
we live in a nation that locks seven
million of us behind bars
that's engaged in its longest most
costly war on terror
even as 46 million
face the terror of hunger and poverty at
home
a terror that forces many to sign up to
serve in that no same wars
we live in a nation where the richest
0.1
those with 20 million dollars or more
have doubled their share of our nation's
wealth since the 1960s
under our system of rigged prices
monopoly capitalism and financialization
of every bit of us down to our very
homes
that wealth of the top 1 thousandths
compounds
as does the poverty
and the two parties of property with
their police
and their borders
and their drones
and their detention camps
keep it that way
and our money media calls it a democracy
these are the times the tribe tri-men's
souls wrote thomas paine in 1776
speaking of life under british rule
in this special luncheon feature three
men accustomed to deep thinking
are going to apply themselves to the
legacy of pain and consider the
standards he identified for rebellion
are they met as well today
in the corporate imperial age of the
koch brothers
as they were then under the hereditary
rule of george iii in the royal east
india company
angela davis called on us to consider
our history i've been asked just briefly
to sketch pains
in order to do that just briefly i'd say
that his common sense rights of man and
age of reason were the most widely read
political essays of the 18th century not
only in this country but in europe too
common sense published in 1776 is
credited with giving the war of
independence its rhetorical fire and its
vision of a non-hereditary state with a
constitution
he gave us the terms united states and
counter-revolution too
and he lived long enough to see and
participate in his way i would say in
both
he died in greenwich village in 1809
common sense the idea came with him from
the uk
where he was born in 1737 in a region
called east anglia
his were rebellious times where the
echoes of the levelers and the diggers
hung in the air common people
who'd fought privatization in the
enclosure of land and found themselves
executed and incarcerated on mass
because they demanded their natural born
right to the commons
paine apprenticed as a corset maker a
profession that took off as women's
lives not just our wastes
we're being shrunk
from robust vital things equal
participants in life
to child rearers enclosed domestic
objects
at least women of a certain class
in 1757 payne went to sea aboard the
king of prussia
as egalitarian-minded sailors and
pirates
protested impressment
forced labor forced service in the
military payne stood up against
impressment
in the rights of man
aboard ship as historian peter limbaugh
has taught us payne would have served
with people from all over the world
including africans irish and blacks from
the caribbean
he would have participated or at least
witnessed their grumbling and perhaps
their
rebellions on board ship
he certainly was aware of their
rebellions against the british
throughout the seventeen hundreds
in which caribbean blacks africans irish
and even some of the colonized americans
too
but certainly the hetero homo
mob
the rowdies
carried with them the world the word of
slave revolts into the streets of what
were to become the united states
including new york's own streets
those slave revolts let's date them
jamaica 1760 bermuda and nevis 1761
suriname 62 63 68 and 72 british
honduras grenada monserrat saint vincent
tobago saint croix saint thomas saint
kitts throughout the 1760s and the 70s
there were rebellions
and they moved to the south alexandria
virginia in 1767 perth amboy new jersey
1772 saint andrews parish south carolina
and in a joint african and irish effort
in boston in 1774.
thomas payne arrived in america that
year and immediately wrote against
slavery
we have it in our powers to begin the
world over again he wrote in common
sense
twenty years later
in agrarian justice
he acknowledged that even after
independence the world was in need of
serious remaking he wrote the present
state of civilization is as odious as it
is unjust
it is absolutely the opposite of what it
should be
and it is necessary that a revolution
should be made in it
the contrast of affluence and
wretchedness continually meeting and
offending the eye is like dead and
living bodies chained together
it wasn't just a us problem it was a
global problem he wrote the great mass
of the poor in all countries have become
a hereditary race
and is next to impossible for them to
get out of that state for themselves
for the sake of justice and humanity he
said not in 76 but in 1796
it is necessary to make change
specifically to make quote property
productive of national blessing
extending to every individual not just a
few
are we in times that try our souls
for sure let's hear it are we
are we in revolutionary times
that's the question we're going to
address today
and we'll recall angela davis who said
we should not be afraid to ask for what
we want
what robin kelly has called our freedom
dreams she said need not bear the
imprint of compromise
so
ask away
compromise not
to address all of this and more we have
richard wolff professor of economics
emeritus at the university of
massachusetts amherst visiting professor
at the new school graduate program
author of many wonderful books including
democracy at work a cure for capitalism
occupy the economy challenging
capitalism and capitalism hits the fan
the global economic meltdown and what to
do about it he also hosts the wonderful
weekly economic update on wbai fm in new
york
and syndicated nationally
chris hedges spent 20 years as a foreign
correspondent 15 of those for the new
york times where he was part of a team
that won a pulitzer prize
until he denounced the bush
administration's call to invade iraq and
lost his post at the times
he's the author of the bestsellers
empire of illusion war is a force that
gives us meaning and death of the
liberal class and he writes a weekly
column that you must read for the
website truthdig
cornell west has called himself a blues
man in the life of the mind long time
princeton professor
now at union theological seminary he's
best known for his classic race matters
democracy matters and his memoir brother
west living and loving out loud
he appears frequently on many programs
when they let him
as well as
on his dear brother tavis smiley's pbs
tv show he can be heard weekly with
tavis on smiley and west the national
public radio program distributed by
public radio international and i believe
also heard on wbai
thank you all we will um
the format
is going to be as follows uh wonderful
gina kim here has distributed cards if
you have questions you should write
those questions on a card we do not
absolutely do not guarantee to answer
all your questions
but we will um sort through discover
some themes and pose some questions to
the
speakers
once they've laid out their argument for
about 45 minutes i'll get a chance to
pose a couple of questions of my own
and we'll have you out of here in 90
minutes or fewer enjoy
[Applause]
okay how's that okay we selected payne
for a couple reasons uh first of all
he's
uh arguably the only real revolutionary
theorist america has produced uh we've
produced some admirable anarchists
uh emma goldman and
alexander berkman noam chomsky
dorothy day and others
we have produced
some
powerful
prophetic voices
out of oppressed communities
whether that is
you know frederick douglass or
malcolm x
my friend cornell west and others
but in terms of revolutionary theorists
we have almost none uh paine may be uh
the only one uh in many ways he was the
first uh intellectual in the sense that
he never tied himself to a political
party he was always in opposition to
power and i thought it opened the
discussion uh with rick and cornell
uh
by uh highlighting some of his major
strengths ones that i think we can learn
from uh the first would be that pain in
a way that uh many of the
uh
uh four uh
figures of the revolution were not uh
understood the monarchy understood
british power he didn't come to the
united states until he was 37. and part
of his job in common sense was to
explain
the structures of power to the colonies
uh who didn't understand them even
figures like benjamin franklin
up until the very last moment wanted to
build a rapprochement with uh the king
uh and payne it was part of payne's job
to explain why this wasn't possible and
i think one of the things that uh i
think all three of us probably feel and
i'll stop in a second and let you both
address this is
that there has been a misreading on the
part of the american left and even among
the progressive community of the
structures of power and for that reason
it has rendered us impotent we have
effectively been channeling our energy
back into a dead political system i
wrote
many of nader's major speeches for him
in the 2008 election and going back to
2008 there were a lot of people at the
left forum who had uh drunk the kool-aid
for barack obama and i think that that
was because they had
quite been diverted quite effectively
into the personal narrative of a
candidate which is irrelevant
in terms of understanding the mechanisms
of power and just as pain understood
that the imperial power of the british
uh
had essentially blinded itself that that
it's hubris uh made it incapable of
listening which is why you had one of
the largest armadas uh 350 ships sent on
new york uh i think we are in a very
similar moment as well and uh maybe
begin
cornell with you and
talk a little bit about the that
idea of structure of
uh yeah
did you want to say something brother
wolf before i say something
okay
i think it's for me it's not just the
question of that structural power it's
true that that thomas paine
comes at 30 at 37 years old to the new
world and already has a critique of not
just good and bad kings but a monarchy
as a whole
so he's talking about a structural
systemic analysis that most of the
americans at the time had not moved
toward
that in 1776 there were over 400
pamphlets published the one pamphlet we
still read common sense so there's a
number of voices being lifted but here
this 37 year old who arrives lays bare
this critical structure of power but
keep in mind who he was
his father was a quaker
he and he inherited a fundamental
solidarity with the downtrodden with
those who were excluded
that he was willing always to cut
radically against the grain in his
conception of himself at 37 was
he was going to die
he was going to be willing to die
if he
ensuring that he would act honorably
think critically
that he would be willing to sacrifice
his popularity for truth and justice and
would always fuse with other folk on the
ground in grassroots movements and so
even as he lays barely's critical
structure of power he has a conception
of himself that is quaker-like i mean he
was not an atheist he was a deist he
hated organized religion he hated dogma
especially religious dogma but also
ideological dogma and viewed himself as
first and foremost
a member of those sly stone called
everyday people
he was a commoner to the core
and he engaged in a revolutionary act
and how he wrote not just what he wrote
because how he wrote was a critique of
the pomposity and the obscurity of the
lack of the latin greek obsessed
language of the edmund burks and others
that he was going to speak a language
that was so clear he said i want to
write as plain as the alphabet for
common folk because i come out of the
common folk so that was a revolution in
form and style and it was the first time
that folk who hardly could read it all
could be read too
and get through
a language that was part of their
colloquial style
that was part of how they communicated
going back to the artisanal class he was
not working class he was an artisanal
class in in fedford village there in in
norfolk but he fundamentally identified
with the common folk what we don't have
today is we don't have intellectuals he
was the first american modern
intellectual unconnected
no doubt about that what we don't have
today intellectuals who have not been
seduced by the professional managerial
carriage
and the subculture of the university who
are fundamentally committed to the
plight and predicament of commoners
everyday people working people poor
people and view their calling not their
career as having an organic connection
with their struggles no matter how
strong or no matter how weak they are
now there are some intellectuals that do
that fewer and fewer and fewer why
because what thomas paine didn't have to
deal with is the backdrop of impending
ecological catastrophe
the backdrop of possible nuclear
catastrophe
the fashionable character of being
cynical and despairing even as you are
highly professionally approved and
recognized
the sipping tea in the cafes
with a sharp analysis but no willingness
to pay a cost
no willingness to take a risk no
military no willingness to cut radically
against the grain
and of course he
dealt with the consequences you talked
to me he died right here in greenwich
village 72 years old
six people at his funeral two of them
black because that critique of african
slavery the first piece he wrote in
march of 1775 was real that led toward
the founding of the first
anti-abolitionist society in the new
world he was fundamentally committed to
a critique of white supremacy very rare
often times among highly visible
white intellectuals
brother chris is rare stanley around him
is rare rick wolf rare
eric phone and rare we can go
we can call the list because the list is
so short
i'm not just talking about making a
symbolic gesture i'm talking about
fundamentally committed to your analysis
it's where white supremacy is an
integral integral factor among other
crucial factors and then you make the
organic connection that's the kind of
brother thomas payne was and it is very
very difficult to build on his legacy
even though we have to acknowledge just
how
crucial that challenge is
i want to pick up on something that you
all just did
uh when laura was still speaking before
we started
she asked how much change was needed or
some words that affect and it was a
strong clear statement yes
then she asked about revolution
much less strong
much more wobbling
now tom paine is exactly about that
difference
just as the name of this conference
the name we chose for this conference is
reform and revolution
faced with a situation that's becoming
more and more
unequal unfair unjust and intolerable
what are we going to do
and what pain
for me
what makes him stand out
is the care
that he takes to go right after that
question
and the way i hear it
is this
we now face he says about his time
more than enough evidence decade upon
decade of accumulated outrages
injustices attacks on our freedoms our
rights and our security
in a sense we've tried
to address this one and that one to work
out an accommodation here to get a
reform over there
we've been there
and we've done it
and it hasn't worked
and we got to face that we can't make
reforms most of the time because the
power structure arrayed against us
blocks us
but even worse
when occasionally we get a reform
same power structure having lost the
effort to block it
now goes to work to undo it to reverse
it and to go right back to where they
were
therefore the conclusion pain reaches
and tries to teach the american people
then
is the same one i think many of us want
to teach now
you've got to change the system
not because it's an alternative to being
achieving reforms
but because changing the system is the
only way
to make a reform that's durable
revolution is the way you complete the
reform process
just as it's the condition for the
reforms you get to last and to mean what
you wanted them to mean when you fought
for them that's why the word revolution
rang in pain's work so powerfully
it's a big change not this not that we
have to say to the king of england go
home
you're out of here
it's
over the british empire hundreds of
years of dominance
we quit we're go you're out of here
a powerful
ending of the colonial relationship that
gave this country its modern birth
its whole history
an amazing thing to say to the people to
separate
and yet aren't we in the same
isn't that the legacy for us too
to finally say
and let me pick up on one theme here
because i know many of you have
encountered references to or if you
have a lot of time you've read the book
by thomas piketty
a lot of time is 600 pages yes it takes
a long time
and he's a good economist but as a
writer
not so much
uh
yes it's in our profession that's
absolutely normal um
the
but his point is the same isn't it
he says he studied capitalism for 250
years he and his colleagues says in in
california at berkeley are the go-to
statisticians to understand the
distribution of wealth and income in the
world these days
and his conclusion in that book capital
in the 21st century is that capitalism
inherently
anywhere and everywhere it has been
established produces as its inherent
tendency a growing inequality of wealth
and income
periodically he points out people get so
freaked by this that they push back and
we have a reform
and as soon as it's over the same
capitalism undoes the reform
and we all know that don't we here in
the united states because the last 40
years is the undoing of the new deal
there it is again
and so pain comes to us
and when chris said to me initially
let's start with thomas paine
now i see what was in his mind
he is teaching us you got to have the
courage
to make a systemic change
you've been to the reform
table you've tried it repeatedly
you have to learn the lesson we are at
the stage of taking a major new step so
of course we're a little nervous as your
hesitant comments to laura indicated
but the logic
now
is something we can understand thanks to
pains pushing through the way chris and
cornell just said
i think the the thing about pain that's
also very important and cornell alluded
to this is language
what the linguists call mutual knowledge
um and pinker has written stephen pinker
has written about this that
language is a vehicle by which reality
is filtered through to you
and part of payne's power which is the
power of all great revolutionary writers
is that he utterly upended that language
to the uh extent that he redefined terms
like democracy democracy was a
pejorative
republicanism or the republic was a
pejorative
and pain reclaimed those words and gave
them a new definition the other thing
which cornell also mentioned which is
important about pain is that he spoke in
the language or he wrote in the language
of
everyday people now um that
as a writer is deceptive um because it's
actually extremely difficult
um orwell mastered that capacity orwell
once said that you know i want as a
writer i want to be that clear window
pane by which people can see through and
payne did that
and when he writes his response to
edmund burke
uh
uh the rights of man uh he goes after
burke's very florid style
and i think language and i'll you know
want to raise this with both of you is
extremely important because we live in a
society now where those who have power
have created specialized vocabularies
that shut the rest of us out economists
have been particularly good at this
but just about the technocrat and we and
we are ruled by technocrats uh has
created a specialized vocabulary that
those of us on the outside are not able
to penetrate and that becomes a kind of
barrier in terms of our ability to
exercise our rights as citizens to
influence power and pain understood that
extremely well
and it's why
his writings were so effective he's an
incredible writer i mean common sense
is arguably one of the greatest essays
in english
when he writes uh the rights of man
especially the second part and and it
becomes extremely important because in
that second part of the rights of man he
actually outlines the whole welfare
state
and the pit government goes nuts william
pitt
and they pass uh the two act law which
uh bans um just as we see in the wake of
the occupy movement bans large public
gatherings uh makes it a lot easier to
prosecute people for treason uh payne
himself is tried for sedition and has to
flee to france i mean has amazing life
he ends up as a one of two foreign
delegates in the national convention
stands up and opposes the regicide of
louis xvi the jacobins turn on him he
ends up in prison
but when he writes the rights of man he
gives to the english working class and
you have to remember that the working
class in england at the time was in far
worse
economic state
than the white working class in the
united states
three out of four or
people in uh large metropolitan cities
in europe were either poppers or beggars
uh and and when the pitt government it
creates all sorts of uh
worker organizations that begin to
discuss political issues the pitt
government shuts it down and drives it
underground but i think and ep thompson
makes this point that one of the reasons
payne is actually better known in
england is because he gave them the
whole vocabulary to the to the kind of
working-class radical labor movement and
i think that that's an extremely
important issue and i and i think that
this gets to rick's point is people's
reaction is that we are still in a
process of searching for the language by
which we can number one describe the
political and social and economic
reality that we are enduring and how to
respond
and i think at the center of that
revolution in form and style of thomas
paine
was a
genuine anger
a righteous indignation
of the conditions of the people that he
was fundamentally
working alongside and struggling
alongside with remember line 24a of
plato's apology
socrates says parisia was the cause of
my unpopularity parisia is plain speech
unintimidated
speech frank
speech speech that is unafraid it's the
language of the great victoria garvin of
malcolm x it's the language of dorothy
day of rabbi abraham joshua heschel it
cuts through the jargon it cuts to
specialized language it gets at the pain
but doesn't remain there because it
articulates the vision so that there's
an alternative to that pain that is also
was lacking
yes and that's what thomas paine had
and part of the problem is when we when
we do have persons with those voices
what happens well thomas paine went to
jail in london he's pushed out he's 11
months in prison in paris luckily makes
it out when he comes back here he has a
critique of george washington he has a
critique of evangelical religion in the
midst of the first awakening and he is
completely pushed aside so oftentimes
poor persons who have these voices are
either in prison incarcerated lied on
character assassinated literally
assassinated or just pushed to the
margins and viewed as some isolated icon
that one worships rather than views them
as part of a movement
you see
movie abu jamal
oscar lopez rivera we go on and on and
on in this regard you see so the
challenge is how do we build on payne's
example but we're living in a much more
crypto-fascist state than he was
that's the lesson
of brother mummy and others those who
raise their voices the national
surveillance state the national security
state is on you the spies are operating
folk on the inside your friends who used
to you thought you could rely on no not
at all they're cowardly they're too
conformist they're too complacent who do
you rely on then that's what thomas
paine was wrestling with most of his
life he dedicates one of the texts to
george washington right next thing you
know george won't get him out of the
clinker
in paris
he's living with james madison in paris
then the critique of george washington
is so devastating george washington is
the icon when he comes to the state they
won't touch thomas payne with a 10 vote
for 10-foot poll because his critique of
george washington is so unrelenting he
has pulled the cover on the demagogue
nobody talks about george
he chopped down the cherry tree
nobody talks about george he sacrificed
wait a minute let's tell a story
that's honest and candid about george
washington especially for someone like
thomas paine who whose view is not just
black people but thomas payne in the
eastern plan in pennsylvania when he met
with indigenous brothers and sisters and
went on to write what they were wiser
than the white folk they were talking to
these were my brothers and sisters these
indigenous peoples that's a vanilla
brother named thomas payne talking that
way
we don't even have white activists these
days enough talking that way with
indigenous peoples and brown peoples and
black peoples and asian people yeah we
got some in this room i'm talking about
as a movement
as a movement why because you grew up in
such compartmentalized deodorized spaces
where you had very little assets to
black folk and red folk and yellow folk
and others those vanilla suburbs and
went to these nice little elite schools
and got sophisticated and and so forth
and not any way connected to what these
struggles have been thomas paine refused
that and he dropped he left school when
he was 12 and a half now i'm not
recommending that
but that's also a way in which he was
not incorporated so easily
by the gentleman of his day who never
accepted thomas paine
never except john adams jefferson even
when he said good things about him he
was still a commoner
he was still so unsophisticated and raw
and coarse you know the vicious lies
told about his personal hygiene and so
it may not been alive maybe he smelled a
little bit but
but i mean all the lies that were
unimportant relative to the issues that
he was talking about
that's how rare he was that's why it's
perfect to start with thomas paine
i think also
not to be the the good news bearer but
let's be clear
let's be clear
all the people who turned against him
along the way
the vast majority of them we don't even
know who they are what survived was what
this man wrote
and it didn't just survive because he
was a great writer he was and it didn't
just survive because he found ways of
changing the meaning of words that
brought people alive incredible skills
chris is right one of the great writers
particularly the great writers of
revolutionary literature
the reason though he survives is that
it's the same question
and when you begin to look
as christian and then we did for what we
could build a lasting conversation
around we found him because he addresses
the same issue
what is to be done if i could borrow the
way another important leader posed the
question
uh what is to be done
this this
is his recognition and i think we ought
to be
for a moment proud that the united
states produced such a person proud that
we generated someone who could pose the
reform and revolution question so
dramatically that even though his coming
down on the side of revolution
which frightens so many people
returns now
to something we want to talk about and
that we want you to
return to read and learn from as we have
because there's lots of very powerful
insight in there
about what it is we face now
and we do in this country face now
an extraordinary structure
that has done the things that were so
upsetting to to pain one example
referred to by both of us all of us
democracy in those days was a word that
can akin to
chaotic
disorganized
messy
ineffective negative negative negative
right we live in a sense in a bizarre
reversal
now it's the holy of holies
but it's all a fake
we celebrated democracy
the way we celebrate cowboys
in the old days
a complete fantasy a makeup
so that we can indulge this desire
as an economist i keep saying this and i
know some of you heard it from me before
we go to work we spend five out of seven
days a week
at our jobs and when we go to work which
is where we spend most of our adult life
we enter a place in a capitalist society
that is the absolute opposite of
democracy a tiny group of people
major shareholders and boards of
directors 25 30 people make all the
decisions that thousands of employees
not to speak of the communities where
these employees work have to live with
their participation in those decisions
is completely excluded
in principle in law and in fact
so we spend most of our adult lives in
an institution that is fundamentally
undemocratic and pretend we live in a
society with a fundamental commitment to
democracy
this is crazy
but it's a craziness that has to be
opened up
by the genius kind of vision that a pain
brings to it so that you kind of shock
a population into recognizing that all
along that's what's been bothering me it
isn't just that i'm poor it isn't just
that i'm living in a polluted
environment in an overcrowded city it
said i'm not treated like a human being
and this is
this is revolutionary stuff
that moment of recognition if you can
help it along with the kind of writing
he had
that lights the fire it's very very
powerful
i want to talk about the two weapons
that were used against pain most
effectively the first was vilification
and when you stand up and speak a truth
as powerfully and eloquently as pain
does
the state uh and this was true both in
colonial america and especially true
in uh
the england of william pitt
and even finally in
the jacobin
revolutionary france where they were
terrified of payne's writing which is
why he ends up in the luxembourg and he
doesn't just end up in the luxembourg
he's slated for execution
and the only reason he's not executed is
because they would mark the doors of the
people to be guillotined the next
morning and his door the door to his
cell was open
and they marked the inside of the door
and at night the guard closed it and he
sat in the room
holding his breath
waiting as the guards passed to pull
those people out of the luxembourg who
would be guillotined and they passed him
by that's the only reason payne is alive
and there's actually an amazing scene
where danton who had
been an ally of pain is brought to the
luxembourg and they embrace
uh before danton is
executed
um
so
vilification uh
there
he was followed uh the government of as
they do here funded all sorts of front
organizations letter writing campaigns
uh and they destroyed him
uh that the power of vilification should
not be
uh
diminished it works
and pain was being burned in effigy
uh by the very people that he was
writing
for
uh in france of course he almost dies
because he opposes the reign of terror
he was a quaker in that sense he wasn't
a good quaker they wouldn't let him be
buried finally in a quaker burial but he
opposed the death penalty
including the regicide of the king and
he stood up in the national convention
and gave a quite an eloquent and moving
speech as to why even your enemy you
must even protect your enemies because
once you begin this kind of reign of
terror against those you oppose it comes
back to haunt you i mean very prescient
as to the direction of the french
revolution that's the first thing and i
know uh that uh cornell west for
speaking the truth
about the administration of barack obama
has suffered from this kind of
vilification
but it's a perfect example of what a
truth teller has to undergo the second
is historical amnesia
[Applause]
and
let's think about it
thomas paine was one of the most
important founders
of our country
where are the monuments to thomas paine
where
he he's been erased
as as a kind of visible figure
and and this gets into the in
frightening kind of erasure of the
entire radical tradition which has been
extremely effective in the united states
and in a sense uh it's a way of in a
kind of stalinist way of rewriting our
own history i mean the communist party
in this country and if you were a a
black person in the 1920s were you where
were you going to it's why robeson
joined the party because it was
integrated or ruskin and all the tactics
that king used came out of communist
tactics that were being used in the 20s
and the 30s
um the wobblies i mean i have to tell
this room you're aware of it but pain
represents that radical tradition that
the establishment has worked from the
beginning of the public to
erase
so that
pain even in his own lifetime as cornell
correctly pointed out becomes a pariah i
mean even jefferson who had been a
friend of pain
uh pushes him
away
and
i thought maybe we could talk a little
bit about the mechanism the state uses
vilification and historical amnesia in
order to blunt and destroy the radical
prophetic voice yeah and that's so very
important to philadelphia 100 years
100 year anniversary of pain they took a
vote they refused to have a statue
anywhere in the city in tribute to him
that's philadelphia that's where he
struggled he walked on foot from trenton
to philadelphia in support of the us
military working with the military under
nathanael greene and george washington
american revolutionary war and that's
the kind of gratitude why because
why because he was so genuinely
revolutionary that once the revolution
was over in the united states we got to
move toward the counter-revolutionary
status quo
as the federalists set in
as their fear of the french revolution
set in the john adams and others but i
do want to add this
probably the greatest black
revolutionary socialist in the early
part of the 20th century was a brother
named herbert harrison
he was the founder of local five
socialist party
he was the most popular lecturer in this
in the city of new york and was very
close to ingersoll as well as clarence
darrow
and it was reading thomas paine that
turned him into not simply a
revolutionary but also an agnostic now
payne was not an agnostic he was a diaz
but when hubert harrison
he was a genius he's a caribbean genius
he came off the boat came straight to
harlem lived on 134th street
and when he died
there was just seven folk there and it's
an unmarked grave to this day read
jeffrey perry's magnificent magisterial
biography and that's just volume one
you see
hubert harrison historical amnesia
everybody knows about booker t
washington
god bless the negro
he founded the black institution unfor
founding black institution own white
money on white elite money against the
unions against our precious immigrants
coming in deeply pro-capitalist
everybody knows booker t washington what
about hubert harrison in the legacy of
tom payne a cross-race we could go on
that's why victoria garvin another
powerful magnificent voice who knows
about the great victoria garvin we need
to know more historical amnesia again
but when
times reach a point where the truth has
to emerge
we're going to be so hungry for these
voices
because we want to be needful
of their insight but most importantly of
their courageous example
of their courageous example because at
that point you either courageous or you
go under we're not at that point now
that's why i think one of the reasons
why the folk were a little reluctant
when she said revolutionary times
you see i i don't think we live in
revolutionary times i wish it were
revolutionary times pain arrived at a
moment where the revolution's already in
place
he just drops in
i wish we could just drop in
and have black folk
and white and red and yellow already
organized already anti-imperialist
already anti-homophobic already
anti-capitalist already anti
against jewish hatred and arab hatred a
hatred of muslims and so forth we can
just drop in on that and then write a
pamphlet
hey
[Music]
we're gonna get together tonight and
write that pamphlet
we work all night right that pamphlet no
no these are counter-revolutionary times
where there's revolutionary awareness
escalating given the defeat the relative
defeat of the left in the last 35 or 40
years with the counter-revolution
triumphing in the name of capital
in white supremacist garb even when you
have black figures who are the public
faces of it you see that's
what our moment it seems to me and i
think that's one of the reasons why folk
were a little bit
leery about that and i've resonated with
that lyricist because we do want to be
honest what we're up against
he said none of us gonna live through
the revolution we talking about
at all
and some of us get crushed like
cockroaches
because the powers that be are powerful
they mighty but not they're not almighty
pain believed that the people organized
or always mightier than the gangsters
who run things
but the gangsters are powerful
very powerful indeed there's no doubt
about that and vilification
well yeah but i mean i wouldn't compare
my case to thomas paine yeah good god
almighty yeah low low no but i mean i i
just think that the
uh
it's it's impossible to tell the truth
especially about the vicious legacy of
white supremacy and his connection to
capitalist exploitation without knowing
you're a candidate for character and
literal assassination that's just a fact
over 400 years there has never been
a person from john brown on the vanilla
side to nat turner to ella baker
who was told the truth about white
supremacy in his connection to
capitalism who was not targeted
chronically systematically across the
board
and that's why you have to have your
spirit intact you can you can get it
intact in a secular way i get it intact
with loving jesus people say whatever
they want that's you i got my mother
hugging life to live
i got my integrity to preserve
and how do you bear witness in the face
of those kinds of lives and those kinds
of crimes and that's what they are
they're crimes against humanity the new
jim crow is a crime against humanity
the educational systems in our cities
those are crimes against humanity the
way those precious children are treated
you see
a working class abused in this well
that's a crime against humanity
and the drones dropping bombs on
innocent children vicious crimes against
humanity in the name of the u.s people
you have to just call it for what it is
but using that kind of language doesn't
just get you in trouble
but it can get you killed yes
one last thought about this
and maybe there's a productive tension
between brother
cornell and
myself we don't know where we are in the
revolutionary process
you only know that afterwards
was it the right time
was it possible
were the conditions in place
you never know
and part of what it means to be
a critic
in the spirit of tom paine
is that you always got to push
you've got to push to see
where
and how far it can go
we are here
and you are here
[Applause]
and this is probably the
biggest attendance that the
that is the whole three days here that
the left forum has ever enjoyed
these are very interesting
bits of information
i think we have to always be willing
both to be cautious and honest about
what we're up against absolutely right
but always with a little space left
for that unknowable
reality
when the things begin to happen really
quickly
that author i referred to earlier from
another place in time
who made famous that question
what is to be done
was famous for another remark he made
about this question
he said sometimes
for decades
nothing happens
and then in a few weeks
decades happen
we have to be open
thomas payne was open
because if you're not open you can't
write that way
part of the it's not just the effect his
writing has on the revolutionary
situation it's also the fact that a
revolutionary situation even when not
grasped consciously
plays its role
in shaping what it was possible for
thomas payne to write and we have to be
in
in sync with that unknowable
extra that's there
partly to live in a time like this and
partly to be able to be progressive in a
time like this
alexander berkman in an essay
writes about uh called the essays called
the invisible revolution precisely that
point where he talks about a life
in a revolutionary society as being like
a kettle that is boiling
and that you don't actually see anything
that all of the
uh traditional edifices of power and
structures not only remain in place but
appear monolithic
and that when they collapse when they go
down it's
it appears to be absolutely sudden
and unpredictable and like as a foreign
correspondent that was something that i
experienced covering the revolutions in
eastern europe uh including the east
german stasi state
uh
where uh until our security and
surveillance state was the most
pervasive
uh
uh
uh security apparatus in human history
we've of course done things the stasi
didn't even dream of
and
and what happened was
you had
uh
in leipzig
mostly lutherans
holding candlelight vigils and they
weren't even very clear about uh they if
their first demand was that they'd be
legally recognized as a group they
hardly appeared revolutionary and yet
they they captured that kind of
zeitgeist
which i think is there within the
american society looking for a language
to express itself and and and and pain
gave revolutionary america that language
um but i think in that sense we we are
rapidly losing faith
in
the institutions the formal structures
of power uh which have been
become wholly owned subsidiaries of the
corporate state
um but language is key and burkman makes
that point that as long as you can you
continue to speak in the false language
of american democracy liberty how can
you use the word liberty when
every single one of us in this room has
all of our electronic communications
downloaded and stored in perpetuity by
the nsa you cannot use the word liberty
uh for a population that has wholesale
surveillance
you have to use the word slavery
and
uh any government that has the capacity
to use that mechanism
will use it hannah aaron writes in the
origins of totalitarianism that the the
purpose of wholesale surveillance in a
totalitarian state is not to find crimes
but to gather evidence so at the moment
that you seek to criminalize an entire
group of people you have
the trivia it's not evidence because of
course at that point crimes and truth
and all of this is is is a fiction but
you have the material and that's
precisely what's happening to us
and so when that stasi state fell it
fell in a week and it fell when suddenly
this handful of
protesters in leipzig were joined by 70
000 people
and eric honaker who had been in power
for 19 years sent down an elite
paratroop division to fire on the crowd
and the paratroopers wouldn't do it just
in the same way the cossacks would not
fire during the bread riots and
petrograd which forced the czar to get
into a railway carriage and and abdicate
even before he got back to petrograd
okay um and so and the same thing
happened in
uh in east germany hanukkah was gone was
gone within a week because those
paratroopers would not shoot on the
crowd so i have a question that's
completely related to what you just said
um because i think in so far as we're
talking about the anatomy of revolution
we also need to talk about the anatomy
of the counter revolution and how if
we are talking about a man who was an
abolitionist and who was the great
rhetorician of the revolution we end up
with a slave-holding republic
how it was that u.s
not colonial but u.s
forces did fire
on rebels
in the shae's rebellion and the
uprisings against debt
uh in that period between
the declaration of independence and the
writing of the constitution
thomas paine
supported the banks getting paid
he was against the mob
he said you get changed by rule of law
or by the military or by the mob and he
was on the side of the law
our laws come out of that period
um i'd love you to address the anatomy
of the counter revolution well the thing
to remember about pain was that in
pennsylvania
uh there was no divide between wig and
torrey uh the pennsylvania elite which
was quaker and anglican were wholly on
the side of the british monarchy
the pennsylvania assembly backed the
property class
and so unlike in the other colonies the
opposition
to the king and the independence
movement was expressed through pain
and radical constitutionalists
who
had no connection with pre-revolutionary
power
and so that in pennsylvania after the
revolution those who take power
unlike every other colony
uh had not been in power before now this
alliance was extremely uneasy
because as you correctly point out with
a slave holding class and let's forget
not forget that we had at the beginning
of the revolution
african-american soldiers
until george washington a slaveholder
banned the conscription of blacks into
the continental army
the only reason that the southern
slave holding class supported the
republic and they had remembered they
had had a rebellion of landless whites
the bacon rebellion in the 17th century
the only reason they supported it was
because the laboring class
was
who were black and enslaved were pushed
out of the political system so you have
this kind of false
narrative or false language that's used
by figures like jefferson while ignoring
huge percentages so
once the revolution is over and they
knew this even before the revolution
they had to push pain out as fast as
they could because that
abolitionist egalitarian
uh movement
was
uh even at the time of the revolution of
an alliance of convenience but made them
very uncomfortable and on the issue of
the banks and i'll let rick deal with
this more um i i and i would just say
that payne's conception of laissez-faire
capitalism came out of adam smith
not malphus and and adam smith had a
very benign view i'm now about to
probably embarrassing myself immensely
but
my very meager understanding a seminary
seminarian not an economist was anyway
that that that there was a kind of naive
view that laissez faire capitalism was
any you know created a kind of equality
and um i think pain was wrong on the
wrong on this justice i think pain was
very uh naive about human perfection and
um as cornell would say you know a
misunder an inability to understand sin
um and human corruption um so that when
pain is in support of the banks and
against the paper currency which did
cause hyperinflation um it comes out of
this naive belief that that that was a
democratizing force
well i mean one of pain has a developing
views about the economy it's very
different what it says in common sense
and what he says
in the rights of man and the last major
piece to agrarian justice agreeing
justice and that second volume of rights
which is basically social democratic he
called for the first person to call for
guaranteed minimum income right
guaranteed minimum income and the very
front page of his agrarian justice is
every citizen ought to receive a
lump of money when they're 15 and i'll
receive another major lump of money when
they're 45. from inherited no matter
what inheritance you break down the
inheritance transmittance of wealth at
the top and people get a chance to start
their teenage years are new and then
right before the worms get you i'm 45
start that anew again with another
injection but so at least
so he's he's very fragmented he's not
systematic and he's certainly not marx
at all but
in regard to the banks too i think
thomas paine
thomas paine did not receive one penny
from the money he got from common sense
or from the rights of man these are the
two
best-selling texts in the history of the
english language didn't give receive a
penny every penny just like martin king
nobel prize every penny went to the
movement every penny went to the cause
when he called for the banks early on
that was a way of supporting providing
financial support for the war
and so we had to have a national entity
that would provide some resources to
keep the war going in an anti-imperial
way but he supported him after shays as
well pardon me but he supported them
after shays as well what but he did have
a suspicion of the mob the mob ought to
deserve suspicion the mob can be run by
gangsters too you had to be very
critical in this regard when he talked
about the people he wasn't viewing it as
an abstraction
he had a critical view toward whether
there was democratic sensibility and
vision when people talked about the
people now when shae's rebellion i would
argue he was still he was still wrong
i'm not defending him in terms of a
particular judgment but his larger
vision and sensibility something i
wanted i guess i raised the question
because of its relevance today as we try
to decide where our allies are and
define the the basic composition of the
community of the population that we're
in
um
because my other question to you has to
do with
this question of
the intellectual revolutionary today
because i think i disagree with you
cornell
um
somebody's right but that's good
i mean on grit tv every week
we're interviewing grassroots
intellectual revolutionaries
i'm thinking of people like max ramo
from the right to the city i'm thinking
like people of people like kalia kuno
who worked with chokwe lumumba in
jackson to take power and to call for a
total transformation of the economic
priorities of that city in a place where
that was viable i'm thinking of the
dreamers with no access to power with no
access to the system changing our entire
um
the comfort of the congress around their
immigration policy even occupy
they got a lot of help from the media
but then they got a lot of hurt from the
media
um but they raised the question of
capitalism in a way that we could talk
about it in a way that we hadn't been
able to for years so
i'm yes my suspicion
of the mob
makes me uncomfortable because some of
my favorite people are in the mob
um and sometimes it's hard who's to tell
who's the mob
and who's the mob capital m and the mob
capital m are in government
brother rick you want to drop your nose
because we don't want dominic but i'll
say something immediately after but you
go right ahead though all right um
let's be
generous to tom paine he thought
that many of the problems he saw
accumulating in this society
at the time of our colonial
link to britain
could be overcome by a cataclysmic act a
revolution
cutting us off
from this society of which we had been a
colony
rejecting the monarchy rejecting the
support unbelievable
he then
had to face as many revolutionaries have
that what it was
he thought was the problem
turned out to be only part of the
problem
it was a necessary but not a sufficient
step to take to achieve the goals he so
brilliantly put forward for us
that he's so brilliantly expressed
so we learn in the aftermath of thomas
paine either with him or after he dies
after him
that there's more to be done
that being an independent country cut
off from your colonial master is
necessary
but it's not sufficient
how many nations have been discovering
that in the last 200 years
particularly in the so-called third
world
it's necessary
but it's not sufficient what else has to
be done well what law referred to
we have to understand that if we
actually want to realize the goals of a
thomas paine
whether they're articulated in the
american idiom or in the liberty
equality fraternity idiom of the french
revolution
more has to be done
that's what inspired
if i may be so bold
karl marx that's who he is he's born in
the euphoria of the american and french
revolutions
he's caught up in all of that he
believed in it he loved it it's just
when he looked around germany in his
time
it wasn't happening the way it was
supposed to
the end of the feudal regime hadn't
brought liberty and equality and
fraternity
it had brought capitalism which they
early thought might be
the road to liberty equality and
fraternity and then they made this
crucial discovery that capitalism isn't
the bearer of liberty equality and
fraternity
it's the biggest obstacle imaginable
and then begins the learning that we're
part of
that the next revolution inspired and
even made possible by the likes of tom
paine
now have to be informed by what's our
problem and that isn't
a king
that's a piece of theatrics in a few
leftover countries who have to have
kings and queens and we feel empathy for
the money they piss away on that
our problem is an economic system
but it's not that pain was wrong he
needed to open the space so we could get
to what's on the agenda
for the human race now and that's an
enormous debt we have to him all right
so some other questions coming from the
uh uh from the audience london famously
remarked in his article backward europe
advanced asia that the center of
anti-capitalist revolutionary had
revolution had switched to the third
world in the era of monopoly capital do
you agree
i don't think you can talk about the
third world as monolithic it depends on
which corner of the world we're talking
about
i don't think it can be broadly
characterized in in that way
in the same way that i i agree with you
and the examples that you gave you see
folks who are
telling the truth exposing lives bearing
witness in the name of the struggles of
porn working people are not a mob
that's not the mob
see it only becomes a mob when the
gangsters take over just like the reign
of terror the french revolution that's
when the mob spilled over into gangster
activity in the name of the people
just like they were gangsters in the
name of the king there's gangsters in
the name of the church gangster the name
of the synagogue drinks the name of
judaism against the name of christianity
gang's in the name of
buddhism or whatever
for thomas paine and this is where for
take for him actually this was what he
called a religious duty he thought as a
deist he's following the will of god by
doing justly loving mercy
loving mercy and endeavoring to make his
fellow creatures happy that's the
language from
the rights of man but in the absence of
the question is has the center of
revolution shifted away from here to
someplace
else it was never in american empire
says when is american empire been the
center of revolution other than 1776 and
possibilities in 1960.
america has been the bastion
of white supremacy and the rule of
capital ever since 1776 is that right
brother
people we've had we've had resistance in
protest
but we haven't had a south africa we
haven't had a venezuela we haven't had a
cuba we haven't had a china we haven't
had i mean in india in 1948 america has
been the bastion of capital of of of of
what would lennon call the dictatorship
of the bourgeoisie and and that's why
violence
in america is vigilante violence
uh we are the you know what is it 80
80 out of every 100 americans owns a
weapon
and the government has nothing to fear
because trade and this is the problem
that that the the one sort of figure in
our revolutionary intellectual tradition
pain which has been who's been
marginalized in silence
uh
has not had any heirs
and and so and hofstetter writes about
this in that book on violence quite
presciently
that uh you know you go back and look at
american history whether it's the slave
patrols or the pinkertons or baldwin
felts or you know the the coal mining
gun thugs or uh you know the vigilantes
who shot down the miners at blair
mountain that or you know right up to
the tea party the militias that violence
in american society
uh
doesn't revolve around in a way that it
did in europe
around
a transformative ideology
uh but around these kind of
proto-fascist
hatreds
and that that is something that as we
move forward as a nation
and and and we endure the effects of
climate change and economic
disintegration we are going to have to
confront
you know look at nevada suppose those
people had been from earth first
or suppose they'd been black what do you
think would have happened
and and in a way
those vigilantes become important to the
system tolerated occasionally
reprimanded but tolerated because in a
moment of crisis
they become used by the capitalist state
so you have the klu klux klan in the
1920s
three to five million members
reign of terror in the south taking over
whole states including
indiana and and that is something we are
going to have to confront these uh you
know these armed militia figures these
survivalist cults and adam lanza's
mother was a member these which have
terrorized african americans throughout
their history uh and and and been used
to kill radicals in ludlow those people
were killed by vigilantes um that i
think is an example of how
uh
the the rage a legitimate rage and anger
has been very skillfully manipulated
to turn on the vulnerable on the
scapegoats on the weak and let me just
in terms of revolutionary tradition we
should not forget that we are
the british monarchy right we are the
empire and we have the disease of empire
so that even i don't talk to very many
people in princeton except for cornell
because even at princeton university you
will get these absurd discussions about
sending 101st airborne to afghanistan to
liberate women
as if you can talk about and i've been
to war and they haven't as if you can
talk about human rights once you start
using cruz and hellfire missiles so i
think the answer to the question was
don't worry about the center of
revolution shifting someplace else
because it was never here
um
it doesn't mean you don't struggle here
one more question
because this topic has come up a lot in
your questions um and this is can you
connect payne's radicalism to the
immediate crises associated with climate
change
there's a couple of questions related to
climate change
does climate change give us an
opportunity galvanize a revolutionary
segment of society or will business
continue as usual until it's too late
and if we had a source of abundant
energy would we have a revolution well
here
i'll let rick and cornell address this
as well but here i would break with pain
paine not only believed in like the
enlightenment human perfectibility
but he also believed in
wholeheartedly in
material advancement and material
progress and he said the earth that's
given to us is our inheritance to me
yeah and he broke with jefferson on this
i mean jefferson was terrified of the
industrial revolution and wanted to sort
of slow its effect payne saw it as a
benefit and and you know payne often
talked about uh
giving up political activity and he
designed an iron bridge and he had like
many of the artisan class of the day a
deep interest in science so uh i think
you know if we talk about blind spots in
pain that would probably be
a one yeah
well i i think the the way i would
connect pain to the the whole climate
thing is it's sort of
we're now forced to see
yet another
consequence of capitalism and the way
its intrinsic logic
endangers us that is it's not just as
piketty shows us that it produces absurd
social inequalities that are
self-destructive but it also
distorts our relationship to the to the
uh ecosphere and that it's another
argument but it doesn't then just takes
us back to having to confront we have an
economic system
that is fundamentally dysfunctional for
the vast majority of us
what are we going to do about this
situation
and no matter how alarmist your reaction
to the environmental it really is
another kind of alarmism that you can
likewise generate for social inequality
and for many of the other consequences
of capitalism that always bring you back
to
are we able now to think through a
relationship to capitalism that's
parallel or comparable to what pain took
us through in thinking our relationship
to a colonial master
and that means the oligarchs and the
plutocrats of our day wall street big
banks and big corporations
are the equivalent of the monarchs in
history that's right
it means that poverty is a new slavery
it means that the new jim crow is an
intense form
of slavery it means that working people
locked into
a declining
economy in which wages stagnate
prices escalate and profits go hit the
top is also a form of slavery
metaphorically and literally speaking
and we need language like that to
somehow seize the imagination of people
to begin to see lo and behold there's
either a way out or there's not now
climate change for me is a very serious
issue i don't think is going to be the
catalytic issue
i think it's either going to be
revolutionary transformation that allows
us to get some control over banks and
corporations so we can treat nature as a
thou rather than in it but when i hear a
lot of the discourse of climate change i
hear people thinking oh my god my life
is going to be like a wasteland well you
know for poor people it's a wasteland
every day
every day
every year
year after year
year after year so how do we make the
connection between the climate change
agents on the one hand but also those
who are wrestling with these new forms
of slavery in the neo-liberal capitalist
regimes around the world and to recoup
one little piece of credit for the
united states
thomas paine
teaches us to think about revolution as
a matter of changing a system
that's a very powerful contribution it
made him stand out from others at his
time and it's urgently necessary for
more of us nowadays to be willing and
able to confront not this or that
outrage not this or that intrusion on
our lives but a system
that supports and reinforces all of that
and will outwit us as long as we don't
confront it as a system and that we need
thomas payne's help to do
well on the system's point
it's worth remembering that the tea
party after all was not against the king
so much as against the company the east
india company and the mur the
relationship between the royal power the
monarchy and the corporation something
very familiar today
looking at all of this a couple of
people wanted to ask your exact
suggestions we have your suggestions for
how to keep hope your suggestions for
how to start a organized movement
and your suggestion
for things people can mobilize around
today and i'm
condensing a few different questions but
insofar as pain put forward concrete
suggestions whether it was around the
con the continental congress or around
the um inheritance tax and the
guaranteed minimum income what would
yours be today are there things like
that that one could organize or you
would like to see us organizing around
and we've got about four minutes
i'll give you five
well let me start
while my colleagues figure out what
they're going to say
i have one thing that i get out of
thomas paine although i get it from
other places too that i think
begins to confront the systemic issue
we depend as human beings on the
enterprises in our society that produce
the goods and services without which
life cannot continue our food our
clothing our shelter our transportation
and everything else
we permit the institutions that we
depend on the productive institutions to
be organized in a fundamentally
undemocratic way that leave all the
decisions those that affect the
environment those that affect the
distribution of wealth those that affect
everyday life in the hands of a tiny
number of people that sit atop the
pyramid of these institutions what we
call corporations
if we don't want this set of outcomes we
call the consequences of capitalism then
we have to fundamentally alter the
organization of production if we want
the production of goods and services the
core economic base of our lives to serve
all of us then we have to be in charge
of them and it can't be a subset of us
that arrogates that position to itself
the radical transformation what chakwe
lubumba was beginning to do and talk
about in jackson mississippi is part of
a
broadening recognition that that
fundamental revolution that reorganizes
production
is where we have to go to
achieve to concretize where payne's work
pushes us
anyone else yeah just very belief i'm
thoroughly convinced that if 40 of
america's children lived in poverty and
one out of three of america's children
of young people were on parole in prison
or probation it'd be a very different
historical moment if 40 of white
children lived in poverty and one out of
three of white young brothers between 18
and 26 were on parole probation or in
prison we'd have a different moment it'd
be maybe a revolutionary moment which
means and we're going to say do
something about the vicious legacy of
white supremacy and it's relation to
the neo-liberal capitalist regime that
is so tied to lies and crimes so the
issue of black and brown and folk is not
just a moral issue of being morally
sensitive
it is an anti-systemic issue that goes
right back to what brother wolf is
talking about and that's precisely the
reason why
black
young people are disproportionately
targeted because the only time we've had
the possibility of that was in the 1960s
and they came at it so viciously
that's why we still got the political
prisoners and the warriors that are
there they came at us viciously and
they're ready to come back viciously
again the difference will be this time
it will be blackface
that will also lead the vicious attack
the call rowans and the others who lied
on malcolm lied on martin they they were
not in positions of power now you've got
black elites at the very top of the
empire who can facilitate the vicious
attacks that's why sante shakur is on
the top 10 list being a terrorist with a
black president in the white house and
she's a black freedom fighter
and we don't want to say a word about it
shame on us
in terms of the legacy of what folk went
through just 30 or 40 years ago in these
kind of settings where they told the
truth and look what they had to go
through and we so easily turn our backs
and say lo and behold their service
their sacrifice can be marginalized in
the same way that our dear brother
thomas paine one last point footnote
there's only one figure that's
comparable to thomas paine david walker
appeal to colored citizens of the world
and david walker did what wrote his text
and died in that hotel room 11 months
after after the spies got to him but he
went with a smile the way thomas paine
went with a smile because he told the
truth and he exposed lies and he bore
witness chris you got a minute uh i
would say that the reason we are in such
an incendiary moment as that the
political and economic
uh cultural oppression of poor people of
color is now being visited on the sons
and daughters of the white middle class
and that is basically the engine of the
occupy movement these are de class say
intellectuals bakunin always cited these
day class a intellectuals as vital for
revolution arguing with marx on this but
bakunin was right
so suddenly you have the sons and
daughters
white
who endure police oppression who can't
get a job or at least a job where they
can sustain themselves who are enduring
what poor people marginalized people of
color have been endured for decades and
at that moment the state is in serious
serious trouble because an alliance
between an alienated
white
essentially middle class or formerly
middle class our middle class is
disappearing of course
those people of color especially
low-wage working poor uh is one that i
think once is galvanized can begin to
create and that's why the fight for the
minimum wage is absolutely crucial debt
peonage is a form of political control
it's put on there on purpose ask any
african-american it's how sharecroppers
were kept in slavery long after slavery
was officially abolished
and what we have done to college
students in this country is absolutely
criminal i mean my son is in france i
said if you told french college students
that they'd have to pay 50 000
a year to go to college they'd shut the
damn country down which is precisely
what you should be doing here all right
um
[Applause]
hello everybody
so i will just close by say
something's coming it's always it's
always the ruling elites that determine
the configurations of rebellion they are
unable to respond rationally to the
mortgage foreclosure crisis to the job
crisis to climate change they know
they have no internal limits they will
exploit until exhaustion or collapse and
there will be blowback
[Applause]
i want to just thank our participants
cornell west chris hedges rick wolf talk
to your neighbors before they join the
vigilantes and make revolution everybody
thank you
[Applause]
i just want to thank our friend here
victor madison from the thomas payne
friends who's been
brought these in beautiful
posters to give to each of us
book tv is on facebook like us stewart's
as a congressman from ohio and was
assassinated 200 days into his term as
president get our complete schedule at
cspan.org
pulitzer prize-winning journalist chris
hedges talks about his book wages of
rebellion next on book tv he discusses
the causes of revolution and resistances
by looking at stories of rebels
throughout history and examines what it
takes to be a rebel in modern times
he'll be joining us on book tv for a
live call in today around 12 45 pm
eastern
hi there
hi
there can you guys hear me
can you hear me in the back
yeah great
i'm dora tea i'm one of the owners here
uh it's great to see all of you
at labyrinth tonight welcome
uh just a few practical things and then
we'll get going
first please turn off your cell phones
if you haven't done that already
also um our event season is sort of
winding down
but we're of course planning great
events for the fall so if you um don't
already get our email invites and would
like to just leave us your email address
on the back counter there's a sign up
sheet for that
um in terms of the
the uh the event tonight the logistics
are that i will just do a very brief
introduction chris will speak and then
there will be time for q a
um i would just like to ask you we have
uh c-span book tv here tonight um and
i'd like to ask you to give me a moment
to come to you with a mic so that you
the
the whole event can be heard as well as
seen
and i also want to ask you to try to
formulate really a question rather than
a statement in fairness to everyone else
okay
so
it is my great pleasure to introduce to
you and to welcome back to labyrinth
our friend and neighbor chris hedges
whose new book wages of rebellion the
moral imperative of revolt we're
honoring and discussing tonight
chris spent nearly two decades as a
foreign correspondent in central america
the middle east africa and the balkans
he has reported from more than 50
countries
working for many major news outlets
for 15 years he was former foreign
correspondent for the new york times
where he was part of the team of
reporters that was awarded the pulitzer
prize in 2002
for the paper's coverage of global
terrorism
he is the author of more than a dozen
critically acclaimed books
which continue to influence and inspire
those looking for ways to understand and
resist structural inequality and
injustice
chris is a senior fellow at the nation
institute he has taught at columbia
university nyu princeton
and in addition to publishing what seems
to be about a book a year
chris writes a weekly column for
truthdig and teaches inmates in new
jersey prisons
with wages of rebellion chris continues
his work as chronicler of globalized
corporate power
of the suffering and harm it inflicts on
humans and on the environment
but while reminding the reader always of
how high the stakes of inaction are
this book is dedicated mostly to
understanding what it means and what it
takes to take action in particular to
take non-violent action
while is never in doubt that the rebels
we meet in wages of rebellion are men
and women of great
moral and physical courage that courage
is in this telling
almost a secondary effect
primary is the theologian reinhold
niebuhr's notion of sublime madness
this curious mixture chris explains
of gloom and hope defiance and
resignation of absurdity and meaning is
born of the rebels awareness of the
enormity of the forces that must be
defeated
and the remote chances for success
in every chapter he draws not only on
the history of political thought and the
biography biographies of rebels through
the centuries and the world over
but crucially also on a large canon of
literary texts
our cultural patrimony is offered as a
source from which to draw strength for a
struggle that is necessarily a struggle
against all odds
a reminder of the experience of the
natural world as sacred is offered as
another such source of strength
while chris's new book is a book of
history reporting and analysis
and therefore for the most part is
written in the third and in the third
not the first person given the fact that
social justice is the cause to which
chris has dedicated his own life
wages of rebellion is also an intensely
personal book
its last sentence coming at the end of a
tribute to his wife eunice who is here
and their children is
i fear i have never done enough
the work of those who resist injustice
it would seem requires not only
some form of sublime madness
but also a forever restless conscience
please join me in giving chris a warm
welcome
[Applause]
thank you
and uh thank you dortea
uh
one of the great joys of being in
princeton is having labyrinth
uh one of the great bookstores
in the united states
uh and
it would be hard to imagine living here
without
labyrinth and firestone library
across the street
the three books that i wrote before
wages of rebellion
death of liberal class
empire of illusion the end of literacy
and the triumph of spectacle
and days of destruction days of revolt
which i wrote with the great cartoonist
joe sacco
out of the poorest pockets of the
country including camden new jersey
which per capita is the poorest city in
the united states
and at the time we were working there
the most dangerous
attempted
to portray
a political and economic system
that
no longer served the interests
of the citizen
but the exclusive
demands of corporate power
in all of those books i argued
that investing our hope
and our energy
in the formal mechanisms of power was a
waste of time
that we had undergone what john ralston
saw
calls a corporate coup d'etat in slow
motion
that it's over
they've won that we live rather
in what the political philosopher
sheldon wolin calls a system of inverted
totalitarianism
and that is not classical
totalitarianism it doesn't find its
expression through a demagogue or a
charismatic leader but through the
anonymity of the corporate state
making it different from communism and
different from fascism but no less
as effective a totalitarian force so
that we have the facade
of
electoral politics
of
constant constitution
of
the traditional branches of government
but internally corporations have now
seized all of the levers of power to
render the citizen impotent
those were all of those arguments death
of liberal class of course chronicled
the destruction of liberal institutions
which once made piecemeal and
incremental reform possible
labor
the academy
the arts largely commercialized
and of course as noam chomsky has
written
those liberal institutions acted as a
kind of safety valve to ameliorate
the grievances or injustices of the
citizenry
and right the kind of capitalist
democracy roosevelt indeed said that his
greatest achievement was that he saved
capitalism and that's correct but the
destruction of that
uh
mechanism by which you could
address
a crisis within capitalism and of course
the new deal addressing the breakdown of
capitalism itself is gone
uh we are barreling towards a
frightening global neo-feudalism
uh
we have empowered a rapacious
oligarchic elite
we indeed live in an oligarchy
we have destroyed the capacity of our
working class
to
make a sustainable income and the
assault on the middle class
is far underway
and at the same time the state the
corporate state is squeezing more and
more and more and rendering the
government less and less
effective
in terms of meeting the demands of
citizens and that is borne out now with
these secret trade agreements the tpp
and cafta and others where essentially
the power of the state to even intervene
in terms of corporate exploitation is
removed from them
now all of this creates a very
frightening kind of political paralysis
an inability of the state
to respond to the vast majority of the
citizens we see that in the name of
austerity
we see that in
the way that the state
in order to fund its activities exploits
in greater and greater measure the poor
and the most vulnerable
one of the engines to uh the revolts in
ferguson baltimore and other places is
the fact that poor what malcolm x called
our internal colonies uh derive up to 30
or 40 percent of their income from
fining uh
the poor
uh for absurdities not mowing their lawn
uh standing for five seconds or walking
they make the rules up as they go along
anybody who's worked in a marginal
community understands the nature of
omnipotent policing something hannah
aaron warned about in the origins of
totalitarianism and at the same time the
legal system has been utterly inverted
to strip the citizen of its most
of his or her most cherished
constitutional rights we can start with
a rise to privacy uh
the
section 1021 of the national national
defense authorization act and i sued
barack obama in federal court over this
one in the southern district court of
new york and then it was appealed and
overturned which permits the military to
carry out domestic policing in essence
forms of extraordinary rendition on
american city streets seize american
citizens who are deemed to be terrorists
and hold them
without due process indefinitely in
military facilities
the inability on the courts to deal with
wholesale surveillance all of us in this
room have all of our information we know
this because of the courage of edward
snowden all of our information is
captured downloaded and stored in
perpetuity in government computers
once you have a state and i covered the
collapse of the stasi state in east
germany once you have this state that
has the capacity
to monitor a citizen 24 hours a day you
can no longer use the word liberty
that is the relationship of a master and
a slave
uh the ability of the executive branch
to call for the assassination of
american citizens the misuse of
the espionage act
to shut down whistleblowers drake
kiriakou snowden and others chelsea
manning
all of this is combining
to create a very frightening dystopia
and
unfettered unregulated capitalism as
karl marx understood is a revolutionary
force it has no self-imposed limits
stripped of external limits it exploits
until exhaustion or collapse so that
even when you get a figure like bernie
sanders
on many of the issues i agree with
bernie although not on his position with
israel
as soon as he signs onto the project of
the democratic party and i think as
ralph nader has told us for some time
the democratic party is as captive to
corporate power as the republican party
um there is no way within the american
political system to vote against the
interests of exxon mobil or raytheon or
goldman sachs it's impossible
and
the
decision by sanders to work within that
party and not call it out for what it is
essentially allows him to act as a kind
of sheepdog
for hillary clinton uh who and we
clinton's assault against the working
class
was perhaps even more draconian than
that carried out by ronald reagan
nafta
the omnibus crime bill in 1994 which
exploded the prison population the
deregulation of the fcc uh the
destruction of welfare 70 of the
children on uh the assistance acts for
families uh were stripped of their
ability to receive government benefits
glass-steagall
all of this essentially has
propelled us forward to a situation
where as things unravel
we no longer have the legal mechanisms
or the protection by which
we can resist and this is by design um
the nsa has run numerous scenarios
of the effects of climate change and we
just saw march uh 400 and uh 400 parts
per million that's the first time uh the
the levels of uh carbon admissions has
been that high for an entire month in
recorded history these are the death
throes of the planet uh and corporate
forces uh
exploit uh until uh there's nothing left
uh and in theological terms in many ways
they are they are forces of death quite
literally when we talk about those
forces vis-a-vis climate change that's
the reality that we face uh that is the
political the economic the environmental
reality that we are up against
and the capacity of the state to control
uh the citizen to monitor the citizen uh
to use uh lethal force against unarmed
citizens uh and all of the marches by
black lives matter all of the coverage
all of the videos that show us the
murder
by militarized police forces of unarmed
citizens do nothing the numbers of
citizens keep being killed
uh
every 28 hours usually young
man or woman of color is murdered
unarmed uh in this country
and uh and so how do we
react how do we resist what does it take
um
and and what will the state do
that's what i tried to look at in the
book
wages of rebellion the moral imperative
of revolt
and i spend time in the book talking
with
those who have stood up
with magnificent courage to defy
the system
people like mumia abu jamal
julian assange in the ecuadorean embassy
the great
civil rights attorney lynn stewart
herself sent to prison
jeremy hammond the hacker
i attended with cornell west
the trials of chelsea manning
and
we'd leave princeton he lives in
princeton we'd leave at three in the
morning uh to drive down to be at fort
meade and uh each lesson was or each
car ride cornell would usually drive was
a lesson in classic soul so he knows
everything about everything including
classic soul so he go bootsy collins
wrote that song for james brown when he
was 19.
um
and i got a letter from uh chelsea
manning after
she was sentenced and imprisoned she was
not allowed to turn around and look
at who was seated in the courtroom to
support her and i got a letter saying
that she had looked out of the corner of
her eye and seen cornell myself and she
just wanted to send
a thank you
note
i think the greatest existential crisis
of our time is accepting
the reality that is before us with all
its bleakness
and yet finding the capacity to resist
and
liberalism itself in the face of a
crisis
of this magnitude as reinhold niebuhr
has written
is an ineffectual force
it's too intellectual
it's too
passionless
uh it's too lacking
in that quality that niebuhr calls
sublime madness
that capacity to rise up in the face of
overwhelming repression and respond as a
moral imperative
the ability
of rebels to react
to
massive systems of oppression
is driven and baldwin writes about this
by a vision
a vision that takes possession of them
hannah aaron writes about this
where
in the face of and she actually says
when she leaves the university of
heidelberg that
she had to unlearn everything that she
had been taught of course she had
studied with heidegger
in the university to become a moral
human being
and she said that the
those who are most effective in terms of
resisting are not those who who ask or
say this should not be done
or
uh we ought to do this but who say i
can't
that it is that
inability on the part of the rebel to
accept because of who they are
uh
complicity with systems of
injustice
and that is what niebuhr calls sublime
madness uh james cohen and his great
book the cross and the lynching tree
which i urge you all to read
uh also plays with this as a fundamental
quality in those who uh and he talks of
course about the african-american
experience who endure the horrific forms
of racism economic and legal oppression
that are uh not unfamiliar in uh our
marginal communities and and yet have
that spiritual resource to uh resist in
the face of overwhelming
odds what's coming
and we see it as the climate unravels at
a faster pace than climate
scientists
predicted we just saw us we've seen the
norwegian study up in the arctic where
they're saying that all of the
measurements in term of the in terms of
the arctic ice has been wrong uh because
that layer of old ice is gone all the
old and it's in fact new ice
um
the
severe drought in california uh and and
what happens as that society as our
society uh constricts uh politically
economically and and environmentally is
that the forces of corporate control
tighten uh the levers or the mechanisms
uh of power uh the fact that the
uh
corporatized media as one example uh
we'll talk about the drought in
california and not talk about the animal
agriculture industry which is
fundamental
to that drought
and in fact the animal agriculture
industry is
arguably the primary industry behind
global warming and yet the power of
those corporations are such that they
have shut out any kind of a discussion
even this critique of corporate power
uh one that figures like nader or noam
chomsky will give is
shut out those of us who offer this
critique are not offered a platform on
national media and
gnome and ralph and i all find i'm about
to leave for canada on friday
and it's one cbc show after another
and the last time i was in canada
speaking at ryerson university the cbc
filmed the show and here we want to
thank c-span for being here but they
filmed the show uh and and devoted a
one-hour program to it that is
impossible uh within the united states
um i used to wonder whether
uh huxley was right or or well was right
um and um
i think it turns out that they're both
right in a sense that what we first got
was huxley and as we were fleeced
as
we now reach a state where we can't get
credit where all of those cheap
manufactured consumer products are no
longer easily
accessible or available and sheldon
wolin in his great book democracy
incorporates in incorporated calls uh
that
those consumer the access to cheap
credit and consumerism one of the two
primary forms of political control once
those are removed uh then we
increasingly get uh
the the iron boot the iron fist uh that
orwell uh predicted so it turns out i
think that that orwell and huxley were
both right and we are seeing now that
transformation
as you get a huge underclass pushing 50
percent of this country
in terms of poor and near poor uh unable
to sustain a living
chronic underemployment
or unemployment which of course the
statistics mask once you stop looking
for work you're no longer counted as
unemployed or if you have a part-time
job at walmart 28 hours a week most
workers at walmart that's the average
they work you're still put below the
poverty line so you are given
applications for food stamps and you
qualify we subsidize the walden fortune
the walton family making about 11 000
a year
i think that ultimately for me and i
come out of uh
seminary i come out of a theological
background uh that resistance is is
finally not determined by
uh what empirically is around us
and that gets to what father daniel
berrigan who baptized our youngest
daughter
when he defines faith he says that faith
is the
called to do the good or at least the
good insofar as you can determine it and
then you let it go the buddhists call it
karma
faith is the belief that even if all of
the empirical evidence around you
says otherwise the good goes somewhere
and i think that for the rebel like the
religious mystic
it is this faith
that finally defines our capacity to
resist
because the forces that we are facing
are
deadly
and immense
and are unlike any totalitarian force
that human societies have faced in the
past
why
is there wholesale surveillance
and we can look at past totalitarian
regimes to understand it is because you
gather all of the information on the
citizenry so the moment that you need it
you can use it it's not about justice
it's not about innocence it's not about
uh who committed a crime or who didn't
it is about that moment that they decide
to criminalize an entire segment of the
population and have
whatever it is on your file that they
can reach out and twist and use against
you that is why all of our electronic
correspondence our medical records um
virtually everything about us which by
the way is now a big business
corporations sell all this stuff uh and
they have everything on you um but
that's why it's there and it is that
again that fusion of both corporate
and political power which is
indistinguishable of our 16 intelligence
agencies this is why snowden was working
for a private contractor 70 percent of
the intelligence is outsourced to
private corporations and and they are
using that intelligence as assiduously
and as cruelly as the state itself um at
this point there is no difference the
uh the the misuse of the judiciary by
judicial fiat to strip off strip us of
constitutional rights so that uh for
instance um
the right to privacy uh is not addressed
by the courts in very nefarious and dark
ways when i sued
the president i was also part of uh the
lawsuit that reached the supreme court
clapper versus amnesty international and
uh that was challenging the warrantless
wiretapping under the fisa amendment act
this is before the snowden revelations
and the government lawyers stood up in
court in the supreme court and said
it's speculation
the plaintiffs charge that they are
being monitored by the state is
speculation and
if
they were being monitored the government
would tell them
which we now know
from snowden is a lie
but
the court bought it
and at that same time
the obama administration
which had challenged at the day of judge
forrest ruling with a temporary
injunction declaring uh section 1021 of
the nda unconstitutional the day of the
ruling they sent lawyers not just
government attorneys federal attorneys
but attorneys from security agencies
into her chambers and
demanded that she reinstate lift the
temporary injunction reinstate the law
in the name of national security which
to her credit she refused they went then
the next week went to the appeals court
the second circuit demanded the same
thing and they uh did put it back into
effect the law back into effect and carl
mayer who's here was his father arno the
great historian uh and bruce afron i
don't know if bruce is here the great
lawyers on this case who did all the
works and i you know i just had to show
up in a code and tie um uh but we all
wondered why and and i think our
supposition was they're already using
the law and probably black sites like
bagram and other places
um
and so they they the the second circuit
waited
until
the supreme court ruled and then the
case was called hedges versus obama he
said the plaintiffs and hedges vs obama
the plaintiffs in the supreme court
clapper versus amnesty international
don't have standing or credibility
therefore they don't have it in hedges
versus obama now that that's
an example of how the court
plays a very dirty game by which it it
doesn't rule on the on the clear
unconstitutionality
of
deploying the military as a domestic
police force and seizing american
citizens as terrorists and stripping
them of due process
it skirts it in the same way that
citizens united defines uh unlimited
corporate cash as petitioning the
government of free speech
this is just over and over and over
that the court systems have been used to
strip us legally we have created
omnipotent policing beginning in
marginal communities places where doors
can be kicked down in the middle of the
night uh militarized police enter with
long barrel weapons these are for
non-violent warrants often drug warrants
entire families are terrorized
you only 94 percent of people in america
actually get a trial the police stack
you with
so many charges most of which you didn't
commit and then they offer to strip off
a few uh uh as a plea
um and if you actually go to court uh
they're gonna make an example of you
your sentence is going to be longer
and i can give you numerous examples
from the students that i teach
uh when you get inside the prison system
and you see what's been done
uh to the poor
uh this system of neo-slavery because of
course it is built on the exploitation
100
million uh prisoners now work mostly for
large corporations target pierre caden
they're the modeled worker if you want
to know what the corporate state wants
for the rest of us walk inside our
systems of the system of mass
incarceration because they're the model
worker no benefits
no health insurance they always show up
to work on time and should they actually
protest their conditions or attempt to
organize their sent off to solitary
confinement where they're locked away
for so long they often go insane
tens of thousands of american prisoners
are in solitary in this country britain
puts three to four prisoners a year in
solitary
and the economic engines that now drive
it
mean that these
corporations are writing the legislation
um
and so those prisons i think become a
kind of model for where we're headed
as we are
steadily stripped of our rights
and the struggle before us is one where
we are going to have to face
uh the
uh an assault on the ecosystem which
even if we stopped emitting carbon uh
today
would still trigger catastrophic change
uh it is the uh creation and we see it
these uh trade deals which are just
nafta on steroids uh
weakening the power of the government to
curb or halt corporate exploitation
and all of that means that the only
mechanism left
by which we can save ourselves and save
our children
is
to begin to carry out acts of mass civil
disobedience
um and that
requires
taking to the streets
i covered the revolutions in eastern
europe
east germany
czechoslovakia romania
and i watched
day after day hundreds of thousands
500 000 people in alexanderplatz
half a million people
in venezuela square in prague
and i was every night
uh in czechoslovakia in the magic
lantern theater with vaslav havel and
klaus and dinsbear all the people who
would inherit the government
and hovel for me was a kind of model
of what it means to be a dissident
uh what it means to rebel
he had of course begun
with charter 77 in 1977 in 1978 writing
his great essay the power of the
powerless calling upon us to live in
truth to ex not to expose by and by
living in truth exposing the system for
what it was
and
and that of course is the great terror
of the system that it is exposed for the
predatory creature that it has become
and hovel was not a particularly
charismatic figure or even a very good
speaker but he had the moral authority
there was no question in prague
and i remember that winner
all through the streets of the city
there were posters
of
a young charles university student named
jan [ __ ]
who to protest the soviet invasion
uh
which had overthrown dupe check
and re in stated a pro-soviet regime had
gone to wensolot square and lit himself
on fire
four days later he died of his wounds
and the funeral possession of students
from charles university to the graveyard
was broken up by the police it was never
reported of course it was a non-event
and we have many non-events now in this
country including
uh the the the poor in this country who
have been rendered invisible by a
corporate media unless
they cater to the stereotype of what did
our president call them thugs and
criminals
without understanding the long slow drip
of humiliation pain despair
indiscriminate violence that causes them
to react as we would react
if we were enduring the same form of
oppression
and uh when they buried pollock's body
his grave became a shrine they exhumed
his remains they cremated them they gave
them to his mother and said
she could not bury them
a week after the communist government
fell ten thousand people
went to red army square and renamed it
jan pollock square
that winter there were also
there was i was also in wenceslas square
when
uh the singer martha covasheva walked
out on that balcony
and she had sung the prayer to marta the
anthem of defiance
that
uh
was a call to resistance
in 1968
and when
dubchak was overthrown
her recording stock was destroyed she
was banned from the airwaves and in the
intervening years she had worked on an
assembly line in a toy factory
she walked out on that balcony
and began to sing the prayer for marta
and every check in the crowd knew every
word
that is the moral power of resistance
of living in truth
and that is what berrigan talked about
that when you stand up
for justice
even at that moment when it seems that
everyone around you is passive
and doesn't see you or hear you in fact
that truth seeps out
and
that's what i took away
from those revolutions from people like
vaslav havel they are those ironic
points of light
they hold forth that narrative
that at a certain moment becomes
a conflagration
rebellion finally is not carried out for
what we succeed
but for who it allows us
to become
i fight fascists
not because i'm going to win
but i fight fascists because they are
fascists
and that is the moral paradigm
imperative of revolt
it is the call to stand up and do what
is right
in the face of overwhelming and even
deadly odds with the recognition that we
may not succeed indeed most of us may
not succeed
but we cannot use the word hope
if we are not willing
to rebel
thank you
[Applause]
we need new batteries we have them
[Music]
okay i think yes all right
i'm going to go from here to over there
as someone who's written about
democratization in the rest of the world
not here
i've been struck with the protest street
protests in the last few years that deal
with corruption
lack of democracy in people's own
countries
one of the issues or problems with those
protests however is that they are not
already not
connected or networking sufficiently
with other forces in their own societies
such as what i call democratization ngos
for example they're not they're enough
in other words they're not tied to the
institutions which might help them or
support them i don't know whether you
want to make a parallel here
but it strikes me that that's an
inherent
problem with protest movements with
street protests
now you raise a good point that if there
is not
an alternative political vision
and if there is not a political
expression of that vision then those
movements become
chaotic and anarchic and are easily put
down
and that's where we have to look for
greece at greece or spain with podemos
cerresa in greece
uh 10 years ago cerresa was polling four
percent
and i think and i've spoken to
uh
shama sawant the
socialist city council woman in seattle
about this
uh at length and uh i think her point is
correct that we have to begin to build
movements that have a political
expression this was i think bernie
sanders great mistake in not running as
an independent but the goal the system's
gamed i am
work for ralph nader and a long time
admirer and supporter of nader so i
understand intimately all the obstacles
they throw up
to essentially lock out
anybody who doesn't conform to the
democratic or republican mold
but if we see elections as essentially
furthering a movement rather than as an
end in and of themselves uh and this is
something we're gonna uh shaman i will
be meeting with others in new york at
the end of the month i'm to go out and
kick off her campaign rally
uh in seattle on the 6th uh and i don't
want to run and she doesn't want to run
so we got to find some sacrificial then
we're we've tried to convince cornell
but he doesn't want to do it
but i think that's right i think that
that uh and this is where we have to
look at europe but the the secret is
building the movements because it's the
movements
has howard zinn understood it's the
movements that none of which achieve
formal positions of power that opened up
the space in american democracy the
liberty party that fought slavery the
suffragists the labor movement the civil
rights movement and the most powerful
political figure in america until he was
murdered assassinated in 19 in april
1968 was king because when he went to
memphis or he went to selma 50 000
people went with him which is why
johnson and the power establishment were
terrified of him and that is the point
karl popper makes that point in the open
society and its enemies that the
question is not how do you get good
people to rule that's the wrong question
papa writes
most people attracted to power he says
are mediocre or venal
the question is how do you make the
power elite frightened of you
so that there's a and
kissinger's memoirs don't buy the book
uh
he and nixon are looking out a window in
the white house i think it's 71 there's
a huge anti-war demonstration they have
bus empty city buses you know kind of
as barricades all around the white house
and nixon's going henry
they're going to break through the
barricades and get us and that's just
where we want people in power to be and
that's why nixon was the last liberal
president we had not because he was
liberal or had a heart but because he
was frightened of movements
the mind and safety act osha the clean
water act all of which were authored by
nader is pushed through with a
functioning liberal wing of the
democratic party that has now been
destroyed courtesy of bill clinton
um
and
and and we lost that understanding that
it's not our job to take power
it is our job to build movements that
hold power accountable and that's what
unfortunately we've lost those movements
uh in the name of anti-communism they
it's been a century of destruction
labor
the old anarchist movement the old cio
the wobblies the communist party which
whatever you think of the communist
party was sitting down integrating lunch
counters long before king and the civil
rights movement which that's been that
we that that is history has been
completely erased from american
consciousness
and the destruction of the state ellen
schrecker writes about this in no ivory
tower the purging of the universities
and her other books i think such were
the crimes
until thousands upon thousands of
journalists social workers high school
teachers artists all of whom were pushed
out of the society and blacklisted the
fbi she writes would show up at a high
school with a list of six or seven
teachers no evidence they were gone and
they could never get another job
the aclu is purged they're all purged
and this was done by design
and all of the blood that was spilled
the american labor wars were the
bloodiest in the industrialized world
the blood of those workers that created
the middle class
that opened up the space in our society
all of that sacrifice has been rolled
back and we have to rise up with that
same sacrificial spirit and that same
uh
ferocity
of holding fast to moral imperatives to
build movements because in that sense
i'm an anarchist i think power is always
the problem
uh and we must build movements that hold
power accountable and we have to start
now
thank you uh thank you for your talk
it's very interesting
we certainly need a critical mass of
people
a very large number of people stand up
against the power elite uh our
government the corporations but don't
you think it's going to take uh a
massive catastrophe on the level of like
right well
you raise a good point it's a it's a
very important point because if you look
and i write i do look back at uh
you know
1848 and other cycles yes historians
write revolutions tend to come in waves
and this wave is beginning
but it's usually a crisis
so all of the tinder is there and i
think all of the tinder is there but
what is it that sets it off it's often
something relatively banal so the first
palestinian intifada is set off by a
traffic accident where seven palestinian
day workers are killed by the driver and
israeli truck
um
it's just a point where people have had
enough i mean the the murder
by
um
militarized
forces of occupation that we call the
police
uh of people of color is not new
um but it's finally enough
and uh but you're right that it's that
the the encroachment of the state in
terms of the stripping away of our
rights and the more draconian forms of
control
uh
it in a moment of crisis it's it it
exposes itself so when aaron
in origins of totalitarianism writes
about omnipotent policing she's writing
about the stateless and she was
stateless left germany stripped of her
passport has no rights in france she
said when you create legal and physical
mechanisms of omnipotent policing which
we have done of course in the war on
drugs and the criminalization of poverty
uh then when the society breaks down it
becomes very dangerous because you
already have both the legal and the
physical mechanism to use those forces
against the society at large
but you're right it is a crisis i i
covered the breakdown of yugoslavia it
was hyperinflation uh that triggered uh
the unrest and we must there's a chapter
in the book called vigilante violence we
have to understand that america is a
deeply violent culture it is a culture
that is a society that is founded on
genocide and slavery um that faulkner
gets it that is the original sin we
carry it within our dna today um
the systems of mass incarceration is
neo-slavery uh it has been uh changed or
mutated it has a protein quality but
it's all slavery by another name
and uh
the uh
you know the moment that
the state feels
seriously threatened is the moment that
the mask will fall
and uh what is
a common experience for the poor
and especially the urban poor will
become an experience for the rest of us
so that moment of crisis if we're not
prepared could be seized uh by
proto-fascist movements we have no
shortage of them the christian right the
tea party the lunatic fringe of the
republican party i mean we have to give
clinton his due he turned the democratic
party into the republican party the
democratic party in europe would be a
far-right party and he pushed the
republicans so far to the right they
became insane
um
and and and the and the state if it
feels it already feels it's already
worried i mean the nsa has run scenario
after scenario on climate breakdown and
ryan they know what's coming they're
ready
um this is not you know the the
uh
the rise of these forces of and that's
what happens when empires go down you
bring the
uh draconian and violent forces of
control on the outer reaches of empire
that we internally don't see back into
the heart of empire
and that's how we get militarized police
wholesale surveillance uh drones uh you
know all the stripping away of civil
liberties those are the standard
mechanism by which empire perpetuates
itself so it's the disease of empire
come back and visited upon all of us who
were complacent while crimes were being
committed in our name
can you hear me
um
mr fukuyama was here recently and he
spoke but not as
strongly as you did about the current
situation i agree with everything you
said
and i don't know whether we need a
disaster but when i observed occupy wall
street which was a grassroots movement
nothing really happened in the end and
when you look back at the anti-vietnam
war movements you had powerful leaders
powerful minds committed with moral
authority you're one of those persons
why don't you start one you'll there'll
be thousands of people who will follow
you people who write about it are
committed but we need powerful voices
and leaders like you to gather the
grassroots
well that that is you know my
differentiation because i in the end i'm
i'm a writer and i don't go before
audiences even in zuccotti park and tell
them what they want to hear i was very
critical of black bloc anarchists which
did not win me friends in the occupy
movement but as i told many of the
people in the occupy movement the moment
i need your adulation i'm finished it's
my job as a writer to try and speak the
truth insofar as i can
determine it
i think the occupy movement was a
profound
and seismic event in modern american
history because it was the rise of what
bakunin called the day class say
intellectuals remember marx uh dismissed
the day class say intellectuals although
uh you know both marx and lenin were
intellectuals um and and bakunin was
right so what you got in occupy were
largely the sons and daughters of the
white middle class who had taken out uh
tremendous loans horrible loans uh found
themselves thrown into horrific debt
peonage couldn't get jobs and there was
no place for them in the society as they
assumed and as they had been told by
all through their lives and by the
institutions in which the to which they
went into debt to attend that there
would be and so
that role the rise of the day class say
intellectuals uh uniting with service
workers and the working poor in this
country uh i think was extremely
important we have to remember that there
were all sorts of problems internally
especially after the tents went up
that's when the drugs came in we saw
some sexual assault in zuccotti but the
in the end the occupy movement was
destroyed it was destroyed in a
coordinated federal effort led by
president barack obama uh and i think we
have to look at occupy as a tactic uh as
uh and in the same way that the freedom
rides were a tactic
uh you know you and then uh
the integration of uh
buses and montgomery were tactic these
are tactics and something's coming it
may not look like occupy may not call
itself occupy we are seeing it with the
radicalization of
black youth who are showing in places
like ferguson a political sophistication
remember jesse jackson and al sharpton
were booed out of ferguson
when when they tried to show up and hold
events there jackson was literally
driven out of the city and never came
back because they looked at that black
elite
the way
and and and and that's how that black
elite functions it functions this is
corporate colonialism so you push face
you push out of barack obama
who does the bidding of corporate power
and those kids in ferguson
who didn't attend princeton get it in a
way that i suspect some of those kids at
princeton do not get it
and they because they have been victims
of that oppression
and uh
and uh you know one of the leaders of
hands up united was invited to the white
house and obama asked him did you vote
for me he said no i'm not going to vote
for you just because you're black that
would be shallow that's those are his
words
t-dub oh the great great hip-hop artist
and and so
that is a level of i mean the whole sort
of focus on gender or race is
anti-politics it's anti-political
there's no political content to it and
what we have in presidential elections
are
and and hillary's about to spend what
two and a half billion dollars
they are manufactured personalities they
use the sophistication of the public
relations industry to make us confuse
how we are made to feel with knowledge
and they create
fictitious personas that appeal to us
and that we vote for this is not
politics
it's
absurdist political theater
and
uh
and those
students i teach in a prison and those
kids in ferguson are probably way ahead
of most of the people in princeton new
jersey
in your latest column you you write
against a
bernie sanders campaign
but it seems to me that
a campaign
led by a self-described socialist
in this country
that was able to generate some
[Music]
grassroots support from
rank and file democrats and independents
would only
help to build
a radical movement right it wouldn't
hurt it right but but that that would be
if it was carried out outside the
democratic party and that was sanders
mistake that is what he is not doing so
if you want to find out what happens
when you declare yourself as a socialist
and then serve corporate power you can
look at olonde and france who's probably
destroyed the socialist party in france
for a generation but why why couldn't it
possibly help to build
an independent radical movement because
all those followers once they're either
disappointed or betrayed
they're going to need somewhere else to
go right well they were already
disappointed and betrayed by barack
obama
the problem is that he's not going to be
allowed to run unless he agrees to
endorse hillary clinton so by next april
he's out
and what he does is he then works to
push his supporters those self-defined
liberals and progressives back into the
dead space of the democratic party and
he did not run as an independent because
he didn't want to lose his committee
chairmanships and he knew what the
democratic party would do to him because
he saw what they did to ralph nader and
that's not speculation because i've
asked him about it and there were
several of us who pushed him or asked
him to run as an independent and he
refused to do it well that's what we
have to do it it's not
you know it's not the leaders that are
going to save us radical change is only
ratified
or acknowledged in parliaments or
congresses
it comes from the street
and you see in a moment of seismic
change are kind of swinging back and
forth you saw the french revolution so
you create
the
uh
the national guard
under lafayette which is a
counter-revolutionary force which is
firing and then the french rise up again
there's a kind of swinging back and
forth as the counter-revolutionary
elites seek to seize control and push
back on the revolution
and the the advance of the revolution so
the the whole point is that without
movements it's a sterile exercise
that we have to invest our energy into
building radical movements that push
back and frighten
centers of power and you know occupy
frightened wall street occupy frightened
more than i think the occupiers realized
it they terrified the state what really
terrified the state was when mothers and
fathers from new jersey were coming into
zuccotti and pushing their strollers up
and down that really frightened them
because
essentially it was
mainstreaming the movement which is why
they had to demonize it
you know the state is fragile
the chicago teacher teachers are
marching through the streets of chicago
they go into a precinct office to use
the bathroom and the police applaud that
terrifies the state
a couple years ago i'm with
veterans for peace 133 of us most mostly
vets are arrested in front of the white
house and it turns out that the cops
have been in the national guard they've
been in iraq and afghanistan and as they
cuff us and it happened to me
they whisper
in your ear keep protesting these words
now the state knows that
and that's why the state passed the ndaa
because it doesn't trust the police to
protect them all revolutions
are are non-violent not colonial wars
but colonial uprisings but revolutions
because
no revolution succeeds crane brinton and
other theorists of revolution who i
quote in my book right about this no
revolution succeeds until the foot
soldiers of the elite the security
forces the police the military will no
longer defend them that's how the czar
was overthrown the cossacks go into
petrograd for the bread riots
they refused they fraternized with a
crowd the czar is rushed back on a
railway line he abdicates on the siding
he doesn't even get back to pedrograd
in when i covered the revolution in east
germany eric honaker he'd been in power
19 years he sends down an elite
paratroop division to leipzig to fire on
the crowd they get there they won't do
it hanukkah is out in another week
and because we have the most dangerous
weapon in our hands
which is the truth about power and about
the state
once we stand up and are no longer
afraid and they are manufacturing fear
in this country at a rate i was in
amtrak and it was saying if you see
something say and the end of the video
the person's being cuffed and taken away
just as a reminder
they are terrified
and if we lose the capacity for fear
and if we stand up in a non-violent
manner
to live in truth and i saw it in the
stasi state in east germany
then it creates
paralysis within the systems of power
they may use violence but they
ultimately won't use it effectively
because there's too many people who
don't want to carry it out
because there's too many people who have
relatives out in those crowds when they
went to get those paratroopers and bring
them into the streets of leipzig they
were crying because their families and
friends were on the streets of leipzig
and they didn't want to shoot them and
they did not shoot them
and we have that capacity if we build
the critical mass
to expose corporate power
for what it is
but it requires us to go out in the
street
getting arrested is more time than i
care to donate to the u s government
but i'm afraid that's the only option
we have
and
we have no time left
as the latest report on carbon emissions
in the month of march
has shown us we have no time left
um thank you i agree with you that it's
a tervy topsy time
um
i would like to know
how many fascists you've met
that know they are fascists since you're
calling them the enemy
and that doesn't count those who know
they're part of the chain
and want to break it
there's a good book
by a german thessaloni male fantasies i
pronounced it right dortay
what
table there thank you
um
and he argues i think correctly that in
the end fascism doesn't really have any
ideology despite this thing about
corporatism and mussolini i mean
you know
fascism has a very often uncomfortable
relationship with business because
unlike inverted totalitarianism where
the primacy of corporate profit takes
precedence over everything in fascism uh
and wolin makes this point in his great
book democracy incorporated uh you will
carry out things that are not economic
don't economically make sense so you
know your railway system is being bombed
to smithereens at the end of the war and
you're using it to ship more jews you
know off to
sobibor or auschwitz so how many
fascists know their fascists most
fascists define themselves as patriots
um i would describe the whole
celebration of american sniper as a form
of fascism
uh and all of those people who decided
to cheer every time in that movie some
iraqi was killed as expressing fascist
sentiments
proto-fascism is alive and well in
america uh it always has been
the clan as
um is a kind of you know
quintessential fascist
organization um
and what fascist movements do is they
channel
with the most retrograde elements of
american capitalism sheldon adelson the
koch brothers it channels a legitimate
rage
towards the vulnerable undocumented
workers muslims
liberals
homosexuals feminists either have a very
long list of people they despise
um
and uh
and that is
part of the current of american society
and that's why i wrote a chapter called
vigilante violence because um we are not
canada
um we have a very dark we are a very
violent culture and uh in times of
distress
i mean those workers who died were
usually shot by vigilantes baldwin felts
pinkertons gun thugs
and not to mention the terror that was
visited on african americans not only
through the clan but the white leagues
and the red shirts and i think it was
north carolina i mean on and on and on
so
that is also
part of our dna
and a very frightening part of our dna
which means that the backlash that i
think is finally coming could
very
possibly be a very frightening
right-wing backlash where people cry out
for
uh
for authority
for hyper masculine authority but i
think that notion of hyper masculinity
uh
uh i think is kind of very very
insightful and we see it with the
celebration of the military in the
united states
the celebration of military
quote-unquote virtues
uh
the
you know hierarchy of the military i
mean there's a kind of state religion at
this point built
around the military that's uh that's
very scary
so we have time unfortunately just for
one more question um and your hand here
has been up
i've been reading your truth to a column
for quite a few years now and i want to
recommend to everyone who hasn't read
the most recent i thought it was the
most precise the most concise
distillation of years worth of your
thinking
um
a tennis match began
in the blog after your column
of people crying out on both sides
you have to vote in the next election
uh locally no nationally no you can't
vote in the next election you're you're
not voting will be the protest
can you comment
well
i mean as emma goldman said if voting
was that effective it would be illegal
i mean i will vote as a protest vote
so uh i supported nader until 2008 i
voted for jill stein in 2012. i think
jill is running again
but my fear is that somehow people think
that voting is important
every totalitarian state i covered
including saddam hussein had elections
stalin had written the most enlightened
constitution in human history and i
think he promulgated it at the height of
the purges in the 30s
so
voting is utterly tangential
not so much locally and that's why i am
working to support sawan i'll do this
fundraiser for her in new york at the
end of the month and then we'll go out
to seattle to help her begin her
campaign because the democratic
establishment not just
uh in the state of washington but in
nationally is determined to destroy her
because like nader
she exposes them the bankruptcy
of the party and that's why she has to
be
destroyed
um so i think you're right locally that
you know there can be some important
because you don't need the massive sums
of cash but by the time you get on the
national stage um then i i do vote
uh but i'm and uh i don't
i just don't think it that that voting
means that much at this
i want point invite all of you to linger
a little bit and we can continue the
conversation but for now let's uh join
in thanking chris
[Applause]
also um i would be remiss as a
bookseller if i didn't tell you that
chris was going to
sign books at the book table upfront
every weekend book tv offers programming
focused on non-fiction authors and books
keep watching for more here on c-span 2.
and book tv's live coverage from new
york city continues this is the inside
of the javits convention center on the
west side of new york
book con is happening today this is a
book festival open to the public it
follows on the heels of book expo
america which is the publisher's annual
convention and book tv has been live all
week here at book expo america and today
we're taking advantage of the fact that
we're still here and we've invited
author chris hedges
on to talk about his most recent book
which just came out this month it's
called wages of rebellion the moral
imperative
of
revolution mr hedges the first line in
your book
we live in a revolutionary moment what
do you mean
i mean that the ideas that have
sustained
the
old system
of global capitalism laissez-faire
capitalism the idea that
an elite
accruing to itself massive amounts of
money
will somehow trickle down
and make the middle class and the
working class more prosperous has been
exposed as a lie the institutions the
political institutions that perpetuate
that ideology
have lost their support their efficacy
congress has an approval rating of about
seven or nine percent um
and we've entered what the theorist
antonio gramsci
uh describes as an interrugnum a period
where
we
uh have lost faith in the ideas that
buttress a particular political and
economic system but we have yet to
articulate
uh or or find a vision for what should
replace it but that the discontent is
there uh even the anger is there a sense
of betrayal
the realization across the political
spectrum that
in essence corporate power
no longer
concerns itself with the rights or
grievances of
citizens the citizenry i think is is
extremely widespread
so do you see collapse of the current
system
um ultimately yes uh the system's not
sustainable anytime a small
cabal of
uh takes power and uh twists
institutions of power to serve their own
ends then as you can go all the way back
to aristotle as aristotle wrote in
politics then you end up either with
revolt or tyranny when that comes what
sets it off oftentimes decaying systems
can sustain themselves
for a very long time the
austro-hungarian
empire was in rot from probably from uh
you know 1848 until the end of world war
ii these systems can go on a long time
in essence what they are systems that
don't respond rationally to the rights
and the needs of citize the citizenry um
you know it doesn't matter what the
citizens want uh nobody wants wholesale
surveillance uh but we get it anyway
everybody is sick of the wars in iraq
and afghanistan but they never end
because they make a certain segment of
the economy that manufactures arms very
wealthy uh
you know nobody wants uh these trade
these tpp or kafta agreements but
they're rammed through anyway and of
course they're held in secret even our
legislators are not allowed to speak
about them uh i sued barack obama in
federal court over section 1021 of the
national defense authorization act which
allows the u.s military overturns over
150 years
of domestic law and permitting the
military to seize american citizens
strip them of due process hold them in
military facilities indefinitely
if they are deemed by the state to be
terrorists we won in the federal the
southern district court of new york
it was appealed by the obama
administration
and unfortunately uh the temporary
injunction uh was lifted and it is it is
still law but we know from opinion polls
on the ndaa it had a 97
disapproval rating these are all
symptoms of a state uh that doesn't work
on behalf of us and uh and that angst i
think
really runs all the way across the
political spectrum now if the state
continues uh to ignore
the legitimate grievances and the
suffering economic suffering of the
population uh despite
uh appeals for a sensible reform
then inevitably it will trigger
more radical responses that will
ultimately lead to a confrontation
between large segments of the population
the state when it comes what triggers it
oftentimes these things are triggered by
a crisis the case of yugoslavia which i
covered as a foreign correspondent it
was
hyperinflation uh but an economic
meltdown with climate change we're
seeing of course severe droughts in
places like california
another act of catastrophic domestic
terrorism
but anything that kind of the system
can't sustain a shock and it triggers a
reaction i mean i would talk about uh
black lives matter with all of these
people walking through the streets of
cities like baltimore or ferguson
we live in a country where almost every
28 hours
an african-american man or woman is shot
dead lethal force they're usually
unarmed we have videos of
our police actually murdering unarmed
civilians
and yet
despite
the outcry it continues uh and we have
in the sp last month seen a spate of
shootings of police officers one in new
york uh two in mississippi
uh
just the other day two and i'm hoping
that these are just incidental
uh
you know and but if that becomes a
pattern um i mean that certainly would
replicate the disintegrating societies
that i covered people reach such a level
of rage that they finally lash out um
but but that's where we're headed the
state is is has turned its back on on
people like you and me so how effective
are some of these
rebellions uh black lives matter occupy
wall street ed snowden right
well
they're effective in this sense
they expose the lie
that the state uses
or the myth the state uses
to
explain itself to the public
you know the idea that we have a right
to privacy
and we know from the snowden revelations
we are the most photographed monitored
watch eavesdropped population in human
history and i covered the collapse of
the stasi state in east germany
you can't use the word liberty
when you are watched 24 hours a day by
your government that is the relationship
of a master and a slave and you never
want to give any government that kind of
power because when they accrue to
themselves that kind of power coupled
with militarized police coupled with a
legal system that essentially renders
those the state targets defenseless
if they feel threatened uh they will
they will use all the tools at their
disposal to protect themselves so um
i say in the book i begin the book by
you know talking about past revolutions
and you know revolutions come in waves
often so you see what's happening in
greece affecting what happens in spain
affecting what happens in ireland and
here and other parts um revolutions
interestingly enough are fundamentally
non-violent uh all of the great
theorists of revolution i quote crain
brinton and here and davies and others
say that no revolution i think this is
correct is successful until
significant segments of the internal
security apparatus defect or are
no longer willing to protect a
discredited power elite so uh despite
there was certainly violence in the
russian revolution especially anarchist
violent assassinations of alexander ii
etc
but
what broke the back of the tsarist
regime was the petrograd red riots in
1917
uh they send the cossacks who were kind
of the tsar's enforcers they refused to
fire on the crowd they fraternize with
the crowd bizarre is rushed back from
the front and he has to abdicate in a
railway sighting in a carriage now i
watched the same thing in east germany
and this certainly that was the probably
up until our state the most
sophisticated security and surveillance
apparatus i mean dwarfing even stalin's
uh soviet union
so eric honaker the
communist dictator is upset about the
street demonstrations in leipzig where
70 000 people are marching through the
streets protesting the communist regime
and he sends down an elite paratroop
division to fire on the crowd they get
there uh
they they refuse to fire on the crowd
hanukkah loses power within a week the
same thing with the shah as soon as the
shah flees the country and then the
armed forces in 1979 are no longer
willing to protect the shah and homanian
and clerics are able to take over that's
how revolutions work and and it goes
back to a 1978 essay by vaclav havel
the power of the powerless
hovel of course leading the velvet
revolution and i also covered the velvet
revolution i was in the magic lantern
theater every night with hobble and
klaus and dinsbear and all these people
inherited the government but it's that
that stating of a truth that becomes
more and more obvious
to the wider society and obvious finally
to those who are within the organs of
power and they no longer are willing to
protect a discredited elite
and i have been involved with groups
like occupy but i've been a fierce
opponent of like black block anarchists
who taunt the police and will do
property damage because i believe that
our greatest strength is as havel said
this living in truth stating the truth
and because once
revolutions become violent that it
empowers those who have
not only a capacity for violence or
pension for violence but on access to
weapons and who prefer to speak in the
language of violence uh and they speak
the language of violence not only to
their opponents but to each other and
that's how lenin you know ends up
crushing uh uh the anarchists and the
soviets uh the mensheviks uh through
violence and and that having
been a foreign correspondent in
societies such as the war in yugoslavia
or i covered the war in el salvador for
five years i desperately don't want us
to go there um and i believe that if a
large a large enough segment of the
population uh probably three to five
percent we're not talking about you know
are willing to put their bodies in the
street in a sustained way as we saw in
eastern europe uh we can begin to affect
hopefully non-violent change um because
at this point uh i think it's fair to
say we're not going to at least in my
analysis going to affect change through
the traditional reformist mechanisms
because they've been eviscerated by
corporate power we've undergone a
corporate coup d'etat
in slow motion and and i think it's over
how many years did you spend at the new
york times 15
we've written about 10 books so so far
12 yeah maybe 14 i've lost are we up to
14 now this is the most recent wages of
rebellion the moral imperative of revolt
numbers are up on the screen if you want
to talk with chris hedges 202 748 8200
if you live in the east and central time
zone
748-8201 for those of you out west and
let's get into the calls with
beginning with jim in macelon ohio jim
you're on with author chris hedges
well hello guys the background noise
there is is tremendous i hope you can
hear me okay
uh peter slim you are the best at what
you do
mr hedges i'm a retired school teacher
i've got two of your books on my kindle
right now the world as it is and uh
wages of rebellion
so you'll be glad to hear that that i
brought those um you put your finger on
virtually every black hole in our public
structures
uh you have the ability a wonderful
ability that i the only other person
i've ever seen quite like it and i hope
you'll take this as a compliment was
christopher hitchens who's able to talk
extemporaneously on virtually any
subject for about an hour
so i i i think that that's terrific that
you that you know your topic so well
in your book the world as it is uh you
you make the following statement uh
which which i believe you've
also mentioned with peter democracy will
eventually be replaced with a robust
national police state and of course you
know this goes to a lot of the things
we've been watching but i i want to put
on a note of optimism here
i think the numbers are with us right
now i think i think there is a tilt
beginning to happen we may be at an
inflection point where and maybe the
police and the military are going to be
more or less falling in line with the
people as you stated in one of your
talks when someone put the handcuffs on
you they were saying you know keep it up
so
if you want to speak to the fact that
maybe the number there is a tipping
point or an inflection here and maybe
the numbers aren't all right
jim thank you very much for the nice
words and for your call well that's why
non-violence is so important uh you know
we have to
appeal to the conscience of those within
the power structures
and
if
we
view the power structure as a kind of
monolithic enemy
as a force where
uh people of good conscience don't
reside then i think we're finished and
you're right i i was arrested in front
of the white house and some of the
police were arresting us this was the
protest i was with veterans for peace
protesting the war in iraq and
afghanistan when they cuffed us it turns
out they'd been in the national guard
and they hated the wars as much as we
did and as i was cuffed uh they said you
know keep protesting
these wars and the state of course
recognizes that and worries about that
and i think part of the reason they
passed the ndaa which permits the
military to carry out domestic policing
in essence extraordinary rendition on
the streets of american city is that
because i think they finally don't trust
the police in a moment of crisis to
protect them
chris hedges i want to go to
jim's inflection or tipping point
in some ways rand paul could have
written right parts of your book is that
a correct yes statement it is or would
you agree with that yeah i mean i'm not
a libertarian because i feel that that
the the only effective mechanism we as
citizens have to fork corporate power is
government and that by making government
more anemic we make corporate power more
uh
global or more omnipotent
i mean who is going to make sure that bp
doesn't
uh go back and
i mean the gulf is largely a dead zone
but i mean who's going to make sure that
these things don't happen
you need a mechanism a superstructure so
i would disagree with them on that but
on the issue of imperial war and on the
issue of security and surveillance uh
the libertarians are really good uh and
they recognize the danger of both uh and
so we are in convergence and i know ron
paul will occasionally put articles that
i write up on his website usually on
these issues and of course i spent 20
years on the outer reaches of empire i
understand
the mechanisms of empire
in a way that americans who probably
haven't been there do not and in fact
the senate will be in on sunday right
debating
the uh
surveillance and patriot act and usa
freedom act as it's called from the
house right they'll be coming in
in uh on sunday afternoon larry's in
centralia washington hi larry
yeah it's an honor to speak with mr
hedges
i saw you at our bookstore in portland
oregon sometime back
but i'm wondering
i uh
the philippines when marcos was
thrown out the army turned against him
too because i think he was going to have
him
fire on the people
but my question is if
you think that the iraq war was dick
cheney
salvaging halliburton warsaw and who's
now in dubai
after the billions of dollars they made
right the iraq war
um and i was a vocal
opponent of the call to invade iraq i
had been the middle east bureau chief
for the new york times i spent seven
years in the middle east i speak arabic
i recognize like most arabists and i
would say the erebus within the
intelligence community within the
pentagon within the state department
that the whole
uh
reason reasoning behind invading iraq
was based on a non-reality based belief
system
the idea that
we would be greeted as liberators the
idea that the oil revenues would pay for
the reconstruction the idea that
democracy would be implanted in baghdad
and emanate outwards across the middle
east or a non-reality-based belief
system i i i think that many of these
ideologues like cheney wolfowitz pearl
eliot abrams et cetera i think they
believe their own rhetoric they have no
experience in the middle east at all
they're culturally historically
linguistically illiterate um i think
they also believe that what's good for
u.s business or u.s corporations
although corporations are now global uh
what's good for corporations is good for
america plus i think it was a
convergence but fundamentally it was
based on frightening a frightening
misunderstanding of uh
of the region and in particular of the
country and what we what invading would
do and you know they always would say
who's worse than saddam hussein well you
know isis is worse than saddam hussein
and we created isis in much the same way
we created al qaeda
from wages of rebellion chris hedges
writes that revolutions when they begin
are invisible at least to the wider
society they start with the slow
discrediting and dismantling of an old
ideology and an old language used to
interpret reality and justify power
you also write that keystone pipeline is
part of the final phase of extreme
exploitation
can you explain that
yes uh and we'll go back to karl marx
i'm not a marxist but i think marx's
analysis of
the inner workings of capitalism and
where it's going is uh correct and and
and important in terms of reading and
and marx argued that unfettered or
unregulated capitalism uh at the end
became a revolutionary force there were
no there's no internal impediments
obviously to accruing or gathering more
profit and once the external elements
are removed it then is free to exploit
everything human labor and the ecosystem
until exhaustion or collapse and that's
why the environmental crisis is
intimately twinned with the economic
crisis so forty percent of the summer
arctic ci smelts shell oil raises up to
drop half billion dollar drill bits into
the arctic sea to profit off the death
throes of the planet the tar sands is
like leading a match because of course
it's even dirtier uh form of energy uh
and there's no impediment there's no
rational discourse about preserving our
future for our children and for
succeeding generations it's all about uh
you know profiting uh
you know in the most destructive way we
can as fast as we can uh and this is
probably very good it is very good for
uh you know the bottom line for large
fossil fuel corporations but it's very
bad for the human race and
and that is essentially what's happened
when civil society is disintegrated uh
the common good is no longer a factor
it's not part of the equation uh carl
polyani in the great transformation
where he writes about the nature of
unfettered
capitalism uh actually he's always an
economist he uses the word sacred he
said when uh nothing has an intrinsic
value in the society when everything has
a monetary value
then you have built within it a
self-analytic quality which marx also
got and that's kind of where we are we
need to rapidly step back from this kind
of mentality i mean the whole idea that
the dictates of the market place should
govern every aspect of human behavior is
insane
no other society has tried it it's not
working out very well for us but i as a
father of four i'm terrified for
what's coming next and we have to build
systems essentially governmental systems
that are not wholly owned subsidiaries
of corporate power
but become stewards of the earth
stewards of our nation so that my
children your children and succeeding
generations will be able to
inherit and live a life
of quality and and health and and these
corporations that's not part of their
dna that's not what they think
bill's in washington dc bill go ahead
you know thank you very much um brief
preface brief question i'm 74 years old
almost retired army psychiatrist and i
subscribe to a fringe group of
understanding group process which in
america goes under the term tavistock
t-a-v-i-s-t-o-c-k my question what's
happened to the concept of government of
by and for the people and behind that is
i firmly believe that the entire group
that constitutes our citizenry is should
feel responsible for the entire action
of our group and that would even apply
good or bad it could be you know world
war ii the extremes on either side are
good examples but what happens if you
could get the lower 50 percent to stop
feeling like victims and start feeling
like contributors to what we have
using basically one of our pure
axiomatic statements government of by
and for the people that's what's on my
mind
well um i mean the consent
of the governed has kind of become a
cruel joke uh i think we see over and
over and we spoke a little earlier uh in
the program about all sorts of programs
including the bailouts constituent calls
uh against the bailout were 100 to one
across the political spectrum and yet
these banks were bailed out anyway
because that's what the big ten citibank
and wells fargo and goldman sachs these
other firms wanted and got uh and i
think that yes the consent of the
governed uh government of buying for the
people uh
means exactly that a government is a
superstructure that is designed uh to
create a quality of life for its
citizens and i would argue in a
democracy watch out for the most
vulnerable uh children the elderly the
sick mentally ill who we've tossed out
on uh heating grades surplus labor as
manufacturing has moved overseas you go
into poor communities of color
and these people have no work no
opportunity which is why of course we
have
the largest prison system in the
industrialized world 25
of the world's prison population because
black and brown bodies can't create
money for corporations if they're out on
a street and there's no jobs but they
can generate 40 or 50 000 a year if
they're locked in a cage which is why a
lot of these people we're talking about
you know huge numbers of people who
never committed a violent crime that's
why they're locked in cages so uh i
think on every single level uh
the primacy of corporate profit and
corporate power has trumped uh what is
fundamental to our democracy we need to
recover
we need to recover our country
jennifer's in ruidoso downs new mexico
and you are on with chris hedges on book
tv jennifer
hi mr hedges it's great to speak with
you
i'm a great fan
i have one question well i have two but
one's really pressing in my mind i'm
glad you mentioned ndaa
and i thank you for suing the president
on behalf of the american people
we have operation jade helm upcoming
and
10 states to last two months
it's
purported to be a military action
quote
training
two months ongoing and they're using a
lot of special forces
and i i assume and it's hard for me not
to think that that will
somehow fall under the provisions of the
ndaa are they coming to kill us are they
coming to put us in prisons
and my next point would be my next
question to you is have you found as i
have found
that based on
as much surveillance that we're
subjected to in all ways of
communications it's very difficult for
us to organize
and to
move forward as a movement of the people
against these powers that be
well let's talk about the ndaa and uh
judge catherine ruby forrest in the
southern district of court of new york
who
imposed a temporary injunction declaring
the law unconstitutional
my former employer the new york times
covered the trial and wrote a very good
editorial supporting the judge's
decision um
uh
he declared that they now have the power
and we went to the democratic leadership
by the way the lawyers bruce afron and
carl mayer and myself and said that we
would be willing to drop the lawsuit if
they would just write into the
provisions that this did not apply to
u.s citizens which they would not do
because of course it does apply to u.s
citizens and in judge forrest's opinion
she raises uh the internment of 110 000
japanese americans during world war ii
and said that this
provision uh permits the government to
criminalize in her words an entire group
of people
and and hold them
in essence in internment camps or in
military facilities uh where they can
sit without ever seeing a lawyer so uh
what's happening now we're not in a
state of crisis i don't think the state
needs to employ
that kind of those kind of draconian
forms of control
but should uh the society disintegrate
should there be uh
the kind of unrest uh that we see in
some european countries like greece for
instance then they certainly will bring
in the military if they feel that they
need the military in order to retain
power and they will use uh these legal
mechanisms which they have created for
themselves
against us i don't we're not in a moment
of crisis right now
there's a we're in a moment of relative
stability so i think while yes you know
they put tanks
on the streets of ferguson missouri
against unarmed protesters while you see
glimpses of the capacity of the military
state
uh i think we'd have to be in a kind of
free fall for us to begin to see this
employed on a very large scale
wages of rebellion is chris hedges
newest book and carl's in midvale utah
carl go ahead
thank you mr hedges for your insights um
don't know if you're surprised to be um
allied with rand paul as has been
mentioned
and uh even glenn beck in your stance on
non-violent protest i was curious
to know if your book has any insights
on things that people can do
to be
persuasive with the government in a
non-violent way we seem to be in a trend
that's violent
right now
um are there steps we can take to um to
be effective in protesting in a
non-violent way
and um
and not become criminalized as entire
groups
thank you carl well the problem is that
even non-violent protest brings with it
uh
[Music]
the you know the use of a legal system
that has criminalized a set so for
instance you've seen large numbers of
people who are very closely involved
with the occupy movement charged with
felonies they're often allowed to plea
out but because they're on probation uh
they have to be very careful about doing
any kind of activism uh you know we have
seen uh on the rise of omnipotent
policing only 94 percent of people in
this country go to trial most get
stacked with plea charges many of which
they didn't commit and then they
bargained their way out um
uh so there's a there's a legal system
and a physical mechanism uh that uh is
used to criminalize and will be used to
criminalize even non-violent descent um
and so for me
i think it would be uh foolish to
believe that if we were able to bring
those numbers into the street if we were
able to carry out sustained acts of mass
civil disobedience uh just because we
were non-violent we would free ourselves
from the draconian forums of the state
in some ways the state fears those mass
movements far more than it does anarchic
violence because that kind of violence
frightens the mainstream
and it gives the state a license to use
violence in return
and linda is in riverton new jersey
linda you're on book tv
thank you
hello chris and thank you very much for
all the work that you do i'm very
thankful for the truth
that you are able to get out there
i know recently you became an
ordained minister i saw the event online
and
i was just wondering personally how you
deal
with the realization
of all these things that are going
around on around us
um and
just sort of getting up in the morning
and
and spiritually how you can you speak to
that
on a personal and spiritual level
and i i would there's a lot of
spirituality and wages of rebellion as
well
well i come out of a faith tradition my
father was a minister i graduated from
harvard divinity school and i teach in a
prison in new jersey and half for many
years and was ordained to in essence
continue that prison ministry
because i think finally it is an issue
of faith and i say this to people of who
have religious creeds or have no creeds
uh it is the belief that
uh the good draws to it the good or at
least the good insofar as we can
determine it and then we have to let it
go faith is the belief that it goes
somewhere the buddhists call it karma
an act of faith standing up
in a sense that moral imperative a
revolt which for me is an act of faith
is finally not defined for what we can
achieve empirically things may be worse
by the end of our lives but more
importantly for who it allows us to
become as individuals
and i think that we're never going to
confront these terrifying forces
that stand before us
whether it's the fossil fuel industry
the security and surveillance state
unless we remain rooted in some kind of
a spiritual tradition
that sets us outside of ourselves that
is not tied to the
emotional highs and lows that define
american culture
that
that allow us to find validation
in the act of resistance itself
and not get too caught up in whether
it's effective or not i mean of course i
hope we are effective uh but even if
we're not uh i i don't think that that
should anyway diminish um the importance
of revolt reinhold niebuhr the great
theologian calls it sublime madness uh
and he said that in moments of extremity
liberalism is a spent an ineffectual
force uh it is that uh capacity which
you know he relates to the quality
religious mystics have uh which becomes
necessary in moments of extremity and i
would agree um a baldwin james baldwin
the great writer when he writes his
essay on the on how artists and rebels
share common characteristics said that
they're not they don't so much
strive towards a vision as as as
as much as they are possessed by it uh
and i think that's right and i spend a
lot of time in the book
talking about those issues because i
think um
i think they're fundamental if we're
gonna
uh rise up and do what we have to do
and cindy in evansville indiana we have
30 seconds left
hi chris
i just wanted to tell you that you're
doing a very good job
i
just i just appreciate it my husband
bought all your books so thank you i
appreciate it bye
i would just close by saying
um
you know i don't fight fascists because
i'm gonna win i fight fascists because
they're fascists
uh and that when we see what hannah
aaron and or emmanuel kahn would call a
radical evil forces that are seeking to
extinguish the systems of life
that are vital for the future of our
children
there is a moral imperative upon all of
us to rise up on their behalf and wages
of rebellion the moral imperative of
revolt is the book
chris hedges is the author thank you sir
thank you
our live coverage from new york
continues now all week we have been in
new york city we've been interviewing
different people and one of the people
we talked to
was adam bella he is the son of saul
bellow the author and but he's also an
editor and publisher at harpercollins he
has an imprint called broadside here's a
little bit of our conversation with adam
bennett
there was no presence of conservative
books uh in mainstream publishing there
was only
uh regnery which is a
a venerable uh publishing company but
really a sectarian uh outfit that is
outside and somewhat proudly so outside
stands outside the mainstream um
uh we at the free press that is myself
and irwin glickes who was the publisher
of the free press and my
my mentor in the business
were engaged in an effort to break down
barriers to conservative ideas and and
expression and it was an exciting uh and
consequential uh thing to do um
after some time after ten years or so uh
when we had enough success that the
large publishing companies woke up and
realized that there was a in fact a mass
market
a sizable market for conservative books
then
uh
special imprints began to be created uh
and there are now four
at this present count
dedicated conservative imprints at the
mainstream houses
and that was adam bellow we taped that
interview this week in new york city and
you'll be able to see that entire
interview
on
saturday june 6th
beginning at 7 30 p.m our live coverage
from new york our coverage from new york
will be shown that evening
well
all week long as i've said we've been in
new york city and book expo america has
been happening which is the publishers
convention
and one of the panels that we covered
was about diversity
in literature and diversity in the book
world here's the panel
book tv
uh
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen
columnist and syndicated editorial
cartoonist ted roll is an award-winning
graphic novelist and the author of
non-fiction books about domestic and
international current affairs his
political cartoons appear in
approximately 100 newspapers around the
united states and from 2008 to 2009 he
was president of the association of
american editorial cartoonists he has
won several awards for his work
including two robert f kennedy
journalism awards a scripps howard
national journalism award and best book
of the year award from the american
library association
joining him on stage tonight is chris
hedges chris has spent nearly two
decades as a foreign correspondent in
central america the middle east africa
and the balkans he has reported for more
than uh from more than 50 countries and
has worked for the christian science
monitor national public radio the dallas
morning news and the new york times
hedges was part of the team of reporters
at the times awarded a pulitzer prize in
2002 for the paper's coverage of global
terrorism he is also the author of
several best-selling books including war
is a force that gives us meaning and his
new book wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolt we're here tonight
to celebrate the release of ted's newest
book snowden without any further ado
please welcome ted rawl and chris hedges
[Applause]
hi so
thanks for coming everyone i'm ted
that's chris um i'm going to talk a
little bit about my book and then chris
will talk a little bit about whatever
he's going to talk about and
then we'll have a little discussion and
then uh we'll throw it out to the
audience for q a
so if you have any questions comments
insults please keep them and we will
absolutely field them uh and uh like the
government we will ignore your your
insults um
so um can you everyone hear me okay in
the back and everything okay so i'll
talk a little bit about the book uh we
don't really have the ability to do a
slideshow but my slideshow was just
going to be pages from the book so you
could just grab a copy of the book and
look at it
before you buy numerous copies of it uh
but i'll just go through the uh thinking
here um with me here oh closer okay okay
so
um i will i these mics are cleaned after
every appearance right um
so
um
so anyway um
this book was uh really not my idea like
all of my best ideas it was someone
else's uh my publisher uh seven stories
press uh dan simon who's here tonight
actually suggested that
oh
yes okay sorry
said that i uh suggested that i might
want to do a graphic novel biography of
edward snowden and um i was immediately
intrigued by the idea i was really into
it but
i was concerned that someone else would
do a biography in some format in prose
or otherwise and so um one of the things
that one of the one of the things i
wanted to do was to make the book
discreet and and and its own thing that
would be different from say a snowden
autobiography or a prose book but like
all books it's always the hardest thing
is format how do you get into
this topic how do you you know we know
edward snowden is a controversial and
fascinating figure and what he did has
uh evoked a lot of strong opinions on
all sides of the political spectrum but
the question is
for me was how do i get to you know
what's the book what is the book we know
there's a snowden book but what is it so
when i was asking people
uh about you know people were saying
well uh what's your next project uh as
they always do i said well i'm do
working on a graphic biography of edward
snowden and i was shocked by how many
people told me that they didn't know who
he was
including
very
people who are well read
people who you know who are who are very
aware of privacy issues
and
i was just amazed by that so i thought
that you know
how is it that we can live in a world
where in 2013 two years ago what to me
is the most important story of my
lifetime more important than 9 11.
how is it that that story has become
faded into obscurity and then the other
aspect was that among people who knew
who he was they were very vague on this
on the particulars a lot of people said
isn't he that russian spy
or uh isn't he
that guy who said something i mean
that's a quote literally i heard over
and over uh something about nsa or cia i
don't know they were doing something
wrong i don't know so i realized that
what he revealed had to be stated and
laid out in some kind of very
clear concise way that could be easily
digested by just about anybody
and so
i realized that part of the book was
going to have to be about laying out
these nsa programs that were revealed in
june of 19 of 2013 uh to the guardian
and the new york times in the washington
post and to lay them out and so because
the only program that has been discussed
in congress or by president obama in any
way has been the telephony metadata
program which is the nsa uh spying with
the cooperation of the telecoms like
verizon and att and sprint on the
information that's on your phone bill
that's telephony metadata so it's the
stuff what time you made a call where
the person was how long you talked to
them what their phone number was what
your phone number was that's it and you
can get a lot of information from that
you know if you're calling an oncologist
you might have cancer or someone close
to you might have cancer if you're
calling mother jones magazine to
complain about your subscription not
about your magazine not arriving you're
probably not a republican so you can
tell a lot about people from telephony
metadata and clusters of people and
subsets of clusters of people
and
there's been a lot of articles about
that but there hasn't but then there's
been a lot of misdirection purposefully
by the government and by the press
that's largely controlled by or
allied with the government so for
example they keep saying well you don't
have to worry about it because that
program
doesn't actually re
intercept the voice content of your call
and that's true they're telling the
truth about that because they have
another program that does that and then
the people who defend that program say
well you don't have to worry about that
program because it doesn't store the
calls it only intercepts the calls
and that's true totally true because
they have another program that stores
the calls for five years or longer uh
it's all stored on a data farm in utah
and to make it really frightening a lot
of these documents that snowden stole
are years old so you know the technology
has only improved uh since 2012 11 and
10 when those documents are dated so
probably the storage capacity is more
efficient the search abilities are
better no doubt and so
the um
so i need i knew that lastly the third
part of the of the
of the book beside telling his story
explaining the explaining what the
programs do
the third thing had to be about the
existential dilemma faced by this man
who was literally one in a million and
by one in a million i mean really two in
1.4 million because there are 1.4
million americans who had access to some
or all of the classified documents that
edward snowden took from the nsa cia and
booz allen hamilton
and
of those 1.4 million people who saw
brazen
violations of the fourth amendment here
i mean let's be clear on this no one on
the political spectrum says that these
programs are legal they're not legal
they say that they're defensible that
they are necessary they're expedient but
they don't see that they're
that they're legal because they're not
legal they're not authorized under the
patriot act they're not authorized
they're they're violent they're massive
violations of the fourth amendment's
protection against unreasonable a search
and seizure
so they are
there's no question about that and so
the the issue really is
why did all of these for me i wondered
about the kind of society that we live
in that over a million people could see
this law breaking on a mass scale
and only snowden and a guy named tom
drake who did the a similar thing but
tried to work within the system about 10
15 years ago
these two guys are the only ones who
have stepped forward in the last 15
years since not last 14 years since 9 11
at all to talk about these programs now
bear in mind also there have been
previous whistleblowers and the nsa's
effort to scoot up scoop up every bit of
information possible has been
something that has been that dates back
at least to the 1980s bearing in mind
also that the nsa's charter from 1947 is
only foreign signals intelligence and
what that means is nsa is allowed
legally under u.s law to spy on
foreigners they can spy on foreigners on
americans when they're talking to a
foreigner but they're not allowed to
talk to an american intercept american
talking to an american or emailing an
american or texting an american or
whatever and so they're doing this on a
mass scale and they started doing it on
a mass scale with a program called
echelon in the 1980s that was not widely
reported upon in the united states but
was well known in europe
and that program essentially made the
effort to intercept every fax
transmission telex bank wire transfer
all these communications at the time and
at the time general hayden who was the
head of the nsa bragged that the uh that
that the u.s did successfully intercept
every bit of communication in the united
states back in the 80s so we're not
talking about anything terribly new this
goes has gone back goes back a long way
it's just much more efficient now and i
opened the book
with
with the passages from the world
depicted by george orwell in 1984
and where people are followed by by
cameras as they move through the streets
uh telephone uh drones and planes and
helicopters track their movements and
most i think memorably is the telescreen
which is the tv that's on the wall in
your house and you can never turn it off
and you watch it but it watches you
whenever the government wants to they
can see what you're doing in your room
and they have it positioned in such a
way that there's almost no privacy
whatsoever in your room well the nsa has
literally this was the part that made me
open with 1984
the nsa has literally recreated this
with smart tvs and snowden has revealed
that the nsa can watch you through the
camera on your on your computer
or the camera on your smart tv
so if you have a smart tv they can watch
you um and so it's it's kind of insane
they can track you through the movements
through the streets just like they could
in 1984 that's how the boston police and
the authorities tracked the tsarnaev
brothers after the boston marathon
bombings and they were literally able to
sit in a control room and watch it now
there's a question about efficacy
you know in the end it was really a
nicotine addiction that caught uh mr
tsarniak because uh the city was on
lockdown and a guy hankering for a smoke
went out to his backyard and found mr
tsarniak in the back in the in hiding
out in his boat full of bullet holes so
uh if if we really need to encourage
smoking if we're really going to capture
terrorists um and probably save
trillions of dollars on the nsa because
there's literally no evidence whatsoever
that the nsa has ever successfully in
post-911 world intercepted a real
terrorist plot against the united states
of america no evidence whatsoever maybe
it's happened but nobody knows nobody on
the senate intelligence committee can
say it so anyway
we have this dystopian world and we have
this society that has been somehow so
morally corrupted and i think the moral
issue is really huge here it's a matter
of right and wrong when you see
law breaking occurring at your job to
say okay well
if i can't go through the system and as
snowden said the problem with the system
and the reason the system is broken is
because you have to report wrongdoing to
the very people who are most responsible
for it
if we if you're not willing to take that
to make that sacrifice as whistleblowers
like daniel ellsberg and chelsea manning
and several and and many others but not
nearly enough have done then there is
literally no ability whatsoever for this
system which is so off the rails in
terms of militarism and
being beholden to corporate interests
and so on and a broken electoral system
it is impossible there's no hope
whatsoever uh just like in 1984 the
world that george orwell portrayed when
i was a kid i'm 52 years old seemed like
a possible future but now it's our
absolute presence in fact that's our
past if we went to the world of 1984 it
would not be as dystopian as what we are
living in today and uh you know i think
i want to
leave time for chris to talk so we can
get to the discussion so that's a little
bit about snowden
[Applause]
thanks ted
this book
wages of rebellion begins from that
point uh from
the dystopia that ted described what
our greatest living political
philosopher sheldon wolin calls
inverted totalitarianism
and by that he means it's not
classical totalitarianism it doesn't
find its expression
through a demagogue or a charismatic
leader but through the anonymity of the
corporate state that in a classical
totalitarian regime you have a
fascist communist revolutionary
reactionary party that overthrows a
decaying structure and replaces it
in inverted totalitarianism you have
corporate forces that purport to pay
fealty to electoral politics
the iconography and language of american
patriotism the constitution and yet
internally have seized all of the levers
of power to render the citizen impotent
we have as the canadian philosopher john
ralston saw
as aptly pointed out undergone a
corporate coup d'etat in slow motion
and as ted explained it's over
and this book that i wrote is really how
does one resist how does one rebel
against this
dystopia
it especially given
the effects of climate change we just
saw through the la times this
massive investigative project that came
out today
showing that exxon mobil was well aware
their scientists were well aware of
climate change and global warming
decades ago
and yet
like the tobacco industry denied that
reality in the name of corporate profit
um i mean you know not only a criminal
offense but a fence that uh you know may
at this point given the extent of the
catastrophe may uh
mean the
extinction of the human species itself
um and so in this book i talk about the
emperor moral imperative of revolt which
of course snowden
exemplifies
and i argue that
given the
incredible power of the security and
surveillance state that is a raid
against us coupled with
militarized police forces coupled with
the evisceration of our civil liberties
finally we have to rise up
not
so much for what we can achieve but for
who it allows us to
become that we can't use the word hope
if we don't
resist and that means physical
resistance it means civil disobedience
sustained civil disobedience and it
means jail time
this is a passage from the book on
snowden i thought it was kind of apt
to go with the talk tonight and ted's
book
i have been to war
i have seen physical courage
but this courage is not moral courage
very few of even the bravest warriors
have moral courage
for moral courage means to defy the
crowd
to stand up as a solitary individual
to shun the intoxicating embrace of
comradeship
to be disobedient to authority
even at the risk of your life
for a higher principle
and with moral courage
comes persecution
the american army pilot hugh thompson
had moral courage
he landed his helicopter
between a platoon of u.s soldiers and 10
terrified vietnamese civilians
during the milai massacre
he ordered his gunner
to fire
his m-60 machine gun on the advancing
u.s soldiers
if they began to shoot
the villagers
and for this act of moral courage
thompson
like snowden
was hounded
and reviled
moral courage always looks like this
it is always defined by the state
as treason
the army attempted to cover up the
massacre and court martial
thompson
it is the courage to act
and to speak the truth
thompson had it
daniel ellsberg had it
martin luther king had it
and what those in authority once said
about them
they say today
about snowden
my country right or wrong
is the moral equivalent
of my mother
drunk or sober
g k chesterton
reminded us
so let me speak to you
about those drunk with power
to sweep up all
your email correspondence
your tweets
your web searches
your phone records
your file
transfers your live chats
your financial data
your medical data
your criminal and civil court records
and your movements
those who are awash in billions upon
billions of taxpayer dollars
those who have banks of sophisticated
computer systems
along with biosensors
scanners
face recognition technologies
and miniature drones
those who have obliterated your
anonymity
your privacy
and yes
your liberty
there is no free press
without the ability
of the reporters to protect the
confidentiality
of those who have the moral courage
to make public the abuse of power
those few individuals
inside government
who dared to speak out about the system
of mass surveillance have been charged
as spies
or hounded into exile
an omnipresent
surveillance state and i covered the
east german stasi state
creates a climate of paranoia
and fear
it makes democratic dissent
impossible
any state
that has the ability
to inflict full
spectrum
dominance on its citizens is not
a free state
it does not matter if it does not use
this capacity today
it will use it
history has shown
should it feel threatened
or seek greater control
the goal of wholesale surveillance as
hannah aaron wrote
is not in the end to discover crimes
but to be on hand when the government
decides to arrest a certain category
of the population
the relationship
between those who are constantly watched
and tracked
and those who watch and track them
is the relationship
between masters
and slaves
and those who wield this unchecked power
become
delusional
general keith alexander the former
director of the national security agency
hired a hollywood set designer
to turn his command center at fort meade
into a replica of the bridge
of the starship enterprise
so he could sit in the captain's chair
and pretend he was jean-luc picard
james clapper
the director of national intelligence
had the audacity to lie under oath
to congress
this spectacle was a rare glimpse
into the absurdist theater
that now characterizes american
political life
a congressional oversight committee
holds public hearings
it is lied to
it knows it is being lied to
and the person who lies knows the
committee members know he is lying
and the committee
to protect their security clearances say
and do nothing
these voyeurs listen
to everyone
and everything
they have bugged the conclave that
elected the new pope they bugged the
german chancellor
angela merkel
they bugged most of the leaders of
europe
they intercepted the talking points of
u.n secretary general ban ki moon ahead
of a meeting with president obama
now what
security threat was posed
by the conclave
of catholic cardinals
the german chancellor
and the un
secretary general
they bugged businesses like the
brazilian oil company petrobras
and american law firms engaged in trade
deals with indochina for shrimp and
clove cigarettes they carried out a
major eavesdropping effort focused on
the united nations climate change
conference in bali in 2007
they bugged their ex-lovers their wives
and their girlfriends
and the nsa stores our data
in perpetuity
i was a plaintiff before the supreme
court
in a case that challenged the
warrantless
wiretapping
a case
dismissed because the court believed the
government's assertion that our concern
about wholesale surveillance was in the
words of the government attorney's
speculation
we had the court said no standing no
right to bring the case
and we had no way to challenge this
assertion
which we now know to be a lie
until snowden
in the united states the fourth
amendment limits the state's ability to
search and seize to a specific place
time and event
approved by a magistrate
and it is impossible to square the
bluntness of the fourth amendment
with the arbitrary search and seizure of
all our personal communications
former vice president al gore said
correctly
that snowden
disclosed evidence of crimes
against the united states constitution
we who've been fighting
against mass surveillance
made no headway
by appealing to the traditional centers
of power
it was only after snowden methodically
leaked documents that disclosed crimes
committed by the state
the genuine public debate began
elected officials for the first time
promised reform
the private president who had previously
dismissed our questions about the extent
of state surveillance by insisting there
was strict congressional and judicial
oversight
appointed a panel to review intelligence
three judges
since the snowden revelations have ruled
on mass surveillance with two saying the
nsa spine was unconstitutional and the
third backing it
none of this would have happened none of
it
without snowden
snowden had access to the full roster of
everyone working at the nsa
he could have made public
the entire intelligence community
and undercover assets
worldwide
he could have exposed the locations of
every clandestine station
and their missions
he could have shut down the intelligence
system as he has said
in an
afternoon but this was never his
intention
he wanted only to halt the wholesale
surveillance which until he documented
it
was being carried out
without our
consent or our knowledge
politicians including the democratic
candidate hillary clinton
argue that snowden could have turned
internal mechanisms
have his grievances heard
but i can tell you from personal
experience that this argument
is as cogent
as the offer
made by the march hare
during the mad tea party in alice in
wonderland
have some wine the march hare said
in an encouraging tone
alice looked all round the table but
there was nothing on it
but tea
i don't see any wine she remarked
there isn't any said the march hair
[Applause]
okay so uh
how should we do this should we uh
jibber jabber or should we throw it out
to the audience in terrible jibber
jabber about what they have to say
i'll i'll let you lead it's your book uh
yeah okay so i think anyone any
questions
come on it's going to be all us
louder sorry what
no
okay
yes
your discussion of
moral heroes
and the distinction between what's legal
and what's moral
chris
i'm thinking about
gabe some examples
uh is socrates the
main
the main moral hero at the foundation of
the discussion
well i'm a great admirer of
the philosopher hannah aaron who writes
quite a bit about
the dilemma one faces when they are
confronted with what emmanuel kant calls
radical evil
and
when she finishes the university of
heidelberg she writes that she had to
unlearn everything she was taught
at university in order to become a moral
being
she herself joins although she was not a
zionist
an underground zionist group that
attempts to help german jews flee
to what was then the british mandate of
palestine
until she's picked up by the gestapo
almost killed
expelled from the country stripped of
her german citizenship and become
stateless
and
i think that the the
this system of what sheldon wolin calls
inverted totalitarianism
the corporate state
uh is one
uh where
we as citizens have lost not only our
voice
but our ability
to to make
you know our most basic rights
respected
we have example after example
of how
what it is that we as citizens
expect or desire
is irrelevant to corporate power
constituent calls in 2008
across the political spectrum were
against the bailouts in congress and yet
it passed anyway nobody wants wholesale
surveillance
i sued the president in federal court
over section 1021 of the national
defense authorization act
which overturns over 150 years of
domestic law
and permits the u.s military to carry
out in essence acts of extraordinary
rendition against u.s citizens on the
streets of american cities
we won in the southern district court of
new york and then the obama
administration appealed it
and and when these people are seized
under this section they're stripped of
due process and held indefinitely and
during that two-year legal battle
after we won and the appeal in the
second circuit uh an opinion poll went
out and uh that section of ten that
section 1021 of the nda
had a 97 disapproval rating
what we have seen is the courts have in
essence upended
our most important constitutional rights
by judicial fiat that's how you get this
absurd idea that unlimited corporate
cash is the right to petition the
government
or a form of free speech
um
and you know in this case the second
circuit desperately did not want to rule
on
uh as ted pointed out the issue of
privacy in my case
the use of military is domestic police
force and so what they did is
they denied my standing and the way they
did it was refer to the case that i
mentioned in my brief talk which was the
which did get to the supreme court
clapper versus amnesty international of
which i was a plaintiff challenging
warrantless wiretapping and surveillance
and they said well hedges doesn't have
standing as a plaintiff in clapper
versus amnesty international therefore
he doesn't have a standing in hedges
versus obama and they threw it out
we have seen it with activists
anti-fracking activists will tell you
they organize communities in oklahoma
pennsylvania
colorado
they educate those communities those
communities pass bans and then the
superstructure of the state bans the ban
whether it's the texas senate whether
it's the high courts in ohio so the the
government which is completely captive
to corporate power becomes a weapon
to criminalize and crush
a legitimate democratic dissent and
that's where we are we have of course
the wonderful
smoke and mirrors and bread and circus
and political vaudeville which is on
track to cost us seven billion dollars
and professional sports and i mean
there's all sorts of ways to
distract us um but um
you know the naked fist of the state
which ted referred to is becoming more
and more apparent especially for poor
people of color where
people are just being gunned down
unarmed people are being gunned down
daily in the streets and if they're not
being gunned down and terrorized in the
streets they're being locked in cages
and i will go back to erin she said that
when you create omnipotent policing when
you strip a segment of your population
of rights the way we have stripped
poor people of color of their rights
then rights become privileges
and once rights become privileges they
can be taken away from everyone you also
have created as aaron points out a legal
and a physical mechanism
by which should there
be unrest or should the wider population
become restive those tools can instantly
be applied to everyone else
it's almost like you know this
everything chris said is
absolutely true and mainstream
and and if you told me
even 20 years ago
that
if i'd heard someone saying these things
i would have thought they were a
crackpot a nut
and you know
but what you're saying is absolutely
true and
it's amazing to me how the system of
checks and balances turned out to be
nothing of the sort
in so so quickly i mean
you know i think you know there's
there's no one thing you can point to
but for me a great example was the 2000
the disputed florida election
you know it's like well the u.s supreme
court was never supposed to hear that
case because in the united states
elections are decided by the states so
when the florida state supreme court uh
ruled for a recount ordered a recount in
certain counties that was supposed to be
the last word and
the u.s supreme court even took pains in
bush v gore to point out that this was
not a precedent shouldn't be relied upon
in the future
uh and yet
nevertheless they stepped in they ruled
they installed bush who didn't win the
state of florida right that's the part
that's really would not have won if a
full recount had occurred and one can
obviously criticize al gore's strategy
of not asking for a statewide recount
which was foolish for statistical
reasons as well as uh for because you
would imagine there'd be a more a bigger
democratic under count in republican
counties than there would be in
democratic counties so i wonder how
gore's math skills are but i but i still
the thing that's still amazing to me is
he was installed and i remember when
that decision came through i lived on
morningside drive overlooking harlem and
i expected to hear glass start breaking
i expected to
hear people screaming in the streets i
expected
what would have happened in any
number of other countries around the
world in terms of unrest protests and so
on and nothing happened and i just
wonder is there something about the
american character
or is there something about the place we
are in as a society and with and and
stuck in this political structure or
have we all been propagandized as as as
through our schools and our and through
advertising and our popular culture to
not resist not react to act like we're
all
um just take it and keep going on i mean
the problem is that when they carry out
you know an egregious violation of norms
it's not immediately apparent what they
have done
um
there's a great book called define
hitler by sebastian hoffner he was a
lawyer in the law courts
in the early 30s when 1933 when the
nazis take power and he he sees how all
of the effort the party makes to subvert
the law and so that on the surface
things appear
as if
there's a continuity from what went
before when in fact there is a kind of
radical
legal change that becomes the
structure by which you impose a
totalitarian
system that was true even in stalinist
russia if you go back and look
uh you know at the early years up to the
20s
there was opposition there was a
dissident press yes the anarchists and
others were brutally repressed but it
takes time and there's a moment in
hofner's book where he describes the
fire in the reichstag which becomes the
excuse by the nazis to impose martial
law and the next morning everyone gets
up and goes to work and takes the kids
to school
and he said actually people there were
people who congregated i think he was in
leipzig
but he said the uh
social democrats were so frightened they
all fled to switzerland
in their cars
and he said people kind of said well
kind of what people say about trump well
at least you know they have the courage
of their convictions however repugnant
those convictions are so
so what we have seen is
a very similar kind of process and
corporate totalitarianism is a different
species from other forms of
totalitarianism but no less permissions
and in fact uh in terms of the
technological uh capacity to monitor and
control the government far more
frightening
than past systems and i covered the
stasi state in east germany so what
you're seeing and what you allude to is
that you're right that it was an
incredibly radical moment and let us
take a moment to defend ralph nader he
did not elect george bush
this became the way the democratic party
sought to demonize nader who terrified
them and who they had to destroy
because he actually represented the
interests of working men and women and
defied corporate power no one's been
fighting corporate power longer and
harder and better than ralph um but
you're right that that this this i mean
you're right to point that out as a kind
of seismic moment
but i think it's i mean we are certainly
you know
utterly illusioned we're probably the
most illusioned society on the planet um
and entranced by all of these kind of
electronic hallucinations that are now
in our handheld devices uh but i think
that the
the the crux of this issue is that when
this transformation takes place in any
totalitarian system it's largely
imperceptible
and then when it is perceptible it's too
late
yes
and then i wanted to kind of just touch
on what chris um said the last time he
spoke about you know his father and um
staying at the new york times or putting
your career would have been betraying
your father
and
i mean i've always studied the family
system like all my life because to me
that's kind of the root of so many of
our problems is that
we just don't have really good leaders
uh people to give
the young coming into this world
leverage and to stand up for what's
right
and i i mean i tried to bring this out
all my life and it was i was not popular
because i could see
the lack of fitness the lack of health
the lack of just like high standards and
standing up for what was right
i mean at such a young age and and i
was always trying to get people to reach
for more to stand up for more to try to
be more than just having a job and
you know paying your mortgage and having
kids
and
you know and i would always be pointing
out just the low standard that was set
that people just i mean like you had to
dig a hole in the floor they set the
standard solo and they would they would
make excuses
for if you pointed out something they
would make excuses you know going down
rather than up you know just kind of let
me let me just talk i mean what you're
what happened and we can go back and i
spent a book death of liberal class
talking about this process
you created a system of mass propaganda
through the creole commission or the
committee for public information in
world war one that destroyed our radical
and progressive movements and then
morphed into
uh
you know moved to madison avenue began
working on behalf of corporations
which through propaganda up up ended or
overturned traditional american values
of thrift self-effacement
hard work communitarianism and replaced
it with hedonism and the cult of the
self
um
profligate consumption uh and so what we
often
times today refer to as
and i think this gets to your point
where it refers to as american values
are in fact corporate imposed values i
mean the anxiety we feel over brands and
how to identify this is all instilled
and what's fascinating is that you read
bernays or lasswell or um you know
walter littmann and others they're quite
open about it
and that
sense of individual preoccupation
even to
the extent that it's infected
spirituality so the question is not in
the traditional religious sense how is
it with a stranger how is it with the
outcast how is it with the demonized how
is it with the other it's how is it with
me which is just a reflection of the
narcissism of the culture and that has i
think been a very disempowering and
pernicious force
i think this kind of brings us to like
one of the questions in in my book about
snowden um
i was
wondering why was snowden different why
was he willing to upend and maybe
possibly even sacrifice his life what
was it about his upbringing that uh that
or his background that brought him to
that point and and the bottom line is
there's nothing um he has you know his
parents are divorced so what half of
americans his age have divorced parents
he was in the boy scouts so was i i mean
he learned basic america traditional
american values of trustworthiness and
uh and honesty and obviously what he
witnessed at nsa and at booz allen
hamilton was dishonest and with the
american people um
there's
what to me was intriguing was that if
there's any one incident that really
turned him against uh the nsa and the
security state it was a very picayune
kind of moment
he was at the he was stationed at uh in
geneva at the u.s at the u.s embassy as
a cia guy undercover i.t
and he heard fellow cia agents he was at
the cia at the time
talking about how they'd flipped a swiss
banker whose records they wanted access
to
and the way they compromised him is they
they took him out got him drunk then
called up the local police and had him
arrested for drunk driving
and then showed up and miraculously
rescued him and they were laughing about
it because that compromised him to the
point where he was he had to turn over
the documents that he would he had the
secret banking documents that he was had
kept from the heretofore from the cia
and um and snowden thought it was
absolutely disgusting he thought it was
un-american he thought it was cheating
he thought it was underhanded and gross
and not the country that he wanted to be
from but it's really a very basic
example of it's a very standard bit of
spy craft not at all sophisticated i
mean if you read len dayton or frederick
forsyth the you've you've seen this and
more
you know this is no big deal so what is
it about snowden i mean you know i
interviewed thomas drake the other nsa
whistleblower who i uh talked about
talked about in washington
whose career was completely destroyed he
was an upper-level executive at nsa and
when he tried attempted to go through
the system reported his um
his concerns about not only privacy
violations but also
wasting of billions of dollars of
taxpayer money on inefficient programs
uh really it was corruption people were
benefit contractors that were connected
to these to the officials that were
approving these
programs were benefiting
these uh
he went to the inspector general he did
everything that you're supposed to do as
a whistleblower nevertheless they raided
his house they set out to destroy his
career they blackballed him they
destroyed his marriage he ended up and
now he's working in a uh at the genius
bar in an apple store outs in in in
maryland that's where he works and i
talked to him about this like well what
is it about you you know why you like
what about all your he said he kept
saying
well it was wrong what i saw was wrong
and i'm and i kept insisting yes but
what about your colleagues they all saw
the same stuff they didn't say anything
they didn't think it was wrong or if
they did think it was wrong they didn't
think it rose to the level of something
worth sacrificing or taking a risk over
and
they kept and he's just
he could
i realized that
after a while that he was just hard
wired this way it was just something
about him he couldn't put his finger on
it the closest he could get to was that
he came from he had been raised in
vermont which has a
spirit which has a local governance and
town meetings and
true you know local democracy and feels
like um you know very intimate and you
feel like you're participating in your
government much more so than perhaps in
other places but there was nothing you
know i mean these there's something
about
to me snowden is a role model
he's what i would aspire my i want my
son to be um you know someone who does
the right thing even when it hurts
that's the definition of integrity
it is and like when so you know i mean
where did we go wrong i mean chris's
work talks a lot about morality and in
this country morality is the providence
of the right in the political
debate it's always and what we're really
talking about is moralism not moral
morality moralism is you know where are
you sticking your genitalia um but the
but morals are about what's right and
what's wrong truly what is the bigger
issue versus the smaller issue like for
example edward snowden had to decide
which of his oaths he was going to
violate his oath to protect the
constitution or to protect classified
data from being revealed out to outside
sources he couldn't do both he had to
choose one and it was a
jean-paul sartre wrote in a notebook
foreign ethics but something i have like
bookmarked i always referred to it what
he defined as the quintessential
existential dilemma which is
i am handed a gun there is a gun to my
head and i and i am told shoot that
other guy or i will shoot you what is
the right choice sartre says of course
the right choice is to say
[ __ ] you and get shot and die
point being the right choice isn't
always any fun but it's still the right
choice well that's socrates
you know it's better to suffer wrong
than to do wrong
aaron
when she writes about those who stand up
to defy radical evil said it's not those
who say
you know we shouldn't do this or this
ought to be done it's those who say i
can't there's just something deep down
into the theologian reinhold nebras
calls it sublime madness
and
uh in this book i spent a lot of time
interviewing those who i believe are
endowed with sublime madness mumia abu
jamal
jeremy hammond
who hacked into stratford and released
five million emails including emails
that showed that the government and
private security firms were attempting
to link
non-violent occupy movements
with
al-qaeda
we used it in our trial
julian assange and others and and
you know one of the problems is that we
look back in history at these figures
these great resistance figures malcolm x
fannie lou hamer
sitting bull
uh
and you know we kind of
uh hold them up but we're unable to see
those figures within our own midst uh
because the state so and snowden would
certainly be one of them because the
state so effectively demonizes them
and makes us afraid to identify with
them and stand up for them
and that was that was true for all of
our great
resistance figures and
profits and and martyrs uh people forget
uh you know how hated a figure even
martin luther king was
uh
while he was alive
these are uh and and if you know history
is important but oftentimes i think we
we don't learn the lessons of history we
don't understand what it means to make
moral choice to take moral risk and and
and and the costs that always come with
taking moral risks because if there
aren't any costs it's probably not much
of a moral stance
it's uh
you know i mean
it's interesting to me about snowden you
know this is in the
this isn't history it's right now and
he's such a typical american guy you
know i mean he's you know he he he looks
ordinary he's he's you know he's white
he's a technocrat he started out as a
right winger he was a right-wing
libertarian voted for ron paul in 2008
donated money to ron paul
he's an american kid from south carolina
raised in crofton maryland um it's you
know i mean really it's
he's probably more relatable to the
average american and also the fact that
he's so young
29 years old when he did this i think
somehow you know it it somehow is
different from uh you know a rosa parks
or someone like that who's just you're
sort of like how could i be rosa parks i
don't think i can be rosa parks but i
think i could be edward snowden except i
would have never been hired by the nsa
to do something like that in fact when i
went to columbia and when they had a
jobs fair when i was uh 19 i went they
had a cia recruiting booth and i went
and talked to them because i had silly
fantasies about carrying microfiche in
the sole of my shoe and and having dead
drops in red square and i went to talk
to them and they said
they said yeah we're never gonna we're
never gonna hire you and i said why not
and they said well you you attended
socialist meetings on campus and i said
communist also
and he and they and so they say well we
only hire mormons from utah
which is why we do so well in the
intelligence community
any other questions
yes uh let me let me let me get someone
who hasn't
sorry
because i got several questions one is
that
this unauthorized illegal government
surveillance a little louder
the content of the
phone conversations that they do they do
record and they're
the phone calls
they get stored in some kind of a data
form
someplace yes it's stored in a data farm
in bluffdale utah which has been it's
massive and it's being expanded all the
time and it's been
built with uh hundreds of billions of
dollars of your tax dollars
now could government use this data
to use against individuals in the court
of law
well they
i mean chris alluded to this earlier i
mean the the thing is the vast majority
of this data as things stand will never
be looked at um it's
99.9999 of it sits on those servers and
what's happened is that
as chris alert alluded to earlier uh in
the past you needed in his reading he
said you know you need whenever someone
fell under suspicion of wrongdoing
they could be searched or tracked or or
followed but that you needed a warrant
from a judge from a magistrate uh and
that no long and since
in recent i would say since 9 11 in
particular but before that too but
certainly after 9 11
the new paradigm has been as the nsa
says they want to collect everything so
what they do is they collect every bit
every communication they store them and
then they search at their leisure
for clusters for patterns and yes for
individuals so
the question is you know even if you
believe right now that president obama
is the bestest president we will ever
have and that our government is the
bestest government we will ever have uh
just like candide and you believe in it
this the fact is presidents change
regimes change do you want will
president donald trump or president ted
cruz behave differently and use that
information differently possibly and um
you know i like to tell the story about
when i became a french citizen i'm born
in the united states but my mother's
french and uh when i was 18 it was it
was 1981 and reagan had just become
president so and there was a lot of talk
that there might be a war and a draft so
i did the patriotic thing and i ran up
to 5th avenue and 74th street and got in
line and declared my french citizenship
and there was a line around the block of
guys about 18 19 years old singing the
marseilles waiting to get in and
the um and so when i finally got my
citizenship papers i got an id card a
passport and uh and then they handed me
a birth certificate and on the birth
certificate it said birthplace palpinia
and i was like pelpina i'm born in
cambridge massachusetts and uh he's like
there's a mistake no no no no you're
born in pel pina and they explained to
me that during world at the beginning of
world war ii uh
when the vichy authorities and then the
nazi authorities the gestapo and so on
when they invaded france they captured
all the census and police data records
uh all the posts that were mostly kept
on postcards and filing cards that
showed religious identification and
whether someone was born overseas or not
and when it came time to deport they
deported jews first and state and people
who were born overseas first
to the camps so at the end of the war
the french government passed a new law
that stated that they would no longer
maintain those records so the french
government just does not know exactly
how many say uh arabs there are in
france they have an they have a
guesstimate but they don't have they
don't have a list of them
there's no way to get it and for example
they don't know how many people were
born outside of france because they
destroyed those records so uh in in
every file supposedly i don't know if
this is really true but supposedly in in
french archives i'm listed as being from
people so um a few years ago i was in
paris driving the wrong way uh against
six lanes of traffic on the
champs-elysees when a cop pulled me over
with his cute little kp and uh and he's
like you know what the [ __ ] are you
doing and i said
and i sho so i'm like ha
and i showed him my passport and he ran
he ran my information and he's like
and he's like vramo and i'm like we
he's like i mean pelpina is like the
mississippi of france okay i mean it's
like it's on the spanish border it has a
really strange accent there's like no
way could anyone who learned english in
the united states have a palpinion
accent it's impossible but he just kept
insisting and i was like we and there's
nothing he could do about it and i was
like bye
and he was just like
so um so the point is that that in that
there's some information that shouldn't
be in anyone's hands uh i personally am
an awesome moral person but if i had
this information there's a bunch of
people who i'd really screw over if i
could get into those files it's more
that when a society breaks down the
reason
all totalitarian systems keep files on
all of their citizens is that the moment
the power structure the power elite
feels threatened they have the capacity
to pull up those files and criminalize
entire groups of people
it based on utterly innocuous data but
data that they interpret in such a way
as to
tar that individual with
criminal or terroristic
activity
that's why totalitarian states collect
data on everyone that's why the stasi
state did it that's why stalin did it
that's why the fascists did it
and we have now handed that tool it's
not really a matter i think necessarily
of individuals it is about this
corporate cabal that has seized power
and
that growing awareness on the part of
the wider public that everything they've
been told about globalization and
neoliberalism is a lie
it is
seen wealth sucked upwards into the
hands of a rapacious predatory elite
it has not furthered democracy it has in
fact obliterated democracy uh it has uh
savaged the environment uh it is and so
as that reality is understood and i
think we're seeing in this election
manifested in this election
as the state you know loses its
credibility then it will increasingly as
it is resort to harsher more naked forms
of oppression that orwell
outlined in
1984 and remember we got two great
dystopian thinkers huxley and orwell but
we got huxley first
we got you know access to cheap
mass-produced goods and spectacle and
entertainment and uh
uh easy credit pharmaceuticals and
pharmaceuticals and now it's gone
and the pharmaceuticals are still there
but but everything else is and and and
as
uh you know those forms of control are
less officious
then we get
the more naked forms and and more brutal
and violent forms of control of which
the security and surveillance state is
uh
you know
kind of first and foremost among that
system
they're asked whether i have a website i
do not have a website i do not tweet i
don't have a facebook page and i don't
own a television
i don't have anything i have a phone and
i have 5 000 books in my house
anyone else
okay yes that'll be the last one
well you can ask secretary of state
clinton she's asking just to repeat the
question why snowden is still living in
russia because they revoked his us
passport and he couldn't get to ecuador
well here's the here's the situation she
asked if there's another place it's
actually one of the things that's in the
book that that corrects
um some of the misreporting that that
has occurred about this issue so
um the u.s government asserted
falsely that the chinese allowed snowden
to leave on an invalid passport in order
to poke poke the eye of the u.s
government but that's false that didn't
happen uh when he boarded his plane in
hong kong he had he had a valid passport
but if you have a passport you ever
notice there's the new ones have a
little chip logo on the front because
there's a microchip inside and you might
foolishly think that that's for your
convenience to allow you to zip through
jfk in a jiffy but really this is a tool
of state control to do exactly what then
secretary of state hillary clinton did
who in my view uh this disqualified this
action disqualifies her from uh the
presidency as much as her vote to invade
iraq
she
she said uh i mean she turned off his
passport while he was in the air to um
to moscow he was only supposed to change
planes in moscow and when he appeared at
chairmativo ii he went to the transit
desk he was supposed to continue onward
to havana cuba but they told him there
was that he couldn't board because he
didn't have a pass a valid passport
anymore uh which is kind of if you think
about it kind of insane that the u.s gov
the state department can just flip a
switch and turn you off like that and by
the way just parenthetically from a
national security point of view let's
just assume that they didn't know
whether snowden still had those
documents with him so you're going to
strand him in russia of all places
pretty stupid so i mean you know he the
fsb could have just like taken that
stuff off him there's nothing that
anyone could have done about it so it
was a really boneheaded move on some and
completely immoral um in so many ways
but he was supposed to he had been
invited to go to ecuador um and he would
have been able to i think that that
option is no longer on the table the
problem is that
you know it's just geography he's in
russia right so how does he get to
another country that would host him
without passing over airspace that's
either controlled directly or indirectly
by the united states
you know just i don't know if you recall
this episode but the president of
ecuador was visiting moscow on at a
trade function uh a trade meeting and uh
and then there was a rumor that the u.s
got that snowden was aboard his plane
and the austrians forced him to the
bolivian president the bolivian
president sorry the bolivian president
and then the austrians forced the
bolivian president to land and you know
he was really angry and there was some
apparently some risk to his life in this
in this uh in this action so risking the
life of a head of a foreign head of
state to try to capture
what a guy who obama characterized as a
29 year old hacker
is uh is kind of really over the top but
that's what would happen to snowden if
he got on a plane he can't get anywhere
he can only go to
countries that border russia and hope
for the best so i mean you know
you could go to kazakhstan i guess
could you talk a little bit about um
what you think are the weak points or
weak points in the culture of
acquiescence that we're living in
like
of american culture
sure
well that's another program
um
what's happening in the united states
reminds me of what happened in
yugoslavia which i covered as a foreign
correspondent
where
in essence you have political paralysis
the inability on the part of the state
to respond
and that political paralysis is carried
out by a self-identified liberal elite
it's not really a liberal elite figures
like clinton you know did as much damage
to working men and women in this country
as ronald reagan
uh obama has only carried on that
trajectory
but what happens and i think we're
seeing it within these elections
is that
when people rise up with a legitimate
frustration and anger and despair and
hopelessness
is that they turn not only on the
self-identified liberal elite which has
been ineffectual which has served this
cabal in this case of corporate
oligarchs but they turn on liberal
values themselves
and that's why we have such powerful
proto-fascist movements in the united
states whether they're christo fascists
whether they're nativists whether
they're tea party
you know militias
and they've always been
part of the virus of american society
going all the way back to the slave
patrols the pinkertons the baldwin felts
the clan
but what happens is that you
direct that rage towards the vulnerable
towards muslims undocumented workers
african-americans
liberals feminists intellectuals and
that we are watching you see it in trump
rallies and what we're that is just part
of the
physical and moral disintegration of the
society
um the use of wholesale violence i mean
we live in a city where one of our
fellow citizens was choked to death
unarmed never committed a crime choked
to death and killed on a city sidewalk
and none of the police went to jail
the
the danger of that is that the you know
the very kind of nihilistic violence
that we're seeing right now between
palestine and israel where the
palestinians have just been so crushed
that they're kind of lashing out with
this incohe but understandable fury and
to understand is not to condone but
understandable is is
is also happening in the united states
we've had 26 or 27
assassinations
of law enforcement officials including
two in new york city this year now these
are not confrontations these are
assassinations
i hope this is not a pattern
but i think that there's so much
evidence now that the society has seized
up
that the society really isn't
functioning at all i mean we watch the
arms industry hollow the nation out from
the inside officially 54 percent of
discretionary spending in fact
that doesn't count veterans affairs it
doesn't account for the nuclear weapons
program it doesn't account for all the
black budgets like these intelligence
streams that we're not allowed to see by
best estimates we're spending 1.6 1.7
trillion dollars a year on endless
feudal wars which we've lost
in countries like iraq and afghanistan
the taliban controls more of afghanistan
than they did when we invaded 14 years
ago
but of course for you know a small
corporate cabal
northrop grumman and general dynamics
it's great it's money it's profit war is
a business and um and and and so
you know we are as american citizens
being tasked or forced through austerity
the collapse of our infrastructure
repressive measures i mean you drive
through one american former industrial
city after another it's a wasteland
it's being taken out on us
and that's how empires you know all go
down we're no exception joseph taner in
the collapse of complex societies
chronicled how you know all of the
characteristics that empires die
um and and and
unfortunately
um
you know that
pathology of death
is one that
you know unleashes some very dark
spectral
forces america is a very violent society
unlike canada for instance we're a very
very violent culture
um so
uh i mean the you know the end of
literacy the rise of spectacle the you
know the way verifiable fact now long
especially on the airwaves it no longer
matters it's all you know it's you know
whatever however you're made to feel
that's kind of what fox news is about um
you know there's just so many signs so
the final sign being that the harsh
forms of control that empire uses on the
outer reaches of empire drones
militarized police wholesale
surveillance
have now migrated back to the heart of
empire so a night raid in east new york
looks no different from a night raid in
fallujah long-barrelled weapons kevlar
vests
um and and that's not accidental
thucydides got it he said what destroyed
athenian democracy is that the tyranny
athens imposed on others that finally
imposed on itself thank you very much
and uh just thank you everyone for
coming tonight the only thing i'd like
to add to that is that
i'd like to answer that question
nothing's really settled in american
politics and i feel like that's a
uniquely american thing um you know it's
in uh in other countries if there's a
dispute over
an issue um there's a battle and then
eventually one side prevails and then
it's over and mostly yes the losing side
goes home licks its wounds and is sad
but it's over but the united states i
mean the south doesn't admit that they
were wrong during the civil war we ne
they were never despite sherman's march
they were not crushed there that this
resistance is not gone the confederate
battle battle flag still flies above
state capitals they never got over it um
and if you just look at all these like
battles it's so hard for liberalism or
progressivism to triumph even when it
does triumph even when it has the
support of an overwhelming
majority of americans um there's still
the losers don't admit they've lost and
the winners don't make them admit that
they've lost so nothing ever gets
settled it's like we never move forward
i i find it just i mean as a political
commentator i find it just baffling
we're always i mean if i could we could
live a thousand years and assuming this
society would last that long which it
won't um it's like there's you know we
could be having the same stupid
arguments over the same [ __ ] forever and
ever
but anyway
thanks everyone for coming uh of course
chris and i will be happy to sign your
numerous copies of your of of your book
our books that you're buying and uh if
you don't buy our books which in which
case are foolish at least by a book
thanks for coming
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen for
coming we ask that you please remain
seated for just one moment while we make
the stage ready for you if you have a
book to get signed
if you haven't purchased the book yet we
do still have them both available back
at the registers towards the back of the
store thank you
[Music]
did you kill money
this is book tv on c-span 2 television
for serious life of robert f kennedy
that all happens tonight on c-span 2's
book tv
good evening
can you hear me
good good all the way in the back
probably okay all right
we can all be seated
now we got a few stragglers coming in
that's all right
so my name is stefan boatride i am a
representative of the left forum board
it is my job to welcome you to left
forum 2016.
[Music]
thank you all for coming
you're sure that this is going to be a
wonderful forum
i attended my first forum in 2010 just
like many of you as a spectator it was a
really amazing forum i saw dr cornel
west almost
blow the podium into the audience when
he was so animated
i knew that it was something i wanted to
be a part of from that very moment so
and during 2011 when i started my
doctorate i joined up with the forum
back then we were talking about occupy
wall street 2016 we are talking about a
democratic socialist gaining millions of
votes throughout the country
times are definitely changing
one thing that's definitely changed and
maybe not for the better is that prices
in new york city continue to ravage the
working and middle classes and
unfortunately the left forum as well
so back in 2011 when i was an intern uh
we were completely unpaid when people
asked me what my compensation was
i said an infinite supply of pretzels
twizzlers and marx's good vibes
that unfortunately is still the
condition that we are in today
so all of you have been uh given some
different
envelopes on your seats
uh and that is us asking you to open
your hearts your minds and of course
your wallets to contribute to the form
now we know that fundraising is very
difficult you need to be innovative you
need to be creative
i unfortunately for you all and neither
of those things
so i'm going to blatantly rip off a very
successful grassroots campaign
fundraising scheme in the nation right
now it goes like this
the left forum does not accept
contributions from millionaires and
billionaires
we have no super pac
we are relying upon millions and when i
say millions i mean dozens of campaign
contributions from folks just like you
and in all sincerity those contributions
go to wonderful things i'm going to
share a little bit of left forum gossip
with you
i'm a very good source for less left
forum gossip
because of the growing influence of the
forum
we have been approached from activists
and leaders from across the nation
asking us if they can do forms in their
city
so we are now sincerely talking about
extending the left forum outside of just
new york in addition to the conference
we have here to other east coast cities
in fact
there's even the conversation
of bringing left forum all the way to
california's golden coast
so we consider these things great
successes but of course we can only do
them
depending on the
contributions from all of you folks
but enough about money it's just too
capitalist for me
so i want to kick this off with a little
bit of fun and that is going to start
with slam poet matt sedillo he is a
revolutionary poet from los angeles
california
he has been featured in the la times
uh he was
on and kpfr radio please matadio
[Applause]
so a rage rebellion revolution right
that's the theme
here we go
it's for you roxanne
sundown levittown port apache dirty
harry john wayne blackface minuteman
moynihan gone with the wind breaking bad
washington [ __ ] confederate flag the
sword the dollar the cannon the scholar
the cavalry in the ivy league history is
written by lightning is the rising smoke
of burning village
the ways and means victors keep their
victims of frontier thesis and notes on
the state of virginia extraction
expansion in the winnie the west lewis
and clark smith and weston has circled
the wagon with bloodshed and slaves
sweat the crack of the whip the law of
three fifths the crown republic of king
cotton the intended failures of
reconstruction the housing covenants
that create a great migration that seems
the mexicans of port mexico
so far from heaven and so close to
monroe doctrine
to davy crockett
to prison industrial complex a war on
drugs is a war on a young bloody
christmas
reefer madness
15 to life four ounces east oakland west
baltimore south of brain all over north
plymouth rock
jamestown
and the rio grande
stolen lives
stolen land
here's a nation
package complete
police escort skinheads
and hooded clansmen
too much hate
down public streets
those very same police
quotas to me
cannon fire
on black boys and hoodies
and mexican kids with shaped heads
they are killing our kids
well half the nation applauds in the
homeland's defense
because they think
they think
that a white woman's purse
has more value
than a black or brown boy's life
here's a nation
hellbent
one percent
genocide pipeline from underfunded
schools to overcrowded prisons the new
king which our kids ain't fit for
nothing but a life in and out of the
system script of innocence guilt by
birth certificate students quotas before
children children suspects before
students young girls
[ __ ]
before victims
here is a nation
that eats its young
this is not a democracy
this is not a republic this is an open
air prison
an industrial scale plantation anything
and everything you've ever gotten from
this system has a mathematical
assessment a calculated equation set to
the algorithm the cost of doing business
keep your hands moving stomach consuming
mind functioning with narrow confines or
job description blood soaked country
forged in genocide built on slavery by
den of thieves posing's messiah the
constitution thomas jefferson jefferson
davis white jesus western civilization
civilizing mission mission accomplished
manifest destiny american exceptionalism
peculiar institutionalized race and
declaration to plantation anthem the
slave shift the bicentennial your back
to the slave with the feet allay liberty
the dirt poor dead tired whole child
lived in poverty of ellis islands
arizona's blood red coyote trails at
traffic in brown flesh brick by brick
grave by grave inch by inch slave by
slave here is a nation there or its
chains keep you in place watch tower
overseer ancient killer union bust
because the islam patron act acting in
next of
national defense which of you would
stand against it which hunts for was a
blown who said that who did that which
side are you on here is the firing squad
that killed men of comets because it
comes up they killed rihanna they killed
john brown they killed that turner they
killed the rosenbergs they killed soccer
and then zeddy malcolm x and martin
luther king deal with salazar they
killed fred hampton they're going to
kill in much the same fashion here or
the blood soaked fields within the life
of eddie lopez brazilian flores susie
pena mike brown with marshall harland's
trayvon martin have the nation applauded
here is that nation this is not a
democracy this is not a republic this is
the states of the union they are killing
our children we
are war this is a call
that's the deal everyone that's the deal
thank you matt
of course the left forum would not be
able to be here today if it wasn't for
the good folks lobbying on our behalf at
john jay so everyone we were going to
bring up uh gerald markowitz is a
distinguished professor of history at
john jay college of criminal justice
he received his doctorate in from the
department of history from the
university of wisconsin has been
teaching at john jay since 1970 he has
written extensively about the ways
corporations have undermined the
environment and the health of both
workers and our communities gerald
markovitz everyone
well it is a great pleasure for me to
welcome you on behalf of the students
the faculty the staff and even the
administration of john jay college of
criminal justice
and of course you know we are part of
the great city university of new york
and
yes
who is here from the city university
alumni
students faculty yes way to go way to go
and you know
and all of you know
that we are in the midst of a
war against public higher education
this is a war that we are engaged in we
are fighting back against
and we are winning some of the battles
but the war goes on
and we have to
really emphasize
that when the state does not fund public
higher education this is not a
economic decision
this is a political decision
that is reflecting on our students
and they are making this political
decision because our students are
predominantly
students of color
students of the working class
students who are immigrants or children
of immigrants
and we are in the midst of a tremendous
fight back against that
part of that fight back
has been successful
the students and the
professional staff congress our union
was successful in stopping any tuition
increase this year by the state
legislature a great victory
[Applause]
but the faculty and staff have been
working without a contract
for six years now
working without a raise for six years
and this just this past week
the union had a vote of its membership
for whether we should authorize a strike
to be called by the union leadership
and i am proud to announce
that 92 percent of those who voted voted
for a strike authorization
[Applause]
but we need your help we need your
solidarity
we need you to join us in this defense
of prior
public higher education
thank you very much
thank you so much professor markowitz
last but not least your host for the
evening a woman who needs practically no
introduction miss laura flanders is the
executive producer and host of the laura
flanders show she was the founder and
host of grit tv with laura flanders her
books include bush women tales of a
cynical species and blue grit true
democrats take back politics from the
politicians she's also available on
podcasts please give a warm welcome to
miss laura flanders
thank you
let's hear it for all the organizers and
participants of left forum 2016 that's
you
[Applause]
we're here to take on one particular
part of the conversation um at the left
forum this weekend capitalism and
militarism at humanities peril
now i would say when we have a former
nobel peace prize winner barack obama
awarding a distinguished public service
award to henry kissinger
our humanity is more than at peril and
it tells you a thing or two about the
nobel prize
um
but there's other news to discuss as
well we have the first muslim
mayor elected in london
we have um 2.4 million people
contributing to the bernie sanders
campaign
a man who has not foresworn the use of
drones
we have donald trump proving that in
case anyone wondered white supremacy
white male patriarchal supremacy is
alive and well and deadly
and we have an election on our hands
while we try to build a movement that
will move beyond
this
electoral morass
i don't need to tell you that capitalism
today is characterized by massive and
increasing inequality in case you forgot
oxfam earlier this year reported that 62
people
own the same wealth as half of the world
that's 3.6 billion with a b people
and only 9 of those 62 are women
wealth and power accumulates at one pole
while misery austerity and ecological
degradation cluster and explode at the
other
having exploited native land and
enslaved people
now it seems to be war and empire that
are keeping capitalism on life support
and thank you for the poem entry uh uh
beginning
we see it in the us and the rise of
racism and fear and the way local police
forces are armed with surplus military
weapons
in the use of public funds to procure
mercenary corporate security forces and
enlist working-class people to fight
each other
goaded on here and internationally by
divide and conquer surveillance
techniques and inflammatory rhetoric of
white supremacy
on my program the laura flanders show
which you can see on telesur english or
telesur or just tune into our podcast at
lauraflanders.com people regularly
reflect about
where we've come to
most recently jeremy scahill no stranger
to all of you
considering the legacy of plowshares
peace activists
phil and dan berrigan recalled that our
movements
have become increasingly
separated
racial justice from economic justice
war and peace from wages and migration
dreams
from the time skyhill recalled when
black power activist oakley carmichael
called phil berrigan the most dangerous
white man alive
we've come a long way
how are we now to
understand the connections and i think
that's the
the challenge of this evening's plenary
is trying to understand the connections
between for example extreme policing
and mass incarceration
and extreme
pilfering and profiteering
and resource extraction
most importantly we're going to talk
about where the cracks are in this
system
what peace movements what peace and
justice movements are developing and how
they are tackling empire what kinds of
leverage both in and beyond the
military-industrial complex the workers
and others actually have to disrupt the
onslaught of militarization
and where is this leverage being used to
build alternatives
on my show every week we look not just
at what's going wrong but what is going
right
we call it the show the place where the
people who say it can't be done take a
back seat to the people who are doing it
so i i can tell you
that we're going to hear from three
people who we have pretty often on the
program and i know that they are not
just
perfect when it comes to talking about
the onslaught that we're up against but
also when it comes to talking about the
opportunities
and how and where people are grabbing
them we're going to get um substantive
meaty
presentations by each of our speakers
and then have a little conversation
amongst ourselves and then release us
all to engage one another in one-on-one
conversation or cluster in groups if you
prefer
um our first speaker today is going to
be
chris hedges he's a pulitzer
prize-winning journalist and author most
recently of wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolt
he was a national book critic circle
finalist for his book war is a force
that gives us meaning he's taught at
columbia nyu princeton the university of
toronto he's teaching courses through
rutgers university to prisoners at a
correctional facility in new jersey and
he is about to launch a new television
show on russia today
chris hedges
wait wait
i'm going to introduce everybody i just
wanted them to applaud you
media benjamin is the co-founder of the
women-led peace group code pink and the
co-founder of the human rights
organization global exchange she's the
author of eight books including drone
warfare killing by remote control and
our articles appear regularly in outlets
such as the huffington post common
dreams alternate the other worlds and
telesur her fourth coming book is on
saudi arabia media benjamin
[Applause]
and finally tariq ali my colleague at
telesur where he hosts a weekly program
you can find out more at
telesawenglish.tv.net he was born and
raised in lahore he came of age in
london as an opponent of the vietnam war
today he is editorial director of the
london publishing house verso and on the
board of the new left review where he's
also an editor he's the author of too
many books to mention fiction
non-fiction and essays the most recent
of those last is the extreme center
a warning
let's start with chris chris hedges
thank you very much
so when i came in i was handed
a broadsheet that
pulled a quote a half of a quote that i
made
and so since i want to talk about the
nature of power
during this
electoral campaign i will finish the
quote i did indeed say it is not our job
to take power
but it didn't end there
it is our job to make the powerful
frightened of us
that is what movements do
movements keep power in check
and
as any good anarchists will tell you
power is always the problem no matter
who holds it
this is a realization that karl popper
made in the open society and its enemies
where he wrote
that it is not the job to get good
people to rule
that popper says is the wrong
question how do we get good people to
rule rather
it is to create a system
where those in power are frightened of
us
yes we certainly want to push forward
into power
those who will listen
but without those movements
without the power of movements to keep
the powerful in check
all power becomes despotic
and this was an understanding that julia
bender had in his great book the treason
of the intellectuals where he said that
all of us who care to create a society
based on justice
a society that
takes care of the vulnerable and the
weak among us that express his
compassion
are given a choice between choosing
uh two sets
of ideals
privilege and power
or justice and truth but as bender
writes the more we make concessions to
those who serve privilege and power
the more we diminish the capacity for
justice and truth we just finished a
session uh on
rosa luxembourg
who i think of all revolutionary
theorists probably understood this
the best
it is important that we rebuild these
movements now movements that have been
destroyed
consciously in the name of
anti-communism uh especially at this
crisis moment
within the american political and
economic system where we are teetering
on the brink of a very frightening form
of proto-fascism
one of the
mistakes
that bernie sanders made
a mistake that shamasawan
and i called him out on before he
announced his campaign
was the decision to run
within the embrace of the democratic
party
and we are now watching bernie sanders
supporters
and i think
arguably sanders himself
confront the fact that this has been a
rigged system
that when you have a system let's not
forget by the way that uh the cost of
running the primaries is paid for by the
taxpayer
and yet the primary rules are determined
by the democratic party
so that they can manipulate a system as
they did in nevada to steal the vote
from sanders they lock out independence
this is why in that last cycle
sanders only won rhode island that was
the only state in which independents
were allowed to vote
you have a system of super delegates you
have money from super pacs it's very
clear
that without all of these mechanisms
sanders would win the nomination
and yet through this long process we
have
been given palpable evidence
that democracy within the united states
is a facade
and we are about to enter an electoral
process with
two
presidential candidates who have
the highest negativity ratings in
american history donald trump being
number one and hillary clinton being
number two
and those of us who care about
recovering agency within our country
overthrowing the corporate coup d'etat
that has taken place and just for
homeland security uh who might be here
tonight let me repeat that word that's
called overthrow
we are going to have to step outside
that system
and build movements
that resist we are going to have to free
ourselves from the insidious
mantra of the least worst
because it doesn't work every election
cycle we're fed the mantra of the least
worst and it gets worse
because our two-party duopoly why it has
a different rhetoric
serves the same centers of power and
that is why on all of the major
structural issues there has been
complete continuity between george w
bush and barack obama with
the caveat that barack obama's assault
on civil liberties has been worse
and i speak as a plaintiff
in a lawsuit
that i brought against the president
over section 1021
of the national defense authorization
act
this is a provision
that overturns the 1878 posse comitatus
act that prohibits the military from
carrying out carrying out domestic
policing
and much to the chagrin of the obama
administration
we won in the southern district court of
new york
and judge catherine b forrest
[Applause]
in a very lucid opinion
explaining her ruling
112 pages
said
that what this act does is empower the
government to criminalize an entire
category of people
and detain them without due process
and she brought up the plight of the
hundred and ten thousand japanese
americans who were detained in world war
two
because this section
authorizes
the us military on the streets of our
cities to carry out extraordinary
rendition against u.s citizens
deny them due process if the state deems
them to be a terrorist
and holds them indefinitely
in our black sites including our
offshore penal colonies
and
the two-year legal process the obama
administration immediately appealed
now they immediately appealed the day of
the ruling they went into judge
forrest's chambers
and they demanded that she lift her
temporary injunction in the name of
national security and when the federal
attorneys came in they now came in with
attorneys from the nsa
and judge forrest to her credit refused
that was on a friday afternoon at 9 00
a.m they were in the second circuit or
the appellate court of new york
demanding the same thing unfortunately
the second circuit agreed why
the lawyers bruce afron and carl mayer
and i wondered why why we knew they'd
appeal but why were they so aggressive
and the only thing that we could surmise
is because it's already they are already
using the law there are already dual
nationals pakistani u.s nationals being
held in black sites
and if they could get out and if they
could get legal representation
the government would be held in contempt
of court
and what was the response the second
circle it's a panel of judges they
review the case they wouldn't rule they
wouldn't rule they wouldn't rule for
months
and during that time the lawyers went to
nancy pelosi and they said because this
provision is renewed every year all you
have to do is insert into the provision
that u s citizens are exempt
and of course they did not because it
was written for u s citizens
and so what does the second circuit do
it doesn't want to rule on the merits of
the case because it's patently
unconstitutional in the way that our
evisceration of privacy is
unconstitutional
and
it essentially was another example of
how the courts have become wholly owned
subsidiaries of the corporate state and
revoked constitutional rights by
judicial fiat
what they did was wait
for a supreme court ruling called
clapper versus amnesty international
and that i was a plaintiff in that
ruling this was challenging the
government's wholesale surveillance
before the snowden revelations
and the federal attorneys got up the
government attorneys got up in the
supreme court and said that i and the
other plaintiffs did not have a right to
bring the case
because
the idea that the government was
watching us was speculation
and they added if the government was
watching us they would tell us
so the supreme court buying this
argument threw it out and then the
second circuit said well hedges doesn't
have standing in clapper versus amnesty
international therefore he doesn't have
standing in hedges versus obama our cert
our petition of the supreme court was
turned down in its law this is all under
obama
it's obama that's used the espionage act
to destroy
whistleblowers who once sought out
independent journalists to expose
corruption malfeasance and crimes
against government
and here we must honor two of our
greatest whistleblowers
manning and julian assange
[Applause]
and edward snowden
and um
if you don't have a third party option
uh then i would encourage you to just
write in chelsea manning or edward
snowden
let me talk a little bit about
what's coming
i think sanders made a disastrous
mistake i understand his logic
when shaman and i asked him
or you know encouraged him to run as an
independent he answered i don't want to
end up like ralph nader
and what he really said is i don't want
to take on the democratic party
establishment
and become a political pariah
because sanders has played i think a
very
or are built a very faustian bargain
with the democratic party he campaigned
for bill clinton in 92.
he campaigned for clinton in 96 after
nafta
after the destruction of our welfare
system
and remember under original
welfare guidelines 70
of the recipients were children
after the 1994 omnibus crime bill that
exploded the system of mass
incarceration that i want to address a
little bit at the end
the deregulation of the fcc that turned
the airwaves over to roughly a half
dozen corporations
all of this was clinton
night in 2004
sanders was calling on nader to suspend
his campaign
sanders has always served as a kind of
watchdog for the democratic party and in
return
they have not mounted a serious campaign
to unseat him in vermont
and he in turn has done everything he
can to stymie third party movements in
vermont
i think sanders honestly believed that
he had a chance
i think we are watching now
a legitimate
anger on the part of sanders and those
around him as they understand that the
game was fixed from the beginning
and yet i fear that sanders will do what
he says he's going to do
which is endorse the democratic nominee
and at that moment sanders becomes an
impediment to social change
if bernie sanders does not want to build
a third party movement
then we are going to have to build it
without it
and we are going to have to free
ourselves
from
this belief that we are going to make
serious social change within the
confines of a particular electoral cycle
we are going to have to begin to
organize
and recognize that what we are building
towards
maybe ten years away
when cerresa began it was polling four
percent
by the time cerresa took power it had a
majority within greece
we have to hold fast to that moral
imperative
we have to stand up and be willing to
defy the system we have to step outside
of the system
and the system will be ruthless
in terms of its response
but we are reaching a moment a
convergence
of deadly
environmental
degradation breakdown we're already
watching it
many of the
refugees and migrants that are streaming
into europe yes there's war but there's
also tremendous drought
in syria
and
this system
is incapable
of responding in a rational way
to the degradation of the environment
caused by the fossil fuel industry and
let me not forget the animal agriculture
industry
wall street has been
unleashed once again
with money that has been given by the
fed at roughly zero percent interest
and so at some point
we are going to see another financial
crisis
that may be twinned with
an ecological crisis
and at that point of breakdown
within a system that is incapable of
responding
except to further enrich and empower a
global corporate elite
you will have large segments of the
population we are also
we are witnessing this at the moment in
europe turning to these proto-fascist
forces that are embodied in figures like
trump
richard rorty in his book achieving our
country was the last book he wrote
warned that
the inability
of self-identified liberal elites to
respond to the suffering of the
underclass
while it continued to speak
in the language of diversity and
multiculturalism
was actually empowering the nativest
racist
homophobic forces that are gathering
around trump why
because they redefined empowerment
what did feminism become
not empowering oppressed women
the way andrea dworkin called us to do
but by having a woman president or a
woman's ceo
and
that lie which was perpetuated by
liberal elites because the assault on
people of color has been far more
draconian than it has been on the white
working class
allows demagogues like trump
to sell a message
to dispossessed whites that they
have been
disadvantaged
or disenfranchised
because
entitlements
have been given to other marginalized
groups
and the the lie of our liberal elite has
essentially come back
a kind of blowback against them
if hillary clinton
becomes president
a figure a political figure who embodies
everything
on each side of the political spectrum
we have come to detest
then you may get rid of trump
but you will vomit up
somebody even more vile
and the only way that we're going to be
able to break the back
of this rising proto-fascist movement
tied to the gun culture and the
christian right
is to build a viable left that holds
fast
to the moral imperative of defending the
interests of working men and women in
this country
and is willing to be pushed outside of
power for a certain
period of time
rather than dilute or give up that moral
imperative which is something by the way
that rosa luxemburg understood
and it's we who have to do it
and if we don't do it
then we are going to see ourselves slide
into a very
frightening form of despotism
one where a state or a system of
neoliberalism which has lost all
credibility
is forced to maintain power
by carrying out increasingly more
vicious
and brutal forms of violence
this is something hannah aaron
understood in origins of totalitarianism
when she wrote about the stateless which
is essentially what people of color in
marginal communities are stateless
they have no rights they have been taken
from them police serve as judge jury and
executioner
and i teach as you heard in a prison i
just finished
teaching
sheldon wolin's great work politics and
vision
to my class
94 percent of the people in our prison
system never had a trial
because the system is designed to deny
them a trial in fact
the students i teach who have the
longest sentences went to trial
and they were punished for it
because they stack charges against you
and then they barter like a poker game
but if you go to court all of those
charges
are arrayed against you and they have to
give you a longer sentence because they
use you as an example they say look
he went to trial or she went to trial
and that's the sentence they got so you
better take the sentence we're offering
you can understand the awful dynamics of
the corporate state by looking at what
it does to the most vulnerable among us
and the best place to do that is in a
prison where corporations have reached
their deadly tentacles down to every
facet of prison life
global tell link
which has taken over the phone services
and let's remember
the phone is the primary way that
children remain in contact with their
incarcerated parents is four to five
times higher than what we pay
commissary has been privatized
and prices have ratcheted upwards in new
jersey you make 28 dollars a month
for 40 hours a week it's neo-slavery
it's alive and well
and
prices are now beyond reach you're no
longer given shoes
in the state of new jersey you have to
spend forty five dollars for a pair of
reeboks if you send a money transfer
through jpay it's privatized so you send
twenty dollars you get a 495
service fee
on and on and on fees are now imposed on
you in prison uh for instance if you
have a bereavement visit to someone
who's dying or you visit a member of the
immediate family who's dead in 15
minutes you get you pay for the guards
the overtime it's nine hundred dollars
so
my students are getting out of prison
thousands of dollars in debt
and when they get out of prison and
thousands of dollars in debt
as ex-felons
they can't get jobs one because there
aren't any jobs and two because they're
demonized
and if they can't maintain those
payments they go right back into prison
and that's why that guy who got stopped
for a taillight runs
and is shot in the back
some people say the mass system of mass
incarceration doesn't work
no no they're wrong
it works just the way it's designed to
work
it works because we have created with
the loss of our manufacturing base and
the assault on our working class a group
of surplus labor
who do not they're brown and black
bodies do not
generate an income for corporations
until they are locked in cages where
they can generate forty or fifty
thousand dollars a year
and the students i teach understand
that reform is not going to become
from
state legislatures or from congress
because corrections corp of america and
global tel they've all got their
lobbyists they're writing the
legislation go on corrections corp of
america the largest pr for-profit prison
complex in the in the country and on the
website it says we are a good investment
because there are 67 percent recidivism
rate in the united states which is why
there are no programs vocational
educational any other programs
and they understand
as they have done and i will close with
this
that the only mechanism left is to carry
out nationwide work stoppages within
those prisons because no prison can
operate
unless you have prison labor and that is
an example for all of us
they just carried one out in alabama in
georgia on the anniversary of attica on
september 9th they're organizing a
nationwide prison stoppage and as they
have said over and over
don't go demonstrate in front of a
courthouse
when we
carry out that work stoppage come to the
parking lot of the prisons and stand
with us let us all follow their example
let us understand that we if we mobilize
and stand up and begin to disrupt this
system
we can take power back into our own
hands
and
eventually build
in the years ahead towards the
destruction
of the corporate state thank you
[Applause]
so i love chris but i don't know that i
agree with you about bernie sanders not
that he should have run separate because
uh i think he's done
an amazing thing within the democratic
party which is
get a lot of young people engaged and
educate millions and millions of
americans about the economic the
tremendous economic disparity in this
country
talk about issues of mass incarceration
to people who haven't heard that before
incorporate the issues that black lives
matter has brought to him
and also show their tremendous split in
the democratic party
and if bernie hadn't run you wouldn't
see
that there is on one side a democratic
party that's represented by hillary
clinton and wall street and the weapons
industries and all that's wrong in this
country and the other side are people
who really want to see the democratic
party represent their values and those
are values that bernie sanders is
standing for
so
raise your hand if you've worked on or
voted for bernie
raise your hand if you plan to vote for
hillary clinton
now you might see that's just a very
small sprinkling here um
raise your hand if you plan to vote for
jill stein
wow
raise your hand if you plan to vote for
gary johnson a libertarian
i uh-huh
uh raise your hand if you if you plan to
vote for donald trump
we got one gentleman over there one over
there
so
it's fascinating times in this country
it's a fascinating time to be with a
group like this
and it's a fascinating time to think
about the opportunities that we have now
and that we're going to have
next january
first i want to just summarize what
has happened to the peace movement under
obama now let's remember that obama came
to power because he beat hillary clinton
and he beat hillary clinton why
the iraq war the iraq war he was
perceived as a peace candidate and
that's how he became president
now let's give him a credit for a couple
of good things really good things that
have happened in these last seven plus
years
one is the iran nuclear deal
incredibly important done against great
odds
with the help of a lot of people in this
room i'm sure but going up against big
lobby groups like
aipac going up against israel going up
against a lot of powers that did not
want to see this go through and it won
and the other is cuba
let's recognize that obama did an
amazing job
opening up to cuba there's still a lot
to be done the embargo still exists
but let's recognize these are two
diplomatic successes that happened under
him his administration but also let's
not forget
they did not happen while hillary
clinton was secretary of state
they happened after hillary clinton left
and john kerry came in and acted more
like a diplomat
so those are two positive things that
have happened but there have been so
many bad things that have happened on
the par foreign policy front
let's remember that this piece president
as laura flanders said who got the nobel
peace prize
did not get us out of the wars of iraq
or afghanistan has bombed seven
countries at least iraq afghanistan
pakistan yemen somalia libya and syria
has not closed guantanamo as he promised
in fact instead of
closing guantanamo he would have been
embarrassed to put more prisoners into
guantanamo and his
answer was instead to use drones to just
kill people instead of capturing them
and imprisoning them and so he became
the
drone commander-in-chief
that has spread this horrendous
technology not only being used in the
united states but is spreading it to
many other countries around the world
he didn't close the over 800 military
bases we have overseas in fact has been
involved in building new bases
and in case anybody hasn't noticed all
of this militarism has not led to a
decrease in terrorist groups
has only led to a spread and a change of
name from things like al qaeda to the
islamic state
trump on the other hand is saying we got
to rebuild the military if i get elected
as if the military needs something like
more money
632 billion dollars the budget this year
obscene amount of money but that even
hides
other monies that are not considered
with the pentagon budget that if you put
them together like veterans affairs
money from the energy department that go
to nuclear weapons you and add all of
that together it's about a trillion
dollars
not only is it 54 percent of all of our
discretionary money but it's more money
than the rest of the world combined
we have the most grotesque military in
terms of our taxpayer dollars and guess
what
they can't win a war
and that's not because they're
underfunded it's because they're sent to
fight in unwinnable wars that we have to
get out of
[Applause]
let's not just blame it on barack obama
let's look at congress i live in
washington d.c now and unfortunately i
get to see it up close and raw when you
go into these congressional hearings and
you see these congress people from the
democrats and the republican side
falling over each other to give more
money to the pentagon than the pentagon
even asked for
and when the pentagon wants to close a
base here and there
congress says oh no you couldn't close
that base it's in my district it will
mean jobs
and when the pentagon says oh we don't
need those uh c17
planes anymore they're old they're not
useful the cargo planes
depend the congress says oh no we
couldn't possibly kill that program it
would mean 35 000 jobs and it would be
in my district
and of course the weapons manufacturers
know this game all too well it is their
game after all and they make the parts
of their weapons in as many
congressional districts as possible take
the most expensive weapon
uh
weapon in the history of the world the
f-35 made in pieces of it in every
single congressional district
and the weapons manufacturers then give
money to the congress people in those
districts so the congress keep people
keep pushing those weapons and the
congress people turn around and they
don't say of course oh we have to keep
these weapons going so i can get money
from my campaign instead they say
jobs jobs jobs
now what an insane way to have a jobs
program after all the military is
probably the only job creation program
we have in the united states
millions of people are employed in
active duty and reserve millions and
millions more for feeding the military
machine
and it is you know freed zakaria who's i
don't think you would call a socialist
he's a pretty mainstream economist on
cnn writes in the washington post he
calls the us military the largest
socialist economy in the world
he says it's cradle to grave socialism
you get your money you get your early
retirement you get your pension you get
health care for your entire life in your
family you get free housing you get
daycare you get
early retirement
you get goodies from movie theaters to
golf courses
it is indeed a jobs program
the former secretary of state robert
gates said i don't know if he was
boasting but he said there are more
members in the military marching bands
than they are in the entire state
department foreign service
an insane jobs program
making things
that make us unsafe
nothing we need to live
they don't make food they don't make
things for us to
wear to house ourselves they don't
provide infrastructure for us
nothing that we as consumers need
it's not even a good job creation
program if you look at the studies that
are done that showed when you put a
billion dollars into
uh providing jobs in the military you
get about 11 000 jobs if you put it into
education you'd get 29 000 jobs if you
put into anything else you would get
more jobs in fact i don't think they
counted this one but i would be pretty
sure if you took all that money and
dropped it from airplanes onto people
that they would create a lot more jobs
than the military would create
and it doesn't keep us safe
as i mentioned
there are more groups
that
would like to attack us than there were
before
isis is indeed a threat we just see
probably a terrorist attack on the plane
that came down going from france to
egypt
but let's remember what martin luther
king said at the time of the vietnam war
stands to today
the u.s is the largest purveyor of
violence in the world
and it's not only
the violence that the
u.s does directly
it's also the indirect violence because
our number one industrial export right
now is what
weapons and when your number one export
is weapons your number one global
marketing strategy is
endless war
so the us
sells weapons
lots and lots of weapons
and the number one purchaser of u.s
weapons is
no it's not israel
saudi arabia that's right
now think of how absurd and how obscene
this is
saudi arabia
a country that is number one in
beheadings in the world
a country that treats women
as minors their entire lives the only
country in the world where women are not
even allowed to drive
a country
that exports extremism
wahhabism
the distorted form of islam
that is exported around the world thanks
to the petrodollars that the saudis have
the saudis
who got involved in the internal affairs
of yemen
dropping bombs since march of last year
that have killed thousands of people
thousands of innocent people it have
take have taken that poor country of
yemen to the extreme of a humanitarian
crisis
with our weapons including cluster bombs
banned by the international community
that makes us complicit in war crimes
the saudis
are number one purchaser of weapons
the number one recipient
of us military money is
israel
another major human rights violator an
apartheid state
that on a daily basis
is oppressing the palestinian people
that state
is the number one recipient of our tax
dollars to the tune of three billion
dollars a year but that's not enough
for the israeli government in fact to
give their okay to the iran nuclear deal
they said you must sweeten this by
giving billions more to us
they wanted 5 billion obama said let's
go for 4 billion we're at 4 billion
negotiations still going on they want
more
this is where
our tax dollars go
this is where our weapons go
number two recipient military aid egypt
an extreme violator of human rights that
came to power through a coup
and it's not enough to sell those
weapons overseas
those weapons manufacturers those greedy
weapons manufacturers that pope francis
said have blood on their hands are also
looking for more internal markets they
look at the eighteen thousand police
departments in the united states and
they wanna sell their weapons and their
tanks their assault rifles their grenade
launchers
their drones they want to sell them
right here in our communities
to put down our own people particularly
poor people of color who are the victims
of the militarization of our police
forces
so here we have
a war economy out of control
a weapons
a military-industrial complex out of
control
and a peace movement that has been
incapable of striking fear into those in
power and moving them away from this
military-industrial complex so let's
recognize
that another place we have to put blame
for all of this is ourselves
for not being capable of building the
kind of movement that we need the
effective movement to put pressure
in the places where we need to put it
so now we look at the opportunities that
we have
well when obama came in our peace
movement died we had a strong peace
movement under bush obama came in people
said oh that peace president is going to
take care of it
he obviously didn't
well fool me once what did george bush
say
don't fool me again
i think one positive we can thing we can
say about a prospect of either a hillary
clinton or a donald trump presidency is
we will be not fooled again
there are no illusions that either
donald trump or hillary clinton are
going to be the peace presidents that we
need
there is no illusion
that they are going to get us out of the
endless wars
it's interesting that donald trump has
said a couple of interesting things
hasn't he
like that nato is obsolete
it's a great thing to say it certainly
is obsolete
he even said that he would talk to kim
jong-un of north korea
it's a positive thing to say
but let's not be fooled by donald trump
and remember at the heart of his
campaign is the islamophobia that he's
been preaching is the anti-immigrant
hatred that he has been preaching
he's even said that
he would bring back torture do whatever
you have to do
so donald trump is certainly not going
to be a peace president
but that gives us the opening
because people will be ready to protest
in fact just yesterday
in dc we protested at the opening of
hillary clinton's offices
and it was quite amusing because we went
as billionaires for hillary
we went as
with signs that says i make weapons i
love hillary
wall street loves hillary
and we stood outside as the mayor of
washington dc went in as different
officials went in
and they looked at us in kind of horror
as we
said we are the one percent we want
hillary for president
and uh
hillary hillary she's our gal take our
corporate money now
but the workers who were working for
those officials came out and said to us
thank you for being here we agree with
you a hundred percent
there are lots of people
that agree with us
and that are happy to see us protesting
already from the get-go
about hillary taking money from wall
street about hillary representing the
weapons industry about hillary taking 10
million dollars from the saudis as part
of her clinton foundation
these are things that have to be exposed
whether or not hillary clinton makes it
to the white house
we need these movements to pressure her
and the other thing we need to do
is build
an alternative to the war economy that
does not depend on who is in the white
house
and let me just
say on building this alternative economy
it's a couple of things and one is
happening already on a very wide scale
which is called the localized economy
i'm sure that many of you are part of it
instead of investing in the big banks
you invest in credit unions instead of
buying from factory farms you buy from
local farmers and organic farms instead
of buying from sweatshops you buy from
thrift stores instead of crass
consumption you reuse and you recycle
instead of buying a fracked oil
you buy your energy from solar and wind
this is the kind of economy we have to
build and from the war economy we have
to convert from the top down remember
conversion it was a big thing during the
70s and 80s we have to bring back the
whole idea of economic conversion where
we take these militaries and bases and
the factories and turn them into the
wind farms we need turn them into the
solar farms we need
instead of aegis destroyers that are
floating in the in the gulf we should
turn them into floating hospitals that
are going to take care of the refugees
and the people who are fleeing from the
wars that we start and the people who
are fleeing from the national natural
disasters from the climate crisis
this is what we need to turn the war
economy into and so i want to end by
saying
that we have
a tremendous opportunity
to show
that whether it's donald trump or
hillary clinton
they represent
an economy that's built on competition
we want one that's built on cooperation
instead of one that's built on constant
growth that destroys the future we want
one built on a sustainability instead of
one built on us versus them we want one
that's built on interconnectiveness
instead of one that judges success by
wealth like donald trump from casinos to
luxury hotels to how many golf courses
he's built we want ones that are
measured by healthy communities and
healthy ecosystems we want a vision that
engages and inspires and unites people
from the black lives matter movement the
immigrant rights movement the peace
movement the environmental movement the
labor rights the artists the students to
say
that we will only give peace a chance
when we challenge those in power and
replace the war economy with a local
peace economy thank you
uh friends
very happy to be here
some of us have been watching
mike is not on
can you hear me now
uh
i said
very glad to be here especially at this
time
because though we're talking about the
presidential candidates
uh
senator clinton and donald trump
what has really been exciting
watching what is going on from afar in
the united states has been these huge
mobilizations of young people
in favor of a candidate who talks of
socialism we can
now
and what i want to tell you is that this
movement of young people
which has
brought many more people together than
one could have imagined much larger than
any political campaign
i remember
involving
trying to go for it against the
mainstream
than at
any other time in recent american
history
the vietnam anti-vietnam war movement
didn't create a political side to it
even though martin luther king was
talking of running
as an alternative president not inside
the democratic party but together with
dr spock challenging the democratic
party that didn't happen one reason it
didn't happen as he was killed
so what we are witnessing is a very
interesting radicalization and it's a
radicalization of young people which is
is happening in most countries in europe
today
why
since the 2008 wall street crash
many people felt
especially those who had absolutely no
idea or no alternative view
that
somehow the governors of the world the
rulers of this world capitalist world
would manage to put something new in
place
that would give some
comfort
to the poor
and to the young who suffer even more on
many levels lack of housing
too much to pay for education
[Music]
and increasingly in some parts of europe
health as well so we have national
health services they're under very heavy
fire and attack from american health
corporations who are increasingly being
given
contracts by state-owned health services
as part of the neoliberal system
so in this situation it was felt that if
the elites who ruled the world
were a bit more rational they would
attempt to put in place something
different something that had been tried
before it didn't happen
and after a short wait
you had the emergence of new popular
movements
from the left
and you had the emergence of mass
movements from the right
this process began in different ways in
different countries but we can now see a
pattern as we can see in the united
states too
and this pattern is as follows
you have had the only country where you
don't have a far right movement is spain
uh
because the left have been very dominant
in spanish society in spanish political
culture but the conservative party in
that country the so-called popular party
has been moving further and further to
the right
itself
and all these movements
had one thing in common they developed
from the grassroots they developed often
in one part of the country either a
region
sicily in the case of the five-star
movement
madrid in the case of the occupation of
the squares in spain and then spread
rapidly from there to the rest of the
country
we've been witnessing now even as i
speak
the rise of a new popular movement
in france again a movement which pushes
all the
established political parties to one
side and says we don't trust you
or the intellectuals who serve these
parties we don't trust you keep away
move away and we want to unite with
trade unions to fight against the new
laws that the french socialist
government so-called is bringing and
putting onto the statute book to
restrict labor rights in france
and this movement comes together at
night
some of them work during the day others
think it's a nice time to do it to
occupy the night
la nuit de bu the night rising
and they meet
and increasingly this movement which
started in paris is spreading
and has spread to other parts of france
there have been clashes with the
riot police etc etc
in britain the radicalization took a
different form
much to everyone's surprise
something odd happened
and what happened was that in order to
reduce the power of the trade unions and
the labor movement inside the labour
party
the labor right was pushing
for a
a virtual primary system but different
that anyone who was a labor supporter
and paid three pounds
could join the labor party and
participate
in the election
for the leadership of this party that's
how it happened
they assumed that like in france this
would benefit the right
because people on the right generally
assume that most people are like them
in britain this turned out not to be the
case
once this rule came into effect
and one of the candidates was jeremy
corbyn
a long time socialist a long time
supporter of the campaign for nuclear
disarmament a long-time campaigner
against the wars
in the middle east a long-time defender
of palestinian rights who had said for
decades that the trident nuclear
missiles in britain should be got rid of
he said all this in his campaigning for
the labour party leadership
and this they had to broadcast this on
television
unlike here
they couldn't pick and choose because if
the other candidates were on he had to
be on and lots of young people who
hadn't heard these things before
never heard of them
and he said that one of the things he
would do if he was elected a leader of
the labour party would be to
renationalize the railway networks
would be to end privatization of
education and would be to end all fees
that students have been forced to pay
for higher education
[Applause]
within weeks
two hundred thousand people had paid
their three pounds and joined the labor
party
i didn't do it out of principle but
many of my friends did and they voted to
the astonishment of the media
which had been denouncing him as a crazy
as a loony as a not who could you know
living in a different world a dinosaur
well he got elected leader of the labour
party
and that has now created huge problems
within the labor party and between
corbyn and the establishment this is in
britain the so-called
motherland of democracy
that
a senior military general serving
general gave an interview to the sunday
times one of rupert murdoch's papers
saying that if corbyn was elected prime
minister of england there would be
mutinies in the army and they would
refuse to obey orders
that happened
another general appeared on a breakfast
time television show saying that the
decision not to ditch the trident
nuclear missiles was unacceptable would
weakens britain defenses and corbyn was
not suitable as a prime minister
so once a conservative
grundy was asked what the hell is going
on can't you control the army this is
unheard of in britain he said oh well
technically you know of course the queen
is the commander-in-chief of the army
so i wrote at the time that's fine then
we all want to live under a banana
monarchy
because that's what they're saying
so the campaign against corbyn has been
huge and so far
things
have been proceeding not too badly
attempts to force him to retreat on
trident have failed attempts to force
him to retreat on other things have so
far failed and his popularity is slowly
growing and attempts to remove him as
leader of the labour party opinion poll
after opinion poll shows if they did
that and he stood again he would get
larger majorities as leader
now
in spain
a mass popular movement podemos
organized itself as a loose party a
party movement a movement party not a
traditional party and came within two
percentage points of defeating the
traditional right-wing socialist party
in that country
i say this
very carefully and cautiously simply to
register that there is anger
on the streets and in people's homes and
this is the way they respond this is the
way this generation is responding
corbin in britain sanders
here
movements challenging social democracy
there
what are their demands effectively
if one is totally frank
what
these people are demanding from the
rulers and from the bankers who who run
this world is
a little bit of social democracy
not too much they're saying we won't ask
for too much
but we do want
a health system that is not privatized
we do want free education we want cheap
homes
and we want our railways taken back we
don't want all the utilities being
privatized in ireland there was a huge
struggle against water privatization
so in these movements by demanding
little they are attracting huge numbers
of people
and the question then comes
is the capitalist state in these
countries
prepared to accept a government elected
on the basis of these demands
the indications are not good
because what we are witnessing
effectively is a hollowing out of the
democratic process itself as
chris has been talking about
that they don't care anymore they don't
need to prove that they're democrats to
anyone
gone are the days of the cold war when
the idea of giving more space to
dissidents in the media was necessary to
show the communists were look we are
better than you
that's all gone they don't need to prove
it
and they feel they can do what they want
and when there's resistance they try
their initial reaction is to try and
crush it ideologically
saying you are putin's agents or you're
working for terrorism or you're doing
this or you're in the grip of islam by
the way
the country in europe which is the most
islamophobic much more so than the us is
france
horrific
absolutely horrific islamophobia
is
in in has infected a large chunk of
their intellectuals
when the kids in the banus the the
suburbs struggle
very few white organizations
off the left
come in support of them you can name
three four four intellectuals who defend
them
so islamic islamophobia is huge i was in
france before i came here
and whenever i was interviewed
the shock and horror
when they said
once at a public event not on like this
about five or six people said
and you now have a muslim mayor in
london
i said i know france is in the state of
shock
but we're in a state of shock because
he's a very right-wing mayor
he completely defends corporate
interests
he is completely opposed to what jeremy
corbyn stands for
and he is
cozying up to those who attacked him the
conservatives
so it's big for you that we have a
muslim mayor but we judge him not by his
skin color or his religion but by his
politics and by what he's going to do
that is our definition
[Applause]
because you know this is not a big deal
in in in in britain lots of members of
parliament not lots but a fair amount
are muslims of muslim origin a
conservative member
of the government cabinet the business
secretary no less is of muslim origin
the former chairperson of the
conservative party who resigned his
chairperson baroness varsi is a muslim
and they come like the new mayor from
humble backgrounds
you know their fathers were first
generation migrants
so it's a huge mistake to fall into the
trap of thinking that automatically
identity
is
the the politics of identity are
progressive sometimes they are as
obviously in black lives matter it's a
huge movement and a very welcome
movement and a movement which is broken
with all the opportunist black
politicians who hung on the coattails of
democratic democrat politicians that's
the most important thing about black
lives matter
but
the case of asian politicians
in europe is very different
very different so each each has to be
judged
according to their politics and what
they do
when they come to power
i just want to speak briefly
about which
media has already done very eloquently
about the state of the middle east
you know
this is a part of the world
that is was made into what it is after
the first world war
when the british and french armies went
in and created these small
states prior to this the middle east was
one area the arab world
and dominated by large cities under the
rule of the ottomans a very loose form
of rule by the way
so that you could go to school
in amman in jordan
you could go to as better school
secondary school in jerusalem
and you could get your university degree
in cairo or damascus
that's how that world used to function
then came the first world war and the
division of the middle east
the arab east
into little states and british civil
servants imperial civil servants used to
boast when asked how did you
draw the borders of iraq
and gertrude bell the civil servant in
question she said with a stick in the
sand
that's how we did
it did it
now we are witnessing
a new imperial process carried out by
this empire
whose citizens you all are
of
re-dividing
the middle east
and even even a more reactionary fashion
the invasion of iraq
what did it effectively do
by destroying the previous state
completely
something they didn't do in japan after
the second world war
something they didn't do in italy after
the second world war where 60 to 70
percent of fascist personnel in the
armed forces the police the judiciary
were retained
that they didn't even do fully
in germany in west germany
20 to 30 percent of the previous
personnel including the chiefs of the
intelligence services of the third reich
were retained by the united states to
fight the new cold war
but iraq completely different destroy
every single remnant of the old state
hand over power to shiite clerical
parties
and the result has been a disaster
a disaster nearly two million people
killed during the occupation of iraq
five million orphans
millions
of refugees in neighboring countries
and the war in iraq which we were told
was over
now more troops are being sent in to
fight isis which was created by the
first war in the in the first place
has gone on longer than the first world
war
longer than the second world war
the wars in afghanistan have gone on
longer than the last vietnam wars and
longer than the first and second world
wars
and you know when a country is occupied
however it's occupied
it has a deeply damaging effect on the
psyche of all its people regardless of
which religious faction they come from
and this is
now what is happening very few people
think that iraq can survive as a state
northern iraq the kurdish areas are
already an american israeli protectorate
and function as such
the iranians control shiite iraq the
saudis va through isis are trying to
control another part of iraq so the old
iraq
that remained united for good or for bad
since the first world war is about to be
divided again
syria
virtually the same thing is going on
there
because it is in the interests
of the empire and its close allies in
the region saudi arabia and israel
to divide them into little tiny
statelets
which can be controlled from outside
hence the destruction of the iraqi army
was considered vital it was the last
one of the last sovereign states
hence the destruction of syria
regardless of the absurdities or even
crimes of their rulers
has to be destroyed to destroy any
states which have
sovereignty
that is not permitted
in this day and age
afghanistan is a complete and utter mess
and as some of us argued when they first
went in this war is going to go into
pakistan and it has done wrecking the
social fabric of that country
and the drone attacks don't help
you know there was a remarkable
situation some years ago when the
iranian government
which was then considered a top-level
enemy government
um the a policeman
fighting against demonstrators which was
of course wrong accidentally killed a
young girl everyone admits it wasn't
deliberate as happens here all the time
it was an accident
obama emerged in the white house lawn
trying to squeeze out a tear
the american press went absolutely crazy
and that very and headlines and that
very same day in pakistan a drone attack
had killed 56 women and children when
they targeted a school by mistake
not a mention in most western newspapers
and it is these double standards that
drive
people mad and crazy and they want
revenge
it's not too difficult to understand why
many young muslims are going in this
direction
to be frank i'm surprised that there are
not more
one should be pleased there are not more
because given the extent of the
provocation
this is what they want to do
take revenge saying why why can't they
get away with killing us why shouldn't
we do the same
and of course one argues sometimes
against this when i'm confronted with it
but you know they they oh you people you
know you don't know how to fight etc etc
they say that
so
in such a situation
what is what are we going to do
well in the united states of course
those of you who live here know better
than me but again watching it from afar
i think the model
which medea has outlined local strength
building local grassroots i would add to
that
building political bases locally and on
a statewide level
before
expending our energies on a national
campaign that's what the left is capable
of doing the seattle example is a very
good one
when an excellent campaign
by
has resulted in her winning at the
elections again to the council despite
heavy democratic action against her and
the democrats trying to find a candidate
of color etc they want it's a good model
and one shouldn't sit back
one shouldn't
one shouldn't sit back and do nothing
and wait and that is the encouraging
thing i have to be honest with you when
i read some opinion poll which said that
30
of those who've been supporting bernie
have said that they will not under any
circumstances vote for hillary clinton
[Applause]
i think that's positive we live in a
very strange world a world of transition
in which the system that is in place is
not working everyone knows it's not
working
we know it's not working and those who
run the system know it's not working
because were it working even a tiny bit
then all these jokers in wall street the
bankers who stole money
half of them would be in prison
for what they did
that's what happened in a tiny little
place called iceland
you heard of iceland
they locked up most of the bankers
involved in deals like this and said you
go to prison
for stealing from your own people
that's what happened
but in the countries the large countries
none of this has taken place
and while on the subject of crime and
punishment
who has been punished for the war in
iraq
no one
i mean at the very least the united
states should offer one person to be
tried at the criminal court and that
could be dick cheney he'd be a popular
choice as war criminal
[Applause]
so laws that supposedly apply to others
do not apply to the united states
or its allies
and we're in a situation where it's
become virtually impossible for
mainstream parties and even some left
groups in left parties
only the italian parties are saying
withdrawal from nato we don't want to be
part of a military alliance
the labour party in britain isn't not
even corbyn
podemos isn't
saying we should quit nato so there are
lots of problems but this transition
also offers solutions
and these solutions are
in flux at the moment
there are left futures ahead
we see them you know in small ways in
different parts of the world though
there have been defeats here and there
but i think that we are also on the eve
of change in some shape or form
because the only other choice that
exists is that of the extreme right
which is much much stronger than us all
over western europe and north america
particularly in this country so we have
to do something we have to organize we
have to fight back and on every possible
level thank you
[Applause]
all right ladies and gentlemen thanks
thanks so much to our different
panelists who spoke we are going to do a
quick q a just a few questions
wait wait wait wait wait wait here we're
going to talk here just a little bit
right okay then we'll take like three
questions but they need to come right to
the front right here yes
okay
all right just while people are moving
around some quick comments um i had a
question for you chris about a
surveillance and what function you think
surveillance the surveillance state is
you know what function it's serving
particularly what function it is serving
visa via social movements
when your government watches you 24
hours a day
which our government is doing you cannot
use the word liberty that is the
relationship between a master and a
slave
all right hold on chris folks if you're
leaving please you you need to respect
the conversation is continuing so please
keep your conversation to outside the
hall
people at the back
pipe down
the factory and i should say i really am
only taking three questions and they're
not going to be from three white men
so
work it out amongst yourselves but i
don't see any women here the the problem
is that
the
corporate elites have created
a system
through militarized police the
evisceration of civil liberties
wholesale
surveillance
and this has already been completed in
marginal communities where rights have
essentially become privileges
and privileges as hannah aaron again
going back to erin
once rights become privileges in a
society then they can be taken away they
have created the perfect system of
wholesale surveillance and oppression
within communities of color which have
been effectively demonized by a
corporate media in a political class and
the consequence is that when the rest of
the sys the the population
becomes as restive
all of the mechanisms are in place at
the flick of a switch
so that we begin to suffer
the excesses of power
that we are culpable for because we did
not stand up
for
poor people of color when
the constitution was being shredded
in front of their face
a question for you medea one of the
aspects of this evening's panel has been
this question of humanity's peril
all this militarism all this capitalism
is putting humanity at peril you travel
um
i know it sounds sappy but i really
don't mean it i mean it in us in a in an
inspiringly useful way
where do you see humanity being
reclaimed or claimed in the context of
all of this
stories how do how do we rebuild our
humanity
i see it in the challenges that people
on the ground are
making to the oppression if you take the
example of israel the fact that
throughout the world there is this very
vibrant boycott divestment and sanctions
movement
is very inspiring and when you hear
hillary clinton say that
bds is evil and encourages students in
their campuses to fight against it i
think that just is going to inspire in
the fall a tremendous movement on our
campuses and i think our young people
are going to show us
how they can stand up against hillary
clinton's bullying
tarek i i have a media question but
before before that i have a question
about ireland i had the great pleasure
of being back in ireland for the first
time in many many years recently on
assignment for the for the nation
magazine and i was there for the 100th
anniversary of the so-called easter
rising 1916.
the first armed rebellion event against
colonial rule of the 20th century i
think um and what was so striking to me
was they've been it's 100 years right so
there have been many anniversaries um
in every instance until this one the
main thrust of the debate in ireland
anyway was
whether the uprising was justified
whether the civilian deaths could be
justified whether this had how long had
this delayed independence for the
southern state the irish state had
laid it on very heavy and the debate had
taken place in a very far i would say a
very conservative part of the of the
spectrum politically this time the
complete opposite
most people claiming the legacy not just
of the the rebels but of the left flank
of the rebels um particularly the james
conleys those who talked about socialism
of the um of anti-nationalism fighting
empire
you saw a lot of focus on the women
rebels who the ones at the same time
were nurses and doctors but also snipers
and fighters
my question to you is one of the things
i saw happening in ireland that was
exciting was just about every school
child had been asked to write their own
proclamation
for 2016
and what and been asked to consider what
would their republic
of the 21st century look like
i wonder to what
extent you see exercises like this
happening in the countries that you're
talking about um
or if you have any suggestions of how we
can go about really visualizing the
future that we want to make because
presumably we need to start making it
now
rather than waiting for someone to hand
it down to us
well the the irish situation
the 1916 anniversary took place at a
time where island is confronting a huge
economic crisis
and where the european union has imposed
on it a set of laws which do not allow
the irish to carry out any spending
without permission from brussels
including on culture and this is felt of
course all over the country secondly
the uh
european union rules insist on
privatization which is what their
economists have been advising the irish
the water privatization the defeat of it
by a mass popular movement brought about
the fall of the government which was
huge
secondly a number of radical left-wing
socialist candidates have been elected
for the first time
in northern ireland to the belfast
parliament a group called people before
profits two of their main campaigners
were elected to parliament likewise the
water campaigners and other radicals
have been elected into the parliament in
dublin and are playing a very good role
by refusing to take sides in the old
wars between the irish political parties
look ireland has a very special history
as you know laura and each country has
to rely
and
depend on its own history and the
precedence in these countries and bring
them back to life here of course you
know very few people uh talk
about the slave rebellions all of the
groups of small groups but important
groups of whites who helped these
rebellions in the past
in britain no one ever talks about the
examples of the english revolution after
all england was the first country to
execute its monarchs
uh
i remember saying this in australia just
as a throwaway line and the whole
audience started applauding and then i
remembered that maybe they did a lot of
irish people had had gone
gone i don't think they heard what you
said i think say it again our england
was the first kind of england was the
first country
which
decided
after a trial to execute the king
and
the french did it later of course and
then the russians followed
and in the
united states i think that event the
english revolution played a big part
because a lot of the puritans who'd come
to the states before the english
revolution did have certain radical
traditions many of them forgot those but
they existed and that must have played a
part in preventing those who wanted the
united states to become a monarchy
because there were some amongst the
founding fathers who were keen on that
and that was reduced so i think you know
to answer your question each country
has
elements in its past which are heroic as
the 1916 easter uprising and
they have to develop them it's a good
idea
all right let's take some questions from
the audience i said i would take three
and i wouldn't take them all from men so
let's do one
two first three
just kind of have to shout and i'll
restate your question
it has to have a question mark at the
end yeah
[Music]
but not only that what's happening in
syria 95
[Music]
so your question
what does the panel think of the slogan
drug
[Music]
all right so that's a good question what
does the panel think of the slogan drop
food not bombs air lifts to people under
siege in relation to syria medea i think
it's a great slogan we were just in
congress this week with those very signs
uh and i agree that we have to say to
our government that it is not doing its
part
to make sure humanitarian aid gets to
the besieged communities in syria and it
certainly is not doing its part to allow
syrian refugees into this country we
should be taking it over a hundred
thousand the goal of ten thousand is
ridiculous and we've only taken in one
thousand three hundred which is shameful
all right can you do as well with the
question mark at the end yes yes
what are the parallels between the
prison industrial complex and the
military industrial complex thank you
good shop question chris
going to enter any inner city school
and you can see that these kids
are being conditioned
for two routes
both of which
essentially ripped from their freedom
and that is the prison or the military
those are the options recruiters are all
over poor neighborhoods
and
when you are in
the
school-to-prison pipeline
you're surrounded by guards you're going
through metal detectors increasingly in
charter schools
you
are disciplined as if you were in the
military
and of course discipline inside a prison
replicates discipline inside military
structures
and so yes it's a very important
question
because with the loss of manufacturing
jobs
the rise of surplus labor the staggering
amounts of unemployment 50 percent for
black youth higher if we count
uh underemployment
um they are being
trained
to either be
cannon fodder or locked in cages
anybody else want to comment on that
no next question
we don't have one but come up here we'll
help you
go for it what's your question
i'll help
so the constitution set up public banks
all right so the constitution
the federal reserve
are is by the fighting bankers all right
i've got a recommendation for you
thank you
what do you think about about
reconstituting the public banks
and i would encourage you to take a look
at a very good episode of the laura
flanders show where we talked about
exactly that and democratizing the fed
so
so i agree that that's something that's
absolutely necessary in building a peace
economy and we have actually as code
pink a new peace economy program we have
sign up sheets that's been going around
here if you haven't had a chance to see
it please come up after and sign up so
we can work together to build public
banks uh to build public institutions
and to build the kind of localized
economy that will take the power away
from the corporations
tarek let me get you to wait to come in
on this as i understand it the labor
party under corbyn has actually pledged
some public money to these kinds of
initiatives worker cooperatives in
particular yeah
they they have done that but between
pledging them and winning an election
and coming to power
who knows what's going to happen you
know one has to be realistic about that
because he the the pledges corbyn has
made some of them are very huge that's
going to be a big fight to
re-nationalize the railway system in the
country which is a very popular demand
supported by between 60 and 80 percent
of the population and this has been the
case for many decades he's the first
political leader who said we're going to
do it the eu is going to fight him
saying it challenges some of the
competition rules in the eu
the
conservative party and half the
playwrights in his own party so on every
single thing there's going to be a huge
struggle and if it's just left to
parliament in debates in parliament it
won't get through anything you have to
have big mass movements
popular movements from below
like the movement that finally elected
him to be kept up to maintain support
without them i think it's going to be
difficult
all right i need to take a group
conscience here we had said three
questions shall i take three more
all right three more quick come on up
uh when germany gets a so-called bailout
when germany gives a bailout to greece
is that added to the principle
question
well it is and most of these bailouts
given to greece they are not bailouts
it's money given to greece so they can
pay back the interest on what they
borrowed before very little of that
money actually goes to the greek people
who are suffering real privations at the
moment it's i cannot even begin to
describe how awful the situation in
greece is when the greek people wanted
change 61 percent of them voted to break
with all these measures they
strengthened their government
unfortunately their government
capitulated to the european union
quickly i'm not sure if if anyone is in
the line wants to ask this question but
i want to make sure that we do get each
of you to respond just briefly to the
question of what is happening in latin
america right now
destabilization in argentina venezuela
brazil we haven't mentioned this so far
but i don't want to have the evening
close without getting there
well i think we have two
sort of associated phenomenon one is
that the state department i.e the united
states
has been trying to weaken destabilize
the bolivarian governments the
progressive governments in south america
ever since they came into office so that
is nothing new and they weren't able to
do it
and one reason why they are able to do
it as the decline in the price of basic
commodities i.e oil in the case of
venezuela has meant a huge
economic crisis in that country which
they haven't been able to tackle it's
not easy i mean though some of the good
advice was rejected uh similarly in
argentina so you have now
attempts to constitutional attempts to
topple
maduro before his term is over a
constitutional coup against
dilma rousseff in brazil and an
electoral victory for a total and
complete row in argentina argentina is
well on the way to becoming the first
hedge fund republic
in south america thank you all right
quick question from you
just
as capitalism emerged
from feudalism
right now there are workers producer
cooperatives
that are emerging question the problem
is the system and the system is
capitalism
all the reforms
your question all the movements
my question is
do you see that the approach
of workers
producer
self-organized cooperatives
on the model of mondragon in the basque
country
that really this is the future because
it confronts and it deals with the issue
of the system all right great question
which is capitalism question mark thank
you
so much
just to work with cooperatives help
so i think this has a lot to do with the
last uh
question about the public banks because
you need public banks to be able to give
out loans to worker cooperatives because
the commercial banks are not going to do
that kind of thing
and you need worker cooperatives to have
a decentralized power and i think when i
talked about a localized peace economy
that's what we're talking about is new
ways of organizing so thank you for
bringing that up and once again if you
want to work with us at code pink come
and talk to us jody evans right here is
in charge of our local peace economy
campaign and we need more folks to work
with us great
and i would just say exactly these kinds
of topics of worker democracy of uh
transformation of the workplace and of
relations of production and distribution
and consumption are the sorts of things
we talk about on a weekly basis on the
laura flanders show so check it out all
right the three of you come on up here
are our friend with the co-op question
modeled a fascinating initiative okay
quick
i'm gonna hold this you're gonna come up
with a great question oh
well the first thing i want to say is
in this society right now
a white male
is not necessarily white and they are
not necessarily male
and i don't think the white males that
are here are the ones that we are
against
so in the interest of unity
i want the white males to know
that they are equal to what i would have
to say now my other question is ninety
percent of my students
are pro
bernie sanders
i got the feeling that he was written
off yet i've never seen hillary clinton
as threatened as she is right now
and she even just said
that she would consider bernie sanders
as her vice president
so
what i'm saying is what i'm saying is
why is there a feeling
whether you're pro or against bernie
sanders that he's to be sort of written
off
to be in a position of power and control
even if you don't agree with everything
he says all right good question about
bernie come on your question and then
we'll get answers from our panelists
we're going to get answers
i'm just curious what we all think about
how do we get beyond uh
geopolitics of separation and
competition into like a unified
planetary synergy
and like what is beyond this paradigm of
political struggle on the global scale
all right and the last one
yes this is on the subject of
surveillance
people talk about using encryption to
protect our data but the nsa has methods
of surveillance that you can't encrypt
they have a grid of space satellites
with interferometry this 3d
we want to know what we could do to get
this stopped and get people covering
this issue and nsa whistleblower william
benny and russell theis support us and
we have videos of them on the site
bacness victims
so three sort of macro questions there
one about
what are we writing off bernie sanders
given what sort of a threat he seems to
be posing to hillary clinton
two what do we do to get down to a more
harmonically convergent sphere and and
plane
and three what do we do about the
possibility that we're being spied on
let me address the issue of bernie
sanders because i i don't write bernie
sanders off in fact with shama
uh she and i encourage bernie to run
as an independent and shama now has a
petition up what's the what's the called
shama
it uh is it there's a petition she has
up calling on bernie to run as an
independent
so no far from writing sanders off
i think that
both sharma and i
were concerned from the beginning
that he would be strangled by the
democratic establishment as he has been
and that we have to begin to build and
if you know we are encouraging sanders
to revoke given the fact that the
election was stolen from him revoke his
commitment to support clinton and with
his
agenda and and the money that he's
raised and the enthusiasm that he's
raised step outside the system and begin
to build a movement so i'm not writing
sanders off
[Applause]
following up on that i think uh i was uh
reading the washington post the other
day and it had a screaming headline that
said
the majority of millennials have a more
favorable view of socialism than
capitalism
that is quite astounding and that is
thanks to bernie sanders so bernie
sanders has done something amazing for a
young generation that treats this old
curmudgeon like a rock star
and they are taking in what he said and
they are going to use it in different
ways and that is to build a different
system in this country so nobody i don't
think here is writing off bernie sanders
we say thank you bernie for the opening
that you've given to a lot of people
especially the young generation
and let's be inspired by that and
hopeful that they are going to say
socialism is the way we want to go and
we're going to build it in a 21st
century that fits what we want in the
united states and that's very exciting
i think harmonic the you know harmony
and convergence is left for you tarek
now i want to say a few things about
bernie too
because the campaign's having a huge
impact globally people can't believe
what they are watching
on the web
not on their television screens but
certainly on the web is these huge
mobilizations and
it would be a big tragedy for the united
states if these mobilizations simply
disappeared
once hillary gets it
i think she has got it there's no point
in pretending she hasn't i mean if she
didn't i'd be delighted but i think she
has so the big question is
you build a movement an important
movement
a democratic movement a movement which
talks about socialism about dealing with
the banks but we can't
for the future
limit this movement to the electoral
cycle
of u.s politics something needs to be
done and the it it will happen if that's
what the kids want to happen and i note
that the young generation the today's
generation has no problem with dinosaurs
either here you have bernie or in
britain where we have jeremy corbyn both
of them are virtually the same age and
that is not what's affecting people what
is attracting them is the ideas which
they are putting forward which many
people respond to the question is how to
take these movements further as for the
synergy i mean
look
the
the bolivarians in south america tried
very hard and while
ugo chavez was alive succeeded to a
certain extent when the oil prices were
right he said
any government in south america which
wants to build a health service which
wants to build cheap houses for workers
and the poor
uh
which
wants to create doctors in its own
society there is a blank check
here you are
go and do it
and it things were moving in that
direction
with various bodies economic bodies
being formed etc that is now in a state
of collapse tragically but the ideas are
still there and people won't forget them
that's the important thing to remember
lots of people remember the good things
that happened and the good things that
were done and when the mood is right
they will come back to them and one of
these was to try and unite the south
american continent
both against the big brother in the
north and
and for the interests of the people in
the south and they may i mean simon
bolivar couldn't do it he said it's like
plowing the sea
but chavez got a few steps beyond
bolivar and that and they actually began
to do it so you know one one can't give
up simply because they're going through
a bad period
medea wanted to say one more i just
wanted to add one other thing that
bernie sanders has done
it has before bernie sanders been
just impossible for any leading
candidates to talk about palestine in a
way that is in any way sympathetic and
the fact that bernie sanders
has brought that up and says that's
going to be a fight in the democratic
platform he's not going to say what a
lot of us would like to say which has
cut off every cent to that repressive
apartheid regime he's going to say we
want an even-handed approach but you
know that is miles ahead of what we have
had
final comment chris
i think the power of sanders
is that
he
gave or verbalized the reality around us
in a way that other politicians
including barack obama have not done
economic inequality
that's a fact it's a fact that
most americans can see every day
and that is a huge breakthrough
on the other hand
i think sanders
and his voting record backs this up
doesn't understand
that you cannot be a socialist
unless you are an anti-imperialist
that imperialism
is the mechanism that creates
centralized control
that serves the dictates
of empire at the expense of the
citizenry
and that it is the
not just militarism in terms of as medea
pointed out
that is financially disemboweling the
country
but it is also
and both parties are guilty of this
creating an ideology one where we deify
the military we deify
systems of internal security
and the consequence of that is the kind
of proto-fascism
that we are seeing now in trump rallies
and
i'm looking for a candidate
that
and and of course it's political suicide
as george mcgovern found out or earlier
henry wallace found out but i'm looking
for a radical candidate that understands
that the first step
on the road to socialism
is the destruction of american
imperialism
chris hedges medea benjamin tarek ali
thank you all three
[Applause]
have a great forum everybody see you
tomorrow bright and early
so
booktv.org
yeah
hi all
good afternoon
it's good to have you here thanks for
coming in
this is another this is now discussion
and that is a production of the kepler's
literary foundation i'm angie coiro and
i'm a member of the events team here at
kepler's
keplers.org keplers.com two different
animals keplers.org is the nonprofit
foundation that works to bring
literature and enlightenment and
enhancement of life to everyone here and
out to the schools and in various other
venues across the uh the peninsula so
thank you for all your support just by
virtue of being here by virtue of being
the audience you are supporting klf and
thank you for that i i have to ask
is it someone in the audience who has
the bumper sticker downstairs i work and
pay taxes so the wealthy don't have to
yeah
you are starting us off on a very good
note
so uh i'm going to ask you to please
turn down your cell phones you don't
have to turn them off in fact if you'd
like to tweet we are at kepler's
and it is time to introduce our guest
we're going to start doing that with a
quick review of some headlines
purdue pharma is the company that
produces oxycontin and that is a key
player in our opioid price crisis in
fact
purdue pharma is being sued by 1 000
different entities cities towns
individuals
for their contribution to our opioid
crisis well the billionaire ex-president
of purdue pharma is now working to
profit on the other side of that mess he
is helping to patent a formula that will
help wean people off oxycontin
another headline some 2000 prison
inmates were paid a dollar an hour to
fight the california wildfires now the
san francisco chronicle has been
covering the construction of a playhouse
by unpaid san quentin prisoners for a
high-ranking prison executive who now is
reportedly out of a job
so there are a lot of news stories that
you can read that might strike new
chords with you once you read america
the farewell tour in one chapter after
another chris hedges documents the ills
that are taking the country down hate
heroin sadism magical thinking those are
just a few
then he shows us how to build it back up
but he doesn't sugarcoat that it's going
to be hard he says and many of us will
fall by the wayside if we choose to do
that work and he doesn't want us to go
into that blind
chris hedges is a journalist a columnist
a tv show host and a presbyterian
minister he teaches in prison his
writing has won multiple awards
including a shared pulitzer prize for
the new york times where he worked for
15 years as a foreign correspondent
america the farewell tour is his 14th
book please welcome chris hedges
thank you you're welcome while we get
chris miked up i want to tell you that
you have some white note cards they are
either in your hands or you're sitting
on them at this point
those are um for you to ask questions
and make some comments for us
i would ask that you keep them concise
and well written and on point and during
our one hour discussion we'll get to as
many of those questions and comments as
we can the way those get up here is
after you write them out hold them up
andrew or jean will pick those up and
get them on up to me so we'll kind of
wrap them in as we go along and we're
going to test your mic how okay how's
that
oh you got to do more than
that perfection of a kind was what he
was after and the poetry invented was
very easy to understand auden how's that
and scott says thumbs up
let's dive in
i have to tell you
reading the book i got about two
chapters in
and i
found it so relentless and i knew
there'd be more hope in the end i
cheated ahead to the last chapter and
knowing that there's stuff we can do
knowing that everything isn't all over i
found it easier to go back and read the
rest
so i just wonder about if you knew that
the
the tone can be intimidating
well i think on purpose
because
i i i don't share
the american cultures mania for hope and
i think that comes out of spending two
decades as a work correspondent we made
a very cold
calculated assessment of what the
weapons systems were around us and we
responded we also understood that so
many of our victories were purik
uh during the war i covered the war in
el salvador for five years
we would often the roads would be
blocked after the salvadoran military
committed a massacre we would have to
walk in often at great danger this was
also true
especially during the war in kosovo
indeed the serb snipers often fired on
the journalists who walked in
and there was
a sense
or a feeling of euphoria when we were
able to document the atrocities that
these atrocities that they had sought to
hide from public view
these lives that they had extinguished
and hoped would never be recorded
i was able to put on the front page of
the new york times but it didn't mean
that i wasn't going to wake up tomorrow
and have to do it all over again indeed
that usually was the pattern
coupled with the fact
that that work was very dangerous i mean
many of the
people i worked with the photographers
and war reporters
over those two decades including my
closest friend
uh kurt shork are are dead they didn't
make it
and i i think that that that that
baseline and it comes somewhat out of my
education
as a seminarian steeped in calvin and
niebuhr and i i not only have a dark
view of humanity i have a tragic view of
life
um which is very much at odds with the
obsessive positive thinking of a
consumer society and a commercial
culture
but i think it actually
gives you a kind of armor
to cope
with what's happening
and just from climate
change alone
things are very bleak
and dangerous
and i i think the greatest or perhaps
hardest existential crisis
of our time is to
grasp
reality and yet
resist anyway
but i i just am not willing and i don't
think it's beneficial to give people
exits
from how bleak it is both in terms of
what we're doing to the biosphere
and this concentration of
wealth in the hands of
the global elite uh
where it's not and it's of course not
just economic ramifications 70 percent
of this country is living paycheck to
paycheck
um
but of course it has political
consequences as carl poyani writes in
the great transformation which is his
book on the nature of unfettered
unregulated capitalism
he said that you create a mafia economy
but eventually you create a mafia
political system which is of course what
the trump white house is
i of course i'm going to get into the
guts of the book but i i'm taking
the way the world has informed your view
of it
and the fact that you're a father
and i i wonder how you have those two
things together that the world is bleak
and let's not do artificial hope
so
what is it that you offer your children
to
let them get up in the morning
well i have younger children and older
children i'm pretty frank with the older
children and and
the the younger children are certainly
aware of climate change um
but one doesn't pummel a ten-year-old
right with uh
you know the the uh
details of the
melting of the polar ice caps and the
consequences of
going beyond two percent
celsius and feedback loops and um
but i'm very worried and and i'm i'm
increasingly worried in a culture
that unplugs itself from the real world
uh and i and i see within our commercial
media
uh
a kind of walking away from responsible
journalism for
endless carnival endless burlesque which
is what cnn is
i mean i come out of the old newspaper
world and the idea that uh repeated
reports or interviews with a former porn
star and a lawyer who wants to run for
president on a former reality television
star who was
in the white i mean this is this is uh
it's just pt barnum all the time
uh and there are extremely serious
things happening around us
uh including the debacles that we are
engaged in in the middle east 17 years
of futile and endless war that just go
unspoken uh
we don't we don't even have a rational
discussion
in the mainstream uh
about the nature of corporate capitalism
and how it works
uh and so
um
you know as soon as you say corporate
capitalism i think there's a large part
of the
populist who just said
you know
crazy liberal old hippie whatever
i think i think that the very
phraseologist i'm neither a liberal or a
hippie
but that's the impression that's i think
that's an honest
when people say you know corporate
capitalism i don't know if you say
corporate capitalism to the
the farm families in the town in upstate
new york where i grew up whose farms
have
all been foreclosed upon and who have
suffered a rash of suicides and
deep economic distress they know very
well what corporate capitalism is if you
go to anderson indiana as i do in this
book and you talk to the old
uaw workers who'd been in the gm plants
that are now down in monterey mexico
paying mexican workers three dollars an
hour without benefits
and their town has become a wasteland
like all de-industrialized
former manufacturing centers in the
united states they get corporate
capitalism uh
i i i think the victims get it
well let's let's start there let's start
with anderson and it's emblematic of any
number of cities sure
it used to be based in
factory work or you know um
that kind of everybody goes to work
together there's a union right um it's a
company town completely anderson was
yeah and when the company goes away
you're left with people who essentially
have nothing
these are some that and the lace factory
that went out you know which we can talk
about i opened scramble
to cities scranton pennsylvania
when you talk to the people in those
towns
what do they say about having lost and
i'm picking a point to start on what do
they say about having lost their unions
that they might have expected to protect
them from all this
well once you pass nafta
you
open the door for gm to do what they did
which is to move their plants overseas
right um that had nothing to do with the
unions
um i mean the the corporate managers
will often seek to blame the unions
uh because
they were paying union workers 25 30 an
hour
uh and providing benefits god forbid
yeah and a pension
and you could
support a family on one salary and you
could send your kids to college and you
could own a home
um
and they they will argue quite correctly
that of course it's
far cheaper for them to produce
vehicles in monterey
um but that's not the fault of the union
i mean the compensation packages
for these corporate executives
has reached utterly obscene proportions
uh in the 1950s i think the ratio was
30 to 1 or 50 to 1 in terms of ceo
worker
now it's in the hundreds 500 600
uh to one
uh
and
so the the the staggering income
inequality which is the worst
in american history it is now
outstripped
the so-called gilded age
has not just economic consequences
but political consequences
as every political theorist going back
to aristotle understood
and and it it i and i i go back to the
former yugoslavia i was the balkan
bureau chief for the new york times
the economic collapse of yugoslavia
vomited up these
political monstrosities like radovan
karitic slobodan milosevic franio tujman
who like trump
ridiculed in this with the same kind of
vulgarity
and also i should mention the same
incitement to violence and the same
racism
uh
they
ridiculed an established elite that was
ineffectual
in terms of dealing with the legitimate
grievances and suffering
of the mass of the population
and that that is that was trump's
success
in that however crude and
and
repugnant he was and is
he nevertheless
expressed
a rage and i would say a legitimate rage
on the part of in particular the white
working class
towards the elites like the jeb bush's
or the
bill and hillary clinton's
who betrayed them
uh and uh and they did betray them why
did that message resonate when we're
talking about a guy with whom you know
everything is gilded
everything you know uh everything is
very high end everything is all about
you know this is very i wouldn't say at
high end and say it's tacky this okay
it's very tacky yes it is tacky but i
guess i'm i'm trying to understand why a
messenger like that is someone you would
be you would believe about the week
because
in in moments of political distress this
opens the door for demagogues and con
artists
and all of those political figures i
just named in yugoslavia were demagogues
and con artists
they tell people what they want to hear
um the the the power of trump as matt
taibbi i think is pointed out correctly
is that
reality for him is delivered through a
television screen
and in that sense he's completely
connected with unfortunately a large
percentage of the american public
for whom the television screen is the
lens by which they interpret and
understand the world around them
so
trump
like all celebrities
has a manufactured personality we know
from his business record that he was
pretty much of a disaster as a business
person a multiple bankruptcies
he defrauded his investors he
refused to pay his contractors
especially in atlantic city many of whom
went bankrupt
um
and so he goes on a reality television
show and they create this fictional
persona of him as this business
titan
and then he uses this fictional persona
to sell himself
to the presidency
but all of this comes through television
all of this comes through make-believe
uh and with the ability to deliver these
electronic
hallucinations in 24-hour streams and
hand-held devices we are as
uh i think it was
uh neil gabler wrote probably the most
illusioned
society on the planet
um because all of this is constructed
it's not
real it's interesting to me that we're
already getting a slew of questions
about how to talk to people with whom
you don't have for example i remember
during the election there was a slew of
people who said how can you look at
trump and not get his business record
how can you look and not get his
inauthenticity
and that's to me where the divide really
started making itself evident
betw between the people who could have
benefited
by looking at the corporate
underpinnings of everything that was
happening instead
you had trump and we didn't understand
why they didn't look at trump the way
we did a lot of people are asking about
how you talk to someone who's that far
apart from well i would i would say that
those who
have
are part of
the
uh in particular white elite who live in
places like menlo park have the luxury
of uh dismissing trump
but when you're desperate
when the established elites of the two
main political parties have lied to you
successively over years
and betrayed you
and destroyed your family and destroyed
your community and extinguished your
hope
and thrust you into despair the highest
i write about suicide in the book the
highest rates of suicide in the united
states are middle-aged white men
so
the the the lies of the
republican and democratic party
establishment were
slicker were more carefully packaged
were delivered in a tone of
reasonableness
um
and the lies of a trump are crude and
vulgar
uh
but
there is a desperation i mean this is
you know as you know i traveled all over
the country for this from
utah to scranton to you know
at one point actually literally
sitting around a bonfire in upstate new
york
near binghamton with white hate groups
praying
that that none of them would google me
[Laughter]
which didn't always work because you had
your contact information exposed you've
been attacked from a lot of angles you
know
people talking about
whether you were
um engaging in plagiarism i mean there
are a lot of persons well let's just if
you want to bring that up i mean the
person who made that charge is the head
of anarchists for trump well that's what
i'm saying is that you were
i mean you can find anything you want on
the internet i understood but that's
part of what i'm saying is that to if
you have someone who is speaking
something that they don't want to hear
they being anyone that you're that
you're
exposing
then there are ways to go after you
personally right well disturb the
message sure and and the new york times
just reviewed this novel and the whole
column is about me and uh largely
and not at all about the novel and they
did to me just what the new yorker did
to glenn greenwald which is to paint you
as messianic and angry
um and and that becomes a way to
um
marginalize if not delegitimize what it
is you're writing about and i would just
for the record i admire glenn quite a
bit so
that's that's standard and
uh i i think that part of the reason
that uh
an establishment liberal
organization like the new yorker goes
after someone like greenwald or
would go after someone like me is
because we call out the
hypocrisy of the liberal class
and
you end up not having many friends at
all
when you are critiquing
the establishment whether the
establishment the establishment
uh
the democratic or the republican
establishment and i you know i'm i'm
quite fierce on both
so
um that you know inevitably makes you a
very lonely isolated and often uh uh
reviled figure but that's the price of
at least from my perspective that's the
price of trying to be as honest
as you can and in that sense you know
uh you know i i went to harvard divinity
school but i lived in a housing project
in roxbury
uh for two and a half years uh actually
across the street from the mission maine
mission extension housing project and
ran a church there and i always say that
uh the two and a half years i lived in
roxbury has learned when i learned to
really hate liberals
um
all of those people at harvard who liked
the poor but didn't like the smell of
the poor who sat around talking about
empowering people they never met so
um this which we're going back to your
earlier question this knee-jerk response
that you're a liberal
uh or
you know that that that just becomes a
way
to
uh attach
a particular
label in this case completely incorrect
a particular label to you
uh and then use that label to
uh essentially shut down what it is you
have to say and that's a very standard
technique i mean when i denounced the
war in iraq uh for which i had a clash
with my then employer the new york times
um the wall street journal ran an
editorial calling me a liberal
pacifist
well i'm not a pacifist i was in
sarajevo during the war
uh when we were being hit with two
thousand shells a day
and uh
i like everyone else in sarajevo
understood that uh if you did not man
the trench system it was literally a
trench system around the city
uh the serbs would break through and
slaughter
a third of the population and push the
rest into displacement in refugee camps
uh and we that wasn't conjecture that's
what they did in the arena valley it's
what they did in vukovar
it doesn't save you from the poison of
violence but i mean this was just a way
to
and i mean i'd also been the middle east
bureau chief for the new york times
uh for sev and speak arabic and was
there seven years these were informed
decisions but by using those labels
it becomes a way to dismiss
what it is you have to say
that's in line with one of our audience
questions is there ever a place or
necessity for violence even to protect
our children from disastrous leadership
um there are moments when uh there are
forces and the serb forces surrounding
sarivo would be a good example of that
where those forces seek the annihilation
of
of potentially your family and yourself
and um
you are faced with that awful choice of
having to pick up a weapon
um and i my first book war is a force
that gives us meaning
is an attempt to
uh explain the culture of war
um
and
the danger of
using violence i mean the people who
first organized the defenses in sarajevo
uh were largely came out of the criminal
class they were people who had access to
weapons and a pension for violence and
when they weren't holding back
the serbs
they were looting the apartments of the
ethnic serbs who had remained behind and
in some cases not only stealing
everything they had but killing them um
that's the the dark
world you
are sucked into once you
employ
violence even in a supposedly just
cause um
but yes i mean i i covered the war in el
salvador uh in there were peaceful huge
peaceful marches in san salvador the
capital and
the
uh military
and the police set up machine guns on
the roofs and fired into the crowds well
that made peaceful
resistance impossible and we got this
tragic civil war
but it's always the oppressor who
determines the
response
and when the oppressor or those in power
refuse over a long period of time
to
to heed the cries of the oppressed and
they use harsher and harsher forms of
control than they provoke counter
violence
let's go into some of the areas of
escape and decay that you look at and
i'm picking out some of the chapter
headings to
give us an entree
heroin work sadism hate gambling and
then of course chapter seven last
chapter we'll talk about freedom
heroin is an interesting one because it
starts out as something of an escape
and then of course once you're addicted
there you are we've seen so much death
deaths have almost doubled
since 2006
and
i think that it might be
a surprise to some people to look at
that and see corporate underpinnings
there can you explain how corporations
are there and in fact if you'd like to
respond to that story i mentioned
about what the purdue pharma exec is
doing now which is well this is the
sackler family who are the largest drug
pushers in the country
and have made billions off of
uh addicting uh
hundreds of thousands if not a few
million americans
uh by pushing heroin derivatives
oxycontin
uh and setting up doctor doctors are
complicit and setting up pill mills
where do these pill mills where are they
set up well they're not set up in menlo
park and they're not set up in princeton
where i live
they are set up in places
that uh
are suffering deep economic dislocation
and despair of course
um southern west virginia
um
and uh these
pills were given i mean you had a back
ache suddenly you got a heroin
derivative you got oxygen uh percocet
and uh they're highly addictive
uh and they're expensive and eventually
you turn to heroin because it's cheap
six dollars a bag
um and the bags are now off in lace with
fentanyl
uh and they kill you
um
so
uh which oddly makes the heroin more
attractive to some of the consumers
if you have a death from fentanyl then
you have a group of addicts you're going
to now they're i wrote about in the book
yeah which surprised me like
they all
uh it's death by marketing so somebody
dies of an overdose and everybody wants
that these bags have names you know
i don't know red star or something so
they all want it because i mean it's
just kind of nuts but it shows you how
perverse that world is and heroin uh
there's a book dreamland uh forget the
author it's quite good which i read um
and in there he writes about how that
arrow the molecules of hair it doesn't
it can't wash it out of your body so a
year later you can uh feel as if you're
dope sick even though you've been clean
for a year
it's a really pernicious drug
and that's what makes what the sackler
family did through purdue pharma so
criminal
there's an interesting point you make
about that is when rats get an extra
dose of
opioids they increase their play with
each other they even tickle each other
when rodents are allowed to socialize
free freely rather than remain isolated
in steel cages they voluntarily avoid
the opiate-laden bottle hanging from the
bars of their cage they've already got
enough yeah how what does that tell us
about the humans well it tells us that
our you know and the model for this book
is really durkheim's study of suicide
the breakdown of social bonds durkheim
found led to
a desire for self-annihilation
and as durkheim understood that lust to
commit death
is at its core about self-annihilation
so you see it in these nihilistic mass
shootings i write about dylan roof of
course and quote because dylann roof
left a written record
so
i mean it's it's a i think a very
revealing study for what's happened the
social decay
uh what durkheim calls the anime
uh that has propelled people into
activities that are
deeply self-destructive so the book is
about those pathologies i mean gambling
for instance and i didn't know a lot
about it
um until
uh i spent time in the trump taj mahal
before trump even announced he was going
to be president uh and and and it was it
had gone through several bankruptcies uh
there were rodents literally running
across the dining room floors uh you
went into the bathrooms and they had
plastic bags over the urinals of the
toilets saying out of order the
the tiles were falling off the there was
mold in the ceiling uh many of the rooms
have been mothballed it was kind of a
wonderful image for what he's going to
do to the country
um
and
uh
and what was and and uh shulled a
a professor at nyu wrote addicted by
design a very fine book where she worked
with the industry about how
eighty percent of gambling is done on
slots and these slots replicate the kind
of zombie like state that one gets when
they
take
uh a depressant like heroin
um
people it's called time on device in the
and the way they monitor these people i
mean many of the tactics in terms of uh
building profiles uh that now the
security and surveillance state
and thank you google and facebook i
should say for complicit in this uh
build on about us were pioneered within
the
casino industry because they wanted to i
mean they did they built projections as
to how
much addicted gamblers would actually
spend
during their lifetimes
you know they could trace when they
would get frustrated they would show up
and give them free coupons while they're
sitting at that slot machine
uh to to keep them um and and
gambling addicts actually have the
highest rates of attempted suicide or
suicide of any addiction so but but it
replicates
the many other
forms of addiction which are really
about
unplugging yourself from
uh
from the world around you because
reality has become so difficult to bear
there was only one place in the book
that i was reading that i i i felt in it
a strong disagreement with you
when you were talking about prostitution
and you interviewed some women who are
activist against prostitution you also
interviewed some women who were frankly
victimized by prostitution the only
thing that rang
wrong to me
is the dismissing of women who say
that they are voluntarily making a
living and okay with being
in prostitution with okay with being
paid for sex
and the difficulty i had with that
was there was well the women who are
saying that don't realize they've been
victimized they don't realize that
psychology that's going on and i feel
women are told an awful lot that they're
wrong about the truth they express about
themselves
that when they state their reality
someone said well if you were if you
were more keyed in you understand that
what you're saying isn't true that was
the only thing that hit me wrong
well
first of all statistically we know that
most of the women who engage in and i'm
actually writing about a very extreme
form of prostitution i'm writing about
the bdsm community
out of kink.com in san francisco which
is torture i mean there's just no other
way around it i took classes
at
kink.com
sitting in a basement room with a bunch
of doms you know
kind of dweeby guys dressed in black um
and we know statistically that a huge
percentage of these women were sexually
abused often as children
i've interviewed enough of them and i my
longest chapter in empire of illusion is
on the porn industry to know that it was
economic
distress
that pushed them
into this industry also it's the ptsd
when i first started interviewing
uh women who had been in the porn
industry i remember the first interview
i did and they started speaking i
instantly recognized the ptsd that i
carried from 20 years of war
so
um
that's the first point the second point
is that the vast majority of women who
are are prostituted uh or it's not uh
what was that movie pretty woman with
julia roberts it's not like that right
they're they're usually women of color
uh and if you go to europe they're all
uh women of color or women from eastern
europe
who are
trafficked
and um
i
i do break with the left i mean you talk
about being a liberal i mean this is not
a liberal belief but it's one that i
hold actually that
um
we have to
decriminalize
the act of prostitution i.e the women
are not the criminals
but the traffickers and the
uh the pimps and you know these figures
are should be criminals and customers
and customers and john so
i think that's a very rational model i
think it's compassionate to the women
but the point is that we should be
building a society whereby that is not
the only economic alternative a woman
has and as you know i quote rachel moran
who was a prostituted woman in ireland
for many years
and she's quite graphic about describing
having sex with repugnant men who she
doesn't want to have and she calls it
being raped for a living
and
yes there are very vocal voices in the
quote unquote sex industry
but i would encourage people to look at
where the money's coming from
that funds that industry
most of the women that i sought out who
had been in the prostitution industry or
in the porn industry
they don't want to talk
you know they suffer the same kind of
trauma well it's not the same but a
similar form of trauma that those of us
who come out of war suffered
uh and so
uh i i would also add you know as a war
correspondent the only thing that wars
produce in greater number
than corpses are prostitutes
these are
widows women
girls in refugee camps i mean
prostitution was endemic in every war
that i covered
and it gets into the
commodification of human beings you know
that that of course the natural world is
a commodity that we're destroying but
also under corporate capitalism human
beings or commodities that we exploit uh
and as somebody who sees with
intrinsically in every form of life
uh
and not just human life
the sacred um i i this is just something
i can't i can't support
let's move over to the alt-right and the
alt light
and how one serves essentially as an
entree to the other
right so
trump is kind of the alt-light
uh you know there's good people on both
sides
uh
but it funnels people into the alt-right
which is kind of
that spectral figure of stephen miller
um in the white house uh
so
it it
normalizes and maybe legitimizes
um
racism
uh
as we said before incitement to violence
it has the
effect of demonizing
the vulnerable
and in proto-fascist or fascist
societies it's the vulnerable who pay
i mean the whole idea that 11 million
undocumented workers most of whom are
from mexico and central america
are at full for the economic
uh decline of the united states is
patently absurd
um
but as things devolve and we are headed
for another economic crisis the new york
times four or five days ago got a very
chilling editorial that said this and
they had an article
a week ago about how the fracking
industry would be the next.bomb.com
crash because it's on projected profits
it's not actually on
in fact the fracking industry loses
tremendous amounts of money so
uh and in a moment of instability
uh
then
you have already mainstreamed
islamophobia you've already mainstreamed
racism
attacks against poor people of color
and
the elites and this goes back to
yugoslavia will then use and or direct
that rage
towards
the vulnerable
and allow this
incoherent uh anger
to express itself through violence
uh as if these people are somehow
responsible and and you know the the one
of the things that disturbs me there are
two things that disturb me
uh particularly about trump one is
uh
the
poisoning of civil discourse
but also
that that characteristic which i write
about in the book of the permanent lie
which is different all politicians lie i
was a reporter they all lie there's no
exception obama lies clinton they all
lie
but
clinton
who
sold us nafta
uh and sold us nafta by promising that
it would mean
millions more good american jobs doesn't
continue
to tell us that nafta produced millions
of good american jobs
the permanent lie which trump engages in
and which
all demagogues all dictators all
totalitarian systems engage in
is
spouted regardless of reality reality
doesn't the you know we're just watching
how they fix the
pictures you know we had the park
service edit the pictures of the
inauguration reality doesn't make
doesn't and that's extremely dangerous
hannah aaron writes about it in origins
of totalitarianism because it's what you
see in front of you is being denied
by the megaphone
and it creates a kind of schizophrenia
um and unfortunately
we are a society awash in fake news
which doesn't come out of moscow it
comes out of fox news it comes out of
breitbart it comes out of these i mean
the whole idea that fox news is now
considered a legitimate
journalistic enterprise
is staggering and frightening while
britain treats fox news as unreliable
and not a legitimate news of course it's
unreliable and it's a piece it's
propaganda
well you're on rt which is a russian
news outlet yes
it could be taken as a conflict of
interest to say that you know it's not a
fake news machine
well i didn't say russia wasn't a fake
news machine all governments
i don't trust any government including
the russian government i mean i'm not
discriminating here
but
if you are an anti-capitalist and an
anti-imperialist critic
you have nowhere to go anymore
and so
i i know very well why rt allows my show
it's the same reason voice of america
put vaslav havel
on during the communist regime hovel who
i was in the magic lantern theater every
night in prague during the velvet
revolution with hovel was a socialist he
didn't support american imperialist
adventurism in vietnam or anywhere else
but he had nowhere else to go
and this is about the corruption
of our media platforms and in
particularly our
public television
if you went back to the 1960s on public
television
you could see
malcolm x
noam chomsky our greatest intellectual
who's been
completely uh blacklisted yes uh howard
zinn james baldwin
and now because they've slashed the
funding because pbs is dependent on
corporate donations like npr it's
uh
uh the it's this constrictor of
acceptable opinion and of course you
know the koch brothers are big investors
in public broadcasting now of course
they're destroying the crown jewel of
american democracy which is called
public education
and
uh
that
constricture
has
left us without a vocabulary to
understand the class warfare that is
being waged against us
by a global corporate oligarchic and i
would argue criminal class
um and that's by intent
and so
the the elites understand that and this
is across the political spectrum there
nobody's buying their ideology of global
capitalism globalization neoliberalism
whatever you want to call it nobody's
buying it they're not buying it on the
right they're not buying on the left
and so the elites have have gone after
over the last year
those critics
of
corporate capitalism imperialism who
already exist on the margins of the
internet and how have they done that
well
google facebook have imposed algorithms
that block those people out so i write a
column every monday for the website
truthdig run by robert shearer one of
the great american journalists former
editor of ramparts and
uh and so it they have what they call
impressions so if you'd gone to google
and you typed uh let's say imperialism
and i had recently written a story on
imperialism or column then it would be
there with other now it's not there and
so we've watched at truthdig alone
the referrals from imperialism uh
decline over the last 12 months from 700
000 to below 200 000
as they perfect the algorithms all of
the sites black agenda report
counter punch alternet which has lost 63
percent of its traffic world socialist
website 80 something percent of its
traffic couple that would net the
abolition of net neutrality and what
they've done
is
uh further push
their critics
uh from
reaching the public
because
they're they have no credibility left
and that loss of credibility is what led
to the insurgency in the democratic
party with sanders and it's what led to
the insurgency
in the republican party with trump
uh and the elites are kind of scrambling
you have to tip your hat though to the
right because when they started being
blackballed from some of the websites
there was a strong unified response that
said you're shadow banning us you're
taking our right to speak it was
an impressive display of a unified
message whether it was accurate or not
they knew how to play that well there
was a unified message among those of us
on the left but we don't have any money
we don't have the most retrograde forces
of american capitalism like the mercers
bankrolling us
i have to poke at you a little bit
because i i looked at your section about
taking money from foundations and how
much that can endanger a message
but then in your acknowledgements you
thanked a foundation
well i did i thank the wallace action
fund
um which is about as left wing as you
can get number one and number two
probably about the only foundation that
would and they didn't they gave me
twenty five thousand dollars for a
research assistant we're not talking
about
what i wasn't wallowing in cash
you haven't cashed that soros check have
you
no source wouldn't give me money
uh let's talk about in fact you were
talking about the politicians and some
of the changes that have been coming
within the republican democratic party
folks in the audience are asking what do
we make of the rise of populism and
democratic socialism and you actually
say in the book that even though there's
some encouraging people coming up they
still will be compromised because
they're politicians
sure every politician's compromised i
mean that's the poison of power and
that's why movements are absolutely
vital
and our movements the movements that
protected the american working class
have been destroyed in particular labor
unions
we we go back and look at the history of
the united states
and the united states was founded as a
closed system for male
aristocratic slave holding elites
and it has been a long fight since the
founding of our country
to open up democratic space and many
americans have paid with it paid for it
with their lives
we had hundreds of american workers
murdered
by gun thugs uh pinkertons baldwin felt
state militias state police like
pennsylvania who were called the
pennsylvania cossacks
um
and they
gave us uh the eight hour work day
they ended child labor the minimum wage
and
we saw it in the struggle for civil
rights by african americans we saw it
with the suffrages um it's been a battle
and those movements
uh have quite consciously been targeted
and destroyed
um
we saw the powell memo in 1971 the
attack on the free enterprise system
where
uh the business interests
uh
reacted to what the political scientist
samuel huntington called the excess of
democracy
um
by
uh
making war
uh and by seizing control of the the
press
the major political parties academia
uh i mean go into an economics
department in any uh major university
and find me a marxist economist
i'm not a marxist actually but mark's
analysis of capital
is probably unsurpassed i don't buy a
solution which is i think utopian
uh
so
um
the wolf's radio program is very good
for economics yeah uh he's great
and
uh and and that analysis is almost
impossible to hear
uh certainly within the mainstream it is
impossible to hear right he's on
pacifica naturally yeah yeah
i've been on a show
um
let's talk about
trying to decide who it is that we can
partner with if we're going to save the
country if we're going to form alliances
uh you talked about the industrial areas
foundation which i had not heard of
before that's the old sololinsky
foundation
yes
and you're talking about people who come
together who may not otherwise merge on
thoughts they're sure you know um people
who come out of churches going with
people who are atheists but they all
recognize
a common need well that's the point and
and you know i i'm very
opposed to writing off as irredeemable
or deplorable trump supporters
i've been in you know in anderson
most of these old uaw workers they voted
for sanders but in the general election
they voted for trump
they weren't going to vote for clinton
not after nafta
impossible
and
uh maybe it comes from
my stock of a small town maine where
most of my relatives held
political views which were pretty
repugnant and drove around literally
with gun racks and but but it gave me a
window into their struggles
um
and
the only way that we're going to advance
is to build coalitions
around
major economic issues i mean if you went
into a walmart and said i'm here to
organize i mean walmart the
uh
the
walmart family the waltons would never
allow you to even get in walmart i mean
there's the great union-busting
corporation of america but if you could
get into a walmart and said we're here
to organize for 15
minimum wage
you would certainly have people of
various political persuasions who
would join you in that cause and i think
with that uh we have to i i am very
critical as you know of the politics of
multiculturalism and
uh identity politics divorced from
economic justice
uh and i think that you know there was i
think it was lord salisbury who said
there's no there's no
uh there's no permanent alliances only
permanent power
or certainly was how sololinsky worked
in chicago
we have to organize around issues
that affect the lives of working men and
women and the poor
uh and
uh you know who they voted for if they
voted
uh
you know whatever i mean i think we have
a right to ask
them to respect everyone around them
um
uh
but we're only going to build
significant change by making these
alliances not falling into the trap of
the class
divide by splitting the working classes
uh along
uh
uh racial
uh
you know or ideological lines that
serves the interests of of the oligarchs
doesn't that turn a little bit
problematic i'm thinking specifically of
when bernie sanders was on the trail and
there were some black lives matter
activists who got up at one of his
rallies and said you're not listening
we're being shot in the street you can
talk about giving us more jobs you can
talk about you know making more money
available to us right now we're being
killed and need to focus on that
and i think that when you put the
blanket of identity politics on that
it can sound
especially from a white guy
kind of just i don't look at the black
lives matter movement as identity
politics at all forgive me i
misunderstood that i i i'm talking about
uh places like princeton where i teach
you because when you said racism i
thought you just well
no i'm i'm strong i write in the book
i'm a strong supporter of the last
chapter of the black lives mate
uh and in fact a matter of fact
interview activists from ferguson who i
admire immensely yes um no they're
responding to
police terror police murder
which happens in marginal communities
every single day in this country
and they have done so with immense
courage
and i will also add that i found bernie
sanders especially at the beginning of
his campaign tone deaf on the issue of
race and racial violence i teach in a
prison so
i'm uh you know i i see up close
uh what we have done to poor people of
color
our system of mass incarceration
uh which is one of the great human
rights violations of the industrial
world 25 of the world's prison
population we are five percent of the
world's prison population 94 of these
people never even had a jury trial this
is about social control
it is about
uh
and and we saw it and clinton you know
go back to the 1994 omnibus crime bill
where he pumped 300 uh
a million dollars into the prison system
uh expanded the prison population from
about seven hundred thousand to two
million
um
you you left
de-industrialized pockets uh there was
no hope for them to make a living within
the legal economy
um
they're not producing money for the
corporations on the streets of these
industrial wastelands but you lock them
in a cage and they can produce fifty or
sixty thousand dollars a year for the
prison contractors for our mark which
runs the food service for global tell
link which
uh has these horrible four to five times
uh what our phone rates are and and
that's makes me extremely uh angry
because for
children the only way they can have
contact with their parents incarcerated
parents through the telephone uh the
privatization of uh medical services uh
um jpeg money transfer there it's a
billion billions
in terms of
predatory activity and dostoyevsky says
if you want to understand the heart of a
society
look in their prisons look what they do
to the most vulnerable
and now we have almost a million
prisoners who work for for-profit
corporations and there are cities and
counties that tell prisons if you build
here we'll keep the cages full yeah well
they do they and they do keep and their
lobbyists pass laws uh to keep
recidivism rates over sixty percent
um you know people say the system
doesn't work that's wrong the system
works exactly the way it's designed to
work and we just uh have had
this prison
work stoppage commissary boycott even
hunger strikes within the system because
they fully understand uh that the only
way to end slavery and we're talking
about states like georgia where people
work 40 hours a week for nothing or they
work for 20 cents an hour
is to stop being a slave because if you
if you paid the minimum wage within
prisons and you don't have to under the
13th amendment the prison system would
not be sustainable it would just be
economically too costly to sustain so
you look at marginal communities you've
stripped people of their rights you
engage in police terror
and they replicate the condition of the
stateless which hannah aaron writes
about and she said the danger is that
when you have a a section of your
society who can be stripped of their
rights in essence rights become
privileges
then in a moment of unrest or
instability you have both a legal and a
physical mechanism by which everyone can
be stripped of their rights and so
uh
i mean just from a kind of human point
of view uh i'm incensed at what we do to
the poor and in particular poor people
of color but also as somebody who has
covered disintegrating societies
uh i'm frightened uh by the
normalization
including lethal police force i mean an
average of 3.3 americans almost all of
whom are unarmed are murdered by police
in the streets of our city every day uh
and if you think
it won't affect us then you don't know
anything about history right
you quote malcolm x i found this to be a
very interesting quote don't run around
trying to make friends with someone
who's depriving you of your rights
they're not your friends no they're your
enemies treat them like that fight them
and you'll get your freedom after you
get your freedom your enemy will respect
you i say that with no hate i don't have
hate in me i don't have any hate i've
got some sense i'm not going to let
anyone who hates me tell me to love him
reason that's particularly intriguing is
we talk about
the corporate
the elite the people who have all the
power and all the money
benefiting when we fight amongst
ourselves when the lower classes fight
amongst themselves
and it's easy to look at the people who
want to ban abortion who are doing the
preppers and anticipate that you know
they're going to have to shoot everyone
it's easy to look at them and say that's
the person who hates me that's the
person who i don't want to be friends
with so make that distinction for us
with malcolm x's quote well malcolm
understood the nature of power
and
uh
you know i do come out of
a divinity school background
and power is the problem and so
uh when people wield power
to carry out acts of radical evil
when they seek to extinguish life and
they are
through the fossil fuel industry seeking
to extinguish life for all of us and our
children
then
um
one has to react exactly the way malcolm
pointed out
um
but
i i admire malcolm x quite a bit and uh
i i think malcolm was uh like martin
luther king
one of our great prophets
uh and uh
um i mean malcolm wrote about white
southerners
and he actually had a great quote where
he said uh you know i'd rather have a
white southerner call me the n-word than
deal with a white liberal
um
a malcolm got power completely as did
king you know and and when king
moved on at the end of the civil rights
movement towards economic justice
those white liberals walked out on him
he was all alone
because yes they could handle
desegregation
but as king and malcolm understood there
would never be racial justice in this
country
until there was economic justice
which
means reparations
um and the inability on the part of the
white ruling elites
to face
the
monstrous
crime against humanity that they carried
out in order to enrich this country both
against native americans and
african-americans
has
created
the mythical version of america and
american virtues and american
innocence
that is embodied in
the face of donald trump
i want to go back to the fact that so
many of our audience members are asking
about how you talk to people with whom
you have opposing views and i'm thinking
about the person that you interviewed in
the book whose view of i can imagine
what he'd say about reparations but
the the way that black people portray
how many people get attacked that
there's actually more black on white
crime um that
people who didn't own slaves or slaves
were happy slaves were sad when their
masters died
and i mean that was dylann roof but
but it's an attitude that's out there i
mean this is how would you subtracting
dylann roof how would you talk to
someone
when you're trying to explain for
example reparations where you're trying
to talk about the generational loss with
something well you you can't speak to
people who are
not uh engaged in the real world
i spent two years writing a book on the
christian right called american fascists
the christian right
and the war on american i didn't
actually use the word fascist lightly i
look at them as christian heretics they
have fused the iconography and
language of the christian religion
with uh the iconography and language of
the state which is fascism for me
they are not about love they are about
hate um they are biblical
they are selective literalists they
don't actually know the bible i mean
when i was with them i was always
upfront about where i came from and as
soon as they realized that i grew up in
the church my father was a presbyterian
minister and i was a graduate of harvard
they never wanted to talk about the
bible with me they were too frightened
uh because they only know what they were
fed that buttressed
their peculiar ideology
so you're never going to argue someone
like that out of creationism it isn't
going to happen and the reason is
because the real world the world out
there the world uh where magic jesus
wasn't watching out for them almost
destroyed them and the stories in that
book
are also heartbreaking
uh and they and i was moved by them so
your substance abuse domestic abuse
sexual abuse
uh unemployment evictions i mean their
lives were just
uh ripped apart
by the disintegration of
their communities their families
and the economic
uh
blockages that prevented them from uh
reaching their hopes and aspirations
and i came at the end of that book to
the conclusion
that we're not going we're not going to
argue them out of any of that
um
the only way to blunt that movement
which i wrote that book 10 years ago
which has now gotten worse because these
christian fascists are rapidly filling
the ideological vacuum around donald
trump
is to reintegrate them into the economy
and so you ask how to speak to them i
sat for hours
and interviewed them about their lives
about what they suffered about what they
endured about and and those stories
engendered in me a very real and
legitimate empathy and they felt it and
the other thing is i never
ever and this comes out of being a
reporter for many years
i i'm always completely honest
with the people i interview i never
pretend to be something i'm not
i never use a pseudonym
and
when i did the christian right they knew
i came out of the liberal church they
knew i went to harvard divinity school
and i think that when you have that kind
of honesty coupled with the capacity for
empathy
you can actually have
meaningful conversations
uh and what was interesting is that
there were people in that book on the
christian right
whose world view was almost
diametrically opposed to mine but who
who
who afterwards contacted me because i
had told their stories with compassion
and respect
and so i think that when you ask how we
speak to them we speak to them about
their suffering
and
we empathize with that suffering
and that is the start of a relationship
and we grasp that they have retreated
into a form of magical thinking out of
despair
and that trying to dissuade them of that
magical thinking rips down the last
protective cover they have
and so
um
i didn't pretend that i believed in
creationism and yet i didn't try and
argue them out of the idea that in six
days god created all living beings
including t-rex who was in the garden of
eden with adam and eve which you know
they believe i mean and if you go to the
creationist museum in peterborough
kentucky they have a t-rex with a saddle
on it
and uh
you know it's funny in here but when
you're sitting there with 40 people and
believe it it's not funny it's chilling
and the guide is saying well i know you
all wonder why t-rex
had such big teeth it's because adam and
eve used t-rex to open the coconuts
but that shows you how how
uh how they've disengaged with
the real world and
that is
anthropologists call it crisis cults you
saw with a ghost dance in 1890
that is a characteristic of every
society none of us are immune from it
uh but it is a symptom of a society in
deep deep distress
i didn't realize until i read your book
that there are silicon valley preppers
that even at the highest point people
are preparing for that let's not get
started on silicon valley
the great great great enabler of the
security and surveillance state
[Laughter]
actually we're too short on the time but
we promised we would get into some of
your last ch
enjoyed this from one of the audience
members okay i haven't read the last
chapter of the book what can be done
okay we're getting into that talk about
burdock house
so
i have to regain communities that have
been destroyed
to pit power against power we have to
build alternative systems that sever us
from the tentacles of corporate power um
we have to turn off our electronic
hallucinations
um
you know if you are sitting alone in
your room furiously writing on your
computer
screen
um you know some diatribe against
state authority
you are
doing just what the state wants which is
sitting alone in your room in front of a
computer screen
we have to build relationships the only
way relationships can be built and
that's face to face
um
the fact that i had real relationships
with members of the christian not the
leaders who are you know the these
people who run these mega churches they
they are
they're all like trump back people say
how can the christian right
you know a lie with trump and that gives
the christian right a morality it
doesn't have these mega church pastors i
mean even in terms of sexual
proclivities they're doing things trump
never dreamed of uh
so and they're making money off of
people's despair which is how trump made
his money so
uh they're complete they're they're two
p's in a pod they're the same they're
they're
um but the fact that i could have
relationships and what we have to build
those relationships and that comes with
listening
it comes with empathy
um that doesn't mean that
you know
you know i was quite upfront if they
made a particular comment about a racial
group or homosexuals i i didn't let it
pass
but it doesn't mean you can't have if we
don't rebuild those relationships and if
we don't rebuild structures to pit power
against power
then in the next financial crash which
is coming
um
and and moment of instability
um they will play us in a very
frightening way i mean trump is not a
product of just our decayed political
system
boris johnson orbon and hungary it's
happening throughout
the industrialized world where the
wreckage of neoliberalism
has destroyed
has concentrated wealth in the hands of
the oligarchic class and destroyed
democratic institutions and we are
watching betsy devos destroy
public education and why
because the department of education
spends 63
uh
billion dollars a year on education and
the hedge funds want it
and they're going to get it
uh i mean the pillage won't stop until
we make them stop
burdock house burdock house is an
example of that former cap kids in their
20s former catholic workers they buy an
old warehouse for 25 000
they recon
recondition it refurbish it to have
rooms uh in the backyard they hold it
was i found it quite moving uh people
these kids trapped in these
low-wage menial
uh you know deadening jobs
uh come and read poetry one of the guys
i interviewed quite a talented blues
musician was playing blues and and look
that we have to get in touch with those
non-rational forces that the
technological society seeks to diminish
or extinguish
what are those forces beauty
truth
grief
a search for meaning the struggle with
our own mortality
this is what makes a complete human
being and it's why the technocratic
state makes war on the humanities and
culture
and and it you know the buddhists say
you can memorize as many sutras as you
want it will never make you wise and we
have to recover wisdom
and the capacity for transcendence
the understanding that there are human
lives and
systems of life
that have an intrinsic value beyond a
monetary value
and that and in as pauliani says that
are sacred
and and the society that the consumer
society the technocratic society
at its core
has made war on the sacred and our only
hope is to recover it
um
because it it it gives us a sense of
self our place in the universe and most
importantly it connects us
and and that atomization that alienation
that enemy that isolation
is not only deadening to our souls
and thrusting us into despair but is an
effective political technique to keep us
captive
last question the messiness of democracy
with all its paralysis and reverses
keeps revolution
alive and vibrant
you want to expound on that
sure because uh this is
uh karl poppers understanding that in an
open society you have mechanisms by
which piecemeal and incremental reform
is possible
the new deal you have the collapse of
capitalism roosevelt says
look if the private sector can't create
jobs the government has to create jobs
he created 12 million jobs social
security
and
when that capacity for um
change
is
becomes calcified as it has become
in our corporate state
then
uh
you you redirect when you redirect all
of the the wealth and the systems of
power to a cabal in this case a
corporate cabal
you leave behind uh
the majority of your population
to fester
and to
express in very self-destructive ways
the pathologies that i write about in
this book
and
you know what i fear
is that this time around when capitalism
goes down
we won't have the progressive party the
old cio and independent press
uh labor unions you know wobblies we
won't have any of that
and you know in the 1930s europe went
one way italy and germany spain and we
went another
uh and
and i i just see especially with the
rhetoric
uh coming out of the white house and the
rise of these trump minimes and places
like florida
uh you know
and and the transformation of the
republican party into a kind of uh party
or built around a personality cult
um
uh i worry that we will swing we have
the potential to swing
to a kind of
corporate-backed
christianized
fascism
on that hopeful note
thank you thank you very much
it's been such a pleasure thank you
thank you for that and if you have your
books and would like to have them signed
they're going to be signed right back
that away by the staff sign so if you'll
uh give chris just a moment for andrew
to get him over to that table where
you'll be signed and then take your
place in line and to get your book
signed thank you so much for coming
[Applause]